thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
okay guys it's that lovely selfie time
hey one side level hello to your fans
hurry up we're about to go live so I'll
just hide here Tanya be fine yeah the
action is coming up welcome to the
casket cup under one minute now for
Hikaru and wow what a move Ali razor
look at him he's biting his sweatshirt
he doesn't know what to do eight minutes
and 59 seconds beaten by one second
could you have swapped Queenstown
immediately
Magnus has had no struggles against a
car over the board he should be happy
we have a winner Magnus Carlson takes it
he wins the air things Monsters the very
first event he's training
oh wait
oh my God
oh and
we see a reaction Magnus
oh no hey Cara not come over here is the
winner of the chessable Masters Fabiano
caruana resigns what an Armageddon game
by Hikaru
happy favorites on their last strike two
will be eliminated a clash of
generations and a big grudge match all
of that on the menu for today and to
break it all down in the studio vamasa
David Howell
let's go
we started with eight players we're down
to six James what impressed you the most
definitely a Norbeck taking out Fabiano
come on the kid is very strong rapid
champion and also farrugia taking out
the big doggy color
it was a day full of surprises hikaru's
quick exit from the Chaska cup left us
all shot but it feels like he never got
started David what went wrong well just
everything went wrong for Hikaru he
wasn't spotting tactics he wasn't as
quick as he usually is and he came up
against players who were determined to
take risks to beat him it was a tough
time but in the end those who won they
deserved it 100 an online chest Hikaru
Nakamura is the man to be and it was
alireza farusha who got the job done now
alireza on day one was shaky he went
down to world number 171 Dimitri kolars
and then takes down world number five
Hikaru Nakamura Daniel how do you
explain that
you don't you just don't explain it
that's just the way these tournaments
work olly Reza was shaking on day one it
was shaky at times on day two against
Hikaru but you really can't overstate
the amount of confidence that you get
from defeating hikarnak or because it
does only get easier from there although
the way Notre bug is playing I don't
know if that's true oh wow it was an
action-packed there and it had us on the
edge of our seats take a look
this is chaos and it's bullet chest now
no checks right now for black unless you
trade the Queens then the knight's still
in trouble and black could easily lose
I guess he's not made it I think the
bishop takes up four he's bluffing here
Nakamura Bishop takes up and you run oh
and you take it oh
out
will Fabi here just struggling to
survive the next few moves you mentioned
fancy he's even fancier this guy's on
another planet yeah yeah look at this a
fork you pretty much have to capture
this white Rook now's the Black Brook
the blockade is eliminated and so
accurate it's crazy all right C6 it's on
the board he gives off his Knight and
this is he resigns and Noddy back after
such the lead in his match the wooden's
fighting for his life and this one the
computer says it's winning yes but that
is irrelevant if you put on the wrong
Square it might just be a draw can he
hide his King big question decisive
question here six seconds for Jordan
I'm still predicting an Armageddon in
this one it's so hard to find a safe
spot for the king playing on seconds
Queen B5 check but now black gets
another tempo for his Pawn oh my
goodness
zero
six no way for white to promote oh this
hers Jordan's only thinking about one
thing and that's repetition we have the
result you ordered see the relief on his
face wow has clinched it
and with that this is where we are going
into day three of the chess cake cup
these are our brackets we see that
alireza Fairuza took down Hikaru
Nakamura and also Fabiano caruana was
knocked down by not a bag of disa Trump
we will have the Winner's final later
today but we start with the losers
quarter final bracket now while it was
the end of the road for Hikaru Nakamura
the other American Grandmaster world
number six Fabiano caruana he is a
bronze medalist at the world rapid
Championship he's fresh out of a win in
the grantchester event fabulous
performance in the chassis bull masters
this is what makes him an absolute Beast
[Applause]
foreign
carwana famously had a 7 out of 7 start
in the 2014 sink Full Cup he also
challenged Magnus Carlson for the 2018
World Chess Championship title how does
a player get there you might ask for
five out of caruana it is feared opening
preparation he is a theoretician like no
other in this 2016 game from the London
chess classic Fabiana Carr wanted them
trade how deep his opening preparation
can go with the white piece against
Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru sacrifices a
knight temporarily with Knight takes G4
after Fabiano takes this Knight on G4
with his Bishop hikar looks to win back
the pizza five hitting the queen and the
night with his Pawn but Fabiano caruana
was a man on a mission he says you're
not going to get your piece back I'm
going to sacrifice my queen on F6 and
after the bishop took the queen he put S
Knight on D5 the queen slides back
because under attack as the bishop to d8
and he plays Knight F5 getting two
pieces for the queen but with a dominant
positional Advantage he went out to win
this nice game and just a great
demonstration of his excellent and deep
opening preparation
[Music]
a universal style of play amazing
preparation and an absolute beast at
calculation Fabiano caruana is still in
the race at the chess get cup and Daniel
he's come a long way in speeches since
the 2018 World Championship absolutely
historically The Narrative has always
been well Fabiano he needs that time
that classical chess in order to show
his true strength and he has turned that
narrative on its head in the last couple
of years he now performs regularly in
the top five entitled Tuesdays including
yesterday when he was mad and he got
second in title Tuesday he's fast he can
time Scramble with the best of them
Fabiana Corona has completely
transformed his classical and Blitz
strength even though he lost to Notre
back yesterday he's still in this
tournament and it was a very very close
match he still has a couple of things
left to say Tanya
and it is going to be a close match as
he faces Ali Reza faruja in the losers
bracket now day two had big upsets in
division one but not just in division
one it was a big day for the underdogs
in division two as well
the second day of the chess kid cup
brought even more twists and turns than
the first in division two there were two
incredible clean sweeps both by
underdogs Brown oxidwani won three
nothing against kyrill alexinco who was
rated nearly 60 points higher than him
and you and yok trong's Son crushed his
fellow Countryman La Quang Liam with a
three-nothing victory
in an anticipated match-up Vladimir
felicea bested David antangallero to
advance to the semi-finals Gregory
o'parin also defeated a higher rated
opponent in his match against Pavel
elianov to advance this is not like okay
this is brutal I'm good Lord that's
unbelievable division three's Alan
pishot continued to shine on day two
marching past San sebien and vitally
bernatsky to the winners bracket final
wow that was exceptional defense from
him and tala Hare Krishna also had a
phenomenal run to now face peace show in
that match
Grandmasters David Navarra and Alexander
donchenko desire Redemption as they have
fought their way forward since the first
round of the losers bracket
big names and big action and keeping us
updated on all of that is Grandmaster
Simon Williams Simon before we get to
that we've got to address the pony in
the room how was the good night
well Tanya you might be surprised to
know I've been very very well behaved
here I was running up and down stairs
earlier on and I I haven't been except
for the Saturday but I have heard a
rumor that some people on the panel have
been going there quite frequently and be
having a very good time there oh yeah
hey James hey James are you all right
James no I like Bishops and knights uh
no no comment there it's been uh it's
been a good time here in Oslo hey uh
yeah what about the chess guys yeah
we'll talk about that leader James uh
the good night stuff but right now it is
about the good night on the chess board
because the winner of semi-finals is
about to start in division two and Simon
what can we expect from that
well we've got um two fantastic players
and uh starting off things got new Young
versus operin and this is players who've
won every match so far so they do get a
second chance and then below that we
have FedEx who must be the favorite for
this group and he's playing our tattooed
friend only 17 years old and he's got a
full tattoo I don't know what I think
about that it flies his father I don't
know but anyway and then you've got the
losers brackets these guys they don't
get another chance so if they lose the
match here they go home and you can see
some big big names you've got Alex senko
versus AJ aching and two other players
I'm gonna pick out there ilearnoff
versus mamajarov they've both been over
2700 they've both been around for a long
long time and that's going to be one
hell of a match there
super exciting matchups there is ten
thousand dollars for the winner but not
just that also a Golden Ticket too
division one off the next event of the
Champions chess store and we also have
action in division three with a big
Winners final coming up and it will be
between these two player Alan P show
will be playing against Hare Krishna
Simon is there a big favorite in this
one
I'm gonna have to go for Harry Krishna I
mean um yep your fellow countrymen
you've probably known very well
um and number one he's got the best name
Harry Krishna so anyone with Harry in
their name you're doing well uh picture
is a very good player but he's very
unpredictable he can play really well at
times but he can also uh not play so
well should I say politely but they're
both fantastic players but Harry Krishna
is just more stable so I'm gonna I'm
gonna go for him in that one sounds like
a clash of styles it is it's kind of the
the South American kind of style you
might see in football quite flamboyant
quite exciting uh against um I don't
know our Indian players very solid I'd
be careful what I say here are you super
pragmatic as a player and very
consistent so it's going to be fireworks
on the board it is it's gonna be a
really exciting match there we're gonna
see if pitro can get through Harry's
very solid style so you never know but
it's gonna be a big match
and not just that Simon we've got more
action
that's right so we have the losers
brackets and again these players they
don't get another chance and uh the
legend is still there The Legend
garakamski and um he's playing very
strong antipov Sam sevillon is still in
with a shout but he's got you Yankee
it's gonna be a very tough match for him
and then one of ding's favorite players
the new world champion felico pons is
playing against donachenko there so uh
big matches going on any other divisions
as well
action all around and of course the
dream is to get to The Season's final as
store points are on the line it's
speeches double elimination bracket
three Division and the grueling format
makes it a challenge for even the best
players in the world
each event in the Champions chest tour
is broken up into three divisions making
the CCT even bigger than ever before as
the best players in the world work to
win their division and progress to
higher divisions hopefully securing a
playoff spot big prize money and Tour
leaderboard points here's what's at
stake in the three divisions in each
event the winner of division three
receives five thousand dollars and 20
tour points those with the most tour
points at Seasons end will secure the
wild card slots for the playoffs and
additional prize money the winner of
division two claims ten thousand dollars
fifty tour points and secures a coveted
slot in the next events division one
finally the winner of division one
receives thirty thousand dollars 150
tour points and a guaranteed spot in the
playoffs at the end of year the playoffs
will include eight players that have
qualified either by winning division one
or by earning enough tour points to
claim one of the wild card slots of
these eight players four will advance to
the live finals in the end
only one Champion will remain
who will be the king of the championship
store 2023 season the biggest season so
far off the door and right now we've got
big games coming up later today it will
be the winners final as Dutch number two
Jordan van for Stakes on the Uzbek
sensation not the back of the South shop
but we start the day with the
elimination bracket the losers quarter
final and big big matchups there tabiano
caruana against alireza ferrugia it's
going to be our Focus game and we've
also got another match with the German
Talent Dimitri colas taking on Jules
musad Daniel is there a favorite in that
one karwana just kidding yeah the colors
mustard match is going to be a very
close one complete toss up Dimitri has
played incredibly well he was that close
to forcing an Armageddon against Jordan
I'm gonna give him the edge just because
of his form but it's a total toss-up the
other one Tanya is a complete toss-up as
well but you don't need me to say that
Fabiano taking on other guys we know
that is going to be super exciting the
players have played each other in Rapid
a bunch of times and it is Fabi who in
fact leads with four wins to alireza
still wins uh James what do you think
about their head-to-head history and how
will that impact today yeah of course
the head of head to head is like I mean
important obviously but I mean it says
nothing in these games here today I mean
it's four games you got to bring your
best game today yeah okay you beat me
before but are you gonna beat me today
is the question and that's what faruga
is going to try to you know be fobby
today so I think I think I'm gonna get a
slight Edge to fruity even though I love
my man's fabulous probably co-e
calculator himself the human calculator
but I am going to take photos
it's going to be fabulous Fabi what's
his awesome alireza and they are ready
to go we are about to start Fabiano
Carolina starts with the white pieces
opening predictions David opening
predictions I'm gonna say one E4 Fabby
really needs to use his opening weapons
especially with white uh against alireza
especially because it's just a two-game
match every move counts and he needs to
get off to that strong start furuja
maybe in this format proved a bit Rusty
in the past yesterday had a great day
against hikara of course but if Abby can
hit him in the opening he will be a huge
favorite so I think he needs to go very
direct from move one
defense it was a queen's Pawn opening
this is one of the main lines of the
grinfeld The Exchange variation where
white builds the center and black aims
to erode that Center to try and chip in
it from afar and uh still very standard
stuff a well-known position I've had
this position against Fabi myself I've
got bad memories
what do we think of this opening Choice
by both sides a bit of a surprise uh
yeah I'm a grinfield player too I mean I
like grenfell like kid and I've kind of
looked at both in fact I know you were a
grenfield player for a long time too we
had that conversation and actually
there's a book a modern ice grunfield
it's a pretty good one it comes as
that's in like the forward chest stuff
but it's a B6 is a newer one we're not
newer but it's it's a it keeps pieces on
the board you have the bishop G4 line
instead of B6 where I think Petersfield
recommends that one in the chassis of
course but with Bishop G4 then F3
happens and then Knight A5 Bishop F7 and
all this lines of theory very deep stuff
there and black gets some very cool
positions B6 keeps it
um attention but it also can get
extremely wild from here so definitely
some sharp stuff from both sides so far
yeah sharp stuff and white has a few
options at some point white is able to
go and grab a Pawn on C5 but it will
come at the cost of the Integrity of his
Pawn Center here he's just keeping
things solid and uh yeah both sides
developing
on the board Harry the h-man is alive
Fabby has been playing uh with the H
Pawn so often in the store so far we
will come straight back to this one but
even our other game Dimitri kolas was a
jewel mustard two very very combative
players who've had so many decisive
games they are about to lift off their
game one it is a best of two in the
elimination bracket Dimitri colas there
with the white pieces he's had eight
decisive games in a row yeah that's
incredible that just shows that his
style is just super energetic extremely
tactical style he is a perennial career
E4 player in fact I've played hundreds
of Blitz Games with him he has never
touched the deer the C Pawn or the
Knight he is an E4 lifer and here we see
julissar deviating from his standard
Sicilian and the Petrov epidemic
continues sadly yeah you said it Tanya
eight decisive games so far but now we
have the most Jewish opening in chess so
can Dimitri call us sprinkle some magic
dust on this one and uh turn it into a
decisive game somehow very uh standard
stuff we've actually seen this before in
the tournaments uh on a couple of days
ago and white will try to erode the
center that black knight sitting nice
and pretty in the middle of the board
it's all about the fight for the middle
Square since there we see first exchange
of pieces and white has an extra Central
Pawn what do we think of this uh so far
early days I think Jana partnership
actually popularized this from Black's
perspective I think Knight B8 to D7 uh
is a move here five now Bishop F5 is
correct sometimes white pushes uh the
d-pawn quite early this line has gotten
actually very very theoretical and it
can get quite tactical white can put the
Knight on E5 Queen from D1 to V3 so you
can even though the position looks
relatively quiet right now the structure
is asymmetrical and White's got lot of
exciting ideas here I think the queen
often goes to A5 in these positions
there it there it is yeah some very
sharp direct lines here and uh there we
go you predicted it Daniel this has been
played before seen before and studied in
depth by some of the top players in the
world I've looked at this briefly myself
and yeah the lines go far too long and
for me to memorize but the players
clearly have done their homework and
Rule despite this not being his main
opening he's been playing instantly up
to this point Queen to C5 was the black
uh was Black's last move hitting the
white light Square bishop and we might
see a bunch of exchanges if black knows
the stuff he should be fine but uh White
at the moment is slightly more active
wow fast start to this one I would not
have predicted such a kind of uh well
such a theoretical line I thought Jewel
would maybe try to duck and dive and
Dodge uh Dimitri's opening preparation
here
very interesting approach by the French
Grandmaster opting for a Petra Jules is
also known for his attacking play so not
a line we see him play out often but in
the best of two match he would be happy
if he can keep things in control in this
one and then fight and go for the kill
with the white pieces in the final game
the bishop falls back now it looks like
the C3 Pawn is on pre but if black does
capture that pawn David it does invite a
lot of threats on that exposed Queen
White good start with the Rook moving to
C1 eventually capturing that C6 pawn and
notice the d-line as well with the queen
and Bishop lined up it's super dangerous
to pick up the C3 Pawn Yeah and I think
really instructive for everyone watching
at home don't move your queen too many
times in the opening Jewel has already
done it twice and if you get too greedy
if you do grab now as you say Tanya The
Rook slides across gaining even more
time the Queen's forced to make a fourth
move early in the opening you're lacking
good squares here for example if you
slide back there will be tactics such as
this one as you mentioned the bishop
very very loose now and I think you
might be able to win material by hitting
the queen kicking it away from the
defense of this piece and for example
you can slide back here the queen is
forced to retreat and eventually the
bishop will drop Black's position is a
bit loose so therefore you do not have
the luxury of time you cannot go Pawn
hunting in this position other moves
that come to mind maybe taking this Pawn
in the center just to develop the Black
Knight I'm also wondering whether you
can get away with bringing the Knight
out here but uh yeah you have to be
really careful at this early stage with
black it's strange to see him pause now
because he's been so confident up to
this point
yeah this takes a you have to be very
precise the Knight needs to develop you
have to connect the Rooks and the queen
is on a strange Square you have some
looseness with the bishop on D6 so this
is a great time to think I do think City
takes uh D is probably best and then
develop the Knight we also want to kick
this annoying Bishop on G5 to put a rook
on d8 somehow so we want to do this too
as well I think White's fine but black
needs to be very very precise in these
next few moves for sure yeah critical
moments already at an early stage Let's
uh let's leave Jewel to think about this
one we're expecting porn sex porn in the
center but uh clearly both players have
their ideas in this petrol at least it's
certain not the dry type of symmetrical
position that we're used to from this
opening no most certainly not and that's
I talked about this yesterday when you
check a line with an engine sometimes
you forget about the most natural moves
oh wait I forgot to start Bishop C4 to
B3 the most obvious move in the position
because it might not be the top engine
recommendation and if jewel is cut
unprepared here it's gonna get really
scary Tanya and Daniel we see a featured
chat there by Fox Uber saying the
unbreakable Petrov and it's true some of
these openings with black like the
Berlin like the Petrov they
traditionally do have that repetition
that you just hold you play it and it's
a draw but with modern chess and modern
engines and these different ideas of the
H Pawn Harry the H Pawn advancing down
the board there are ways to fight these
lines and it's not the way it used to be
anymore they've still got poison oh
absolutely and there's sort of a push
and pull effect on the one hand there's
a lot of grumbling I can't play the
Latvian again but anymore and I can't
play the Kings Gambit anymore because
all these openings have been refuted but
there's also the opposite side which is
that computers uh particularly Alpha
zero Leela chess they've breed a lot of
new life as you're saying into openings
that were considered very sterile
beforehand so it's not all bad lines
with H4 more tactical Lines within
well-known openings uh have become more
exciting yes some gambits that were
beloved by the players of the past can't
really be played against Grand Masters
anymore and that's exactly what we're
seeing in this particular Petrov now
Bishop E4 was the move of Choice by
Jules and we see that Dimitri there is
having a thing James it sort of keeps
the tension on the board with that D5
Pawn C6 Pawn sort of crossing swords
there the d-line opened the bishopany
for attacking that F3 Knight notice how
that defends the bishop on the king side
there are so many tactical ideas Brewing
I thought that was very creative
actually Bishop before but creative also
doesn't mean I mean it's the greatest
too as well the evil bar kind of reacted
there and I think it's maybe because of
this bishop E3 move Bishop E3 is just
really annoying Queen has to maybe I
think go to A3 if that's the case here
maybe I mean obviously you have a I was
looking at Bishop F3 and then you take
on C5 they take on D1 you take on D6 and
then you're hitting it takes takes all
right and then uh or a producer right
across right triangle but here well it
is uh Bishop E3 and I think maybe Queen
A3 because if you move away obviously D
takes C and then we are hitting the
bishop on D6 in many cases so it's a
it's really a weird move I think Bishop
E3 it's a creative move but Bishop B3 is
now on the board too as well so Jules is
gonna have to respond accurately here
yeah and the big question is how narrow
is the path to survival you mentioned
Queen to A3 James it does feel like a
really clumsy Square bit of an ugly
Square on the side of the board the
Queen sidelined not really doing
anything and I could imagine at some
point an attack uh kind of appearing
against the black king and the queen is
so far offside that she will never be
able to participate in the defense but
um yeah you mentioned Bishop takes
Knight as well that whole complicated
line even if white just takes back
beautiful Bishop pair I see long-term
pressure on this Square on F7 it feels
like white has a big initiative so is
black in trouble already at this early
stage just one move after his
preparation ended yeah well that's why I
don't play the Petrov I mean this is why
we get this type of position out of your
preparation what do you get when you're
not in your preparation
yeah looking uh really dicey here in the
early going that's a really great point
to make Italian I want to push a little
bit on that for those who are watching
we're just getting started on chess all
the chess kids out there you said
petroff is not an opening that you might
advise with black against the king spawn
opening what's a good one to start with
then well there's different schools of
thought on this I think most players
start with uh symmetrical King Pawn
openings with black E4 E5 and then
Knight F3 Knight to C6 because that is
easier to learn and teaches you the
fundamentals of development but I think
by the time you hit 1200 or 1300 you
might consider learning the Sicilian
which is a great opening that affords
winning possibilities really at all
levels it is pretty theoretical but it
also gives you the edge in the sense
that most uh players in the start of
their chess Journey don't study the
Sicilian as intensely with white so E4
E5 is good Sicilian is good but I
wouldn't go into the Berlin or the
Petrov just because the top guys played
I wouldn't choose my openings based on
what Magnus plays I choose my openings
based on what your coach recommends uh
or what seems to give you the most
success that's some great advice there
by Daniel based on your own style of
play and intuitively the kind of
positions that you want to choose the
openings and we do see the top players
they have such a universal style they
can play pretty much anything on the
board but definitely something to
remember to try and play to your
strengths and right now it looks like
Jules musad is in a bit of trouble
Dimitri kolos is the one who's playing
to his trance it is a complicated
position while Jules has a think uh
David should we just zoom out of this
one and quickly check in with our other
game Fabiano caruana against alireza
firuja whoever loses is out of the
Chaska Cup this is a best of two and wow
this is a very different position from
Annie Petrov this is fire
yeah there's potentially uh extremely
dangerous now for black I've had this
type of position plenty of times myself
and the black king looks safe enough but
it is a bit Airy at least compared to
his counterpart if the center explodes
which is quite likely to do so at some
point then White's pieces are more
centralized there we go already some
captures some trades in the center what
fruition maybe needs to do is just try
to Hoover all the pieces off as quickly
as possible if you can somehow make the
Queens disappear black long term has a
two versus one Pawn advantage on the
queen side black is doing well in end
games but yeah short term I do fear
slightly full for Asia he's playing
quickly though and I don't see any
immediate kind of ways to generate
threats for white
so yeah it's I'm not sure who I would
prefer here to be honest normally I'm a
grenfeld kind of loyalist but uh this is
one time I might make an exception I
think Fabi has great chances and it's a
position that might suit him just it
feels like there will be calculation to
do at some point and
James we all know Fabi is the master
there he is a Master calculator Coe
calculation over everything says Fabi
now here I do like uh I like the
attacker chances probably has you just
can't put that away he does that there
it is takes play H5 and don't even think
about the next move H5 is just what
you're going to play but now okay we do
have to think of a plan I mean the
Knight can't swing in the F4 and then E6
is there there's some problems maybe
even some sacking possibilities after
Knight F4 you defend E6 we take on G6
and then take again with the Knight of
course there is going to be uh obviously
you need to have more pieces on that
side of the board but it's just telling
you even highlighting as you see here
there's lots of problems in Black's uh
and black some Camp there and around his
King practical chance is definitely Sue
Fabi here but if we're able to trade and
Hoover off all the pieces okay Hoover
vacuum amazing in fact guys vacuum or
Hoover is is what it is but if we're
able to vacuum off some pieces here and
Hoover them off we will actually have
some good chances for black as you
mentioned with the queen side having two
pawns versus one so I do like fobby
Oliver has an extra Bond but with all
this initiative but do we think Fabi is
the one with the better chances
position I mean you're also asking the
wrong guy I'm pretty biased in favor of
the side with the initiative it's also
kind of interesting that black played
this B6 line which was upon sacrifice
white could have captured on C5 earlier
but white is the one who ends up
sacrificing upon for the initiative
again there's no immediate big threats
it's not like white is trying to win the
game in the next three moves he's just
trying to slow roll it on the king side
keep using the pawn as a battering ram
weaken the G6 Pawn once the Knight gets
to F4 there's also ideas of Knight takes
G6 followed by E4 moving up to E5 with a
discovery particularly I was gonna say
with the queen on D6 so some exciting
stuff Brewing on the king side but also
if white plays H takes G6 the H file
opens and you could very well get
yourself checkmated on H2 yeah it's a
really double-edged position Anything
Could Happen a moment ago we saw fabi's
air quality and I worry for him in that
regard because it wasn't looking great
but uh yeah it's now fabi's turn eight
minutes should be plenty of time to at
least generate some ideas here for white
unliking just jumping forward with the
Knight somewhere and hoping that the
Tactical kind of unveil themselves but
this could be decided at least the
course of the game who has the upper
hand over the next few moves and feels
critical already Fabby are pulling down
as Daniel mentioned and the longer that
continues the more you fear for White's
chances if he cannot whip up an attack
somehow there we go as predicted the
Knight lands on F4 dangerous threats in
the air already
it's not a move anybody can resist
playing and just play it literally plays
itself and G5 should be considered here
by black pretty drastic move and it
weakens the F5 Square quite severely
maybe the Knight will move right back to
E2 and then reroute uh the other way to
G3 oh that a five square so juicy this
F5 square a knight's on F5 F5 will
Thrive that's the saying and uh yeah I
don't know if I would be able to play a
move flight G5 but as you say if black
doesn't if black just plays a kind of
careless nothing move then just to show
the tactic but that both of you have
pointed out Pawn takes Knight takes G6
beautiful move exploding the position
and lining up you've lured the black
king forward and discovered check next
move you win the black queen so
dangerous threats and how to deal with
it without weakening your position
without loosening the F5 Square
not an easy question to answer here for
alireza that's actually I mean really
like what do you do yeah that G5 move is
now like looking a lot I want to raise a
glass to that
coming up with all the threats on
alireza's King here he has to make sure
though that the pieces remain on the
board Fabi is down upon currently Queen
E5 and I think this is such a good human
response in the position you stopped
that idea that you were mentioning of
the epon advancing down the board the
bishop on D3 is still blocked and now
that sacrifice we might think that
there's an f-pawn that moves forward but
the queen will simply sidestep to the
edge of the board on H5 and I and that
would be completely safe for black no
more sacrifices for the moment Fabi
makes a quiet move rookie one so it's a
long-term pressure down upon yeah and
that's how you have to that that's how
you have to play these positions you
have to resist the temptation to
sacrifice something and try to justify
the sacrifice immediately and you're
just kind of playing chess I mean the D4
Pawn that is Black's extra Pawn it's
just kind of sitting there it's
blockaded by the bishop for the time
being from a broader standpoint farouza
benefits the more heavy pieces are off
the board so I would be consider
considering Rook takes C1 followed by
Rook C8 but all white needs to attack
Black's King is a queen and maybe one
minor piece we've seen the queen and
Knight tandem David several times in
this tournament checkmating the King on
their own yeah you could certainly
imagine the White Queen ever landing on
the seventh rank uh checking the black
king any check is basically going to be
deadly and you mentioned the idea there
Daniel of just trying to get the Rooks
off the board Hoover them off the board
and I think it's about to happen there
we go one set of Rooks have departed a
second set now staring at each other to
take or not to take that's the question
well if you decide stop with the Rook to
B1 then Black's got this option of
jumping in with the Knight to C4 also
hitting the queen perhaps offering more
trades in the position so it's a big
moment for Fabi also I like the
flexibility with Harry the H Bond he
hasn't taken the decision to take on G6
and with everything that Alpha zero has
shown us there's always a threat of the
H Pawn in fact not trading but moving
forward to 86 at the right moment but
right now that's not the moment to think
about it he's got to decide whether he
moves The Rook or trades it I would be a
little afraid of moving it out simply
because of Knight C4 yeah Knight C4 Rook
C3 but the question is do you want do
you feel that keeping the Rooks is more
important than keeping all these squares
protected you could also take on C8
which seems counterproductive but that
Bishop on C8 could be targeted maybe
with a move like Queen D2 to C1 but I'm
having a hard time making it work
concretely because of Queen C5 for
example and a C7 Square as David pointed
out you want to get your queen to the
seventh rank but all of the infiltration
squares are defended I'm actually loving
the way that alireza has defended in the
last five to seven moves yeah just
really common he's doing what he wants
to do long term he's getting the
business done in terms of taking pieces
off the board he knows long term black
has the advantage but short-term Fabi
needs something and he needs it now I'm
struggling to create anything here
either for whites you knew you need an
Avenue into the black position but
everything is blocked right now and
black has ways to close those doors as
soon as you try to break through so I'm
liking black suddenly yeah you also need
more pieces too as well and it's good to
understand ideas of every opening every
opening has its idea overall themes here
and then the grinfield in games favor
Black most times of course you have to
see what kind of in-game you have you
might have the in-game with the white
d-pawn that you had that's passed where
you have to really uh keep it under lock
and key as uh Aaron nimitzu says right
so we're here I mean this he's up a pond
and I'm like hey I want to trade off
Hoover off some more pieces trade them
and when we reach it in game I'm up this
Pawn I also have the two verses one on
the queen side and we're going to try to
you know win this game in the end game
plays Knight D5 very creative move there
I actually saw this too as well but
maybe he has some attacking Chances with
like H6 and some other stuff wow F4
maybe two yeah this is race yeah relying
on some tricks here to make things work
Fabby he's got the idea that you
mentioned Tanya of just pushing the H
Pawn up once we're checking the black
king the black king then will be forced
onto the background because some really
vulnerable squares and if black does get
tempted to take the Rooks off the board
and then also eliminate the white knight
in the center with his Bishop then black
will be left with a sidelined piece
black might be able to go two pawns up
but you will be playing down without
your knight for the foreseeable future
really interesting stuff the evaluation
bar not really approving but I think a
good practical try he's at least going
to confuse alarism with this move scary
move I mean James pointed out the
prospect of H6 coming at the most
inconvenient moment for black so if you
do take on C1 and then take twice on D5
that might be the moment for white to
play H6 you're showing that on the board
and that is not to be trifled with
because after the king moves recapture
the bishop if the Queen recaptures the
pawn you've suddenly opened up the
pathway for the eval bar to go up and
for the White Queen to act C7 and I
always say in the end game it's not the
quantity of Pawns you have it's the
quality one past spawn on a square like
H6 can supersede even an army of past
fawns that are not as far Advanced also
you can't even take on A2
you lose the queen but even if he didn't
white is already completely winning by
this point and a lot of it does have to
do David as you pointed out with the
sideline Knight on A5 just not
participating in society to its fullest
extent yeah playing down a piece
not that last move and we saw the eval
bar didn't exactly approve of it but
from a practical standpoint Knight D5
asking a lot of questions and also let's
point out that if black gets greedy with
the other Pawn the H5 Pawn which as
we've been seeing with the lines 8-6
coming in could be a danger but this is
also super dangerous because now we see
that Black's Queen is stuck on the king
side really difficult to come to defense
on the queen side and offer a potential
Rook trade a rook takes C8 Bishop takes
C8 Queen C1 or queen B4 I like Queen C1
more the queen hits the bishop jumping
on to C7 all these ideas Queen F4 was
the other move that comes to mind but
with Queen F4 blacks Queen can't step
into the center of the board with Queen
E5 so that can be tricky black really
needs to keep that Queen on E5 as is to
control the board but it needs to get
rid of the H5 pawn and he does it
spoiling the pawn structure but captures
it with the Jeep on wow so two pawns up
now for black but your king is looking
really vulnerable lots of loose squares
around it if the white knight could
somehow maneuver around now to that
beautiful F5 post it would definitely
end in Checkmate but still no way to get
there the black queen covers any uh
squares at the moment this black queen
is the glue holding things together I
just wonder whether kicking it away
pushing the pawn feels risky it feels
like the black queen can still slide
back and keep things under control what
else can white try it the urgency has
increased being down to pawns at the
moment can we start with Queen A3 and
then F4
Queen A3 maybe trying to sneak in from
this angle a bit later kicking the queen
away makes a lot of sense yeah I think
it's up to Fabi I'm struggling to see
any immediate breakthrough but uh he's
only got four minutes left he needs to
find something otherwise he'll crash to
defeat with white
two pawns down down on the clock as well
Fabi trying to find his initiative it
feels like black spawn structure is
absolutely terrible but Fabi has to do
something in the next couple of moves he
starts with the Moon Knight F4 and David
I think it's centered around the idea
that you mentioned Knight comes back
only to go forward always in the air 92
93 Knight F5 once that night lines on F5
we live oh there we go that was nice
Knight F5 and we live that is correct
Chad you get that Knight to F5 it's
gonna get live right so of course I mean
we also maybe could attack this H5 Pawn
at some point with like G3 and queen D1
but I mean he really is trying to figure
something out here right now black
actually is for choice now I have the
two extra pawns here and I have my extra
pawns and in 1975 I was up two Pawns in
the U.S championship and I won every
game so it's very important to uh figure
something out right now as Fabi thanks
yes sir you're welcome you're welcome
thank you Jen
beautiful history lesson that meanwhile
for Russia not panicking just Bishop C6
so he's closed the C line uh he's not
allowing the White Queen to infiltrate
anytime soon
alarm bells ring for me somewhat because
the black Knight's still sidelined but I
think the idea as well might be to drop
back the black Bishop to the top of the
board to E8 to defend the H Pawn if
necessary we might see that now Bishop
E2 I mean he's going for me right he's
going for Knight takes H5 there's all
cars from the window I don't care about
a single one of my pawns all I care
about is optimizing the night virus says
no can do but Bishop E8 assign the
perspect right ferusa didn't even really
seriously investigate Queen takes E4
Bishop takes E4 instead playing it
cautiously but now his minor pieces are
as passive as they've been in a while
maybe time for Fabi to just make a slow
move like Bishop to F3 and secure the E4
Pawn or maybe there's something more
tactical like Queen C8
yeah you've mentioned two really
tempting options there Fabi needs to
weigh up whether he has the luxury of
time because Black's pieces are so
poorly placed right now the minor pieces
especially the first move you mentioned
nice and classy I guess the idea flow
yeah a bit slow that's the downside I
guess the idea at some point would be to
just solidify maybe move the Knight or
protect it and then break through with
the queen but it takes two or three
moves the second one you mentioned there
Daniel bring the queen in does drop the
Knight but you are attacking the bishop
and I guess the question here is does
white have enough to whip up uh kind of
generate an attack against this black
king or is black able to somehow get the
back uh the Knight into the game wow he
plays G3 so more along the lines of your
first suggestion just playing it slow
defending the Knight now the fruit the
queen is free to Rome this one is
heating up I still think it could go
either way especially as the clocks tick
down it's so difficult it's not a type
of position where you can play on
autopilot where you can play naturally
you have to calculate and you have to
kind of guess at some moment what the
best moves are
because you have so many choices on
every turn G3 so calm from Fabi
yeah this is what does he do what do we
do here as a farooja after G3 now the
Knight is way over there on in on A5
looking crazy like he's just there you
forget that you even like have that
night what do you even do with it maybe
there's something like bring it back it
was Knight C6 right nice C6 yeah maybe
five right I see six Bishop H5 oh look
at that time with the tactinos oh we
takes takes 95 though feels like
exchanges help black though I would love
for that type of thing to happen if I
were Alaris at least you might not win
but all risk will be
slow I was going to propose Queen C5 so
I'm glad I kept my mouth shut throughout
that discussion
but uh it's so easy to miss this kind of
stuff oh yeah playing in these formats
as well we've seen one move like this
happen by the very best in the world
hmm yeah these are two of the best
players in the world of course so I'm
hoping we don't see any blunders I think
uh the players have played an incredibly
uh kind of impressive game so far but
who will hold their nerve suddenly
farooch down on the clock for the first
real time in the game less than three
minutes for both players in a very
critical position where it's so easy to
go wrong one more
Lee lost no comeback from there right
now it is the big question can alireza
bring his Knight back into the game and
he does a great call there by Eugene
James he uses the B7 Square he wants to
come to C5 block that Queen out forever
making sure it never comes in to see it
and also put pressure on the E4 Pawn
a big fan of this move actually I mean
there's a book uh you can find it on
chess but of course you know I know but
it is you can also just buy it hard copy
anywhere you can find a grand master
preparation the positional one what's a
book uh in fact uh that well book is
something that you do and read for to
get better at chess Daniel has read
about uh two million of them so we
talked about this yesterday but uh yeah
the book says Grandmaster preparation
has three questions what's the
weaknesses in the position what's the
worst place piece and that was the night
looked very very bad and what's my
opponent's idea but definitely that
worst place piece he found it my night's
garbage I got to put it on a better
Square he moved it to B7 makes total
sense Queen A3 from fabino and Knight A5
nice worst place peace but it's back on
A5 right anything a hot prediction here
it's not going to be a repetition who do
you think is going to avoid the
repetition Tanya because if White's
Queen Retreats that's the second time
we've seen that position who wants to
win Fabi or alareza
I wanted
10 and I would be proven completely
wrong here and of course uh nothing new
there but wow Knight B7 or will he try
to go for the win in this one this is
the moment this is where having access
just to the evaluation bar tells
everything because the computer tells us
black is better we don't know how but uh
if feroza knew just that one detail he
would play on he would keep the game
going but again he's repeating yeah
[Applause]
and he's weakened the B6 spawn that is a
very brave decision and it's infuriating
because you know you're up two pawns but
it doesn't feel like that it feels like
white has the initiative but look at how
he reads it just pushing his pawns
forward again the key is to keep white
from accessing any of these key
infiltration scores C7 is covered now B6
is covered you just push the pawn to B5
that Bishop bunny ate it's doing it all
it's holding H5 and it's holding B5 it
is holding White's entire Army at Bay
and a big chess kid moment there because
we saw alireza repeat once it might make
the opponent feel that you are happy to
bail out in a position and then
psychologically it becomes so much
harder David when you refuse a
repetition for the second time yeah it's
good classical chess wisdom every
Russian Schoolboy knows or every Russian
chess kid knows that you should repeat
twice assert your dominance and then
play on show your opponent you're in
control that you don't want the draw
psychologically it's a big blow for them
and suddenly you see Fabi retreating his
Queen again and he's moved his Queen
several times in a row now without
really bringing her to anywhere too
dangerous and uh yeah it feels like
Black's made huge progress those two
pawns watch out for them on a and A5 and
B5 they are going to decide this game
unless Fabi can work his magic and that
black Bishop you mentioned it Dania just
holding everything together protecting
its king the king's best friend right
now is that black Bishop yeah he's just
found the ideal setup Queen C8 is
tempting but it's just met with either
Knight D6 or Knight C5 and you haven't
achieved anything at all Bishop F7 very
important move to cover the E6 square
and limit the activity of White's night
Fabby tries Queen to C6 trying to win
back the B5 Pawn perhaps and now farugia
has to decide between 96 and Knight C5
tough decisions to make as this clock
creeps down to one minute
yeah one minute whose position do you
feel is easier to play in Practical
terms you're the bullet King here Daniel
well I would take black just because I'd
feel that black is much better but in
terms of whose position is easier to
play it actually might be white and
those two things can be true at the same
time Knight C5 I think that's best to
prevent Queen C6 to D7 which would have
been very unpleasant I would have pinned
the F7 Bishop for Russia so accurate
thus far in the time Scrambler reminds
me of his time scramble against Hikaru
yesterday yeah just to show that line
you mentioned this would have been a
nasty pin suddenly this Pawn would be
under Fire and black would face a huge
attack instead he's given up his pride
and enjoy the B5 Pawn but look at this
counter play now against the white king
it looked safe as houses this King but
suddenly the play has switched this Pawn
will be captured the pawn on G3 is
overworked it's overloaded it has to
protect its Knight and suddenly it's the
white king that will become open and
watch out for suddenly Daniel the D Pawn
about to uh decide this game black in
control wow just the full board
awareness there to switch play to the H
file how are the h-bond
yeah
impressive stuff either way from alireza
actually it's just been a master class
this game just in keeping calm kind of
Defending and just kind of uh organizing
your pieces in their best uh on their
best squares just really impressive
stuff I've got to say from Russia this
game when the grenfell works it like
really works you know what I mean like
the grinfeld is a very powerful
openingly used by all the greats in fact
I mean it's a very great opening but you
do have to know what you're doing and
when it works it just works very well
here I mean white really never got
anything off and got two pawns down and
now it's uh looking bad for floppy here
very about desperately trying to get rid
of the black King's best defender hoping
that there might be some tricks maybe
some Forks some checks green takes C5
and 96 so The Bishop's gone man I have
messed up so many of these positions in
bullet games it's not over yet
over yet but close if alarissa is
accurate over the next three or four
moves he should emerge with a decisive
Advantage at least up one or two Pawns
and other players are playing on 30
seconds
grabbed material when he could took the
Pawns showed amazing defensive technique
and then switched play to become the one
who was aggressive that was a big threat
on the board the one that you were
pointing out to pick up the Knight and
Fork on E6 but of course alirez are
super sharp today he picks up a third
pawn and things are going from bad to
worse for fappy
really nice move there again it's all
about control now no checks for white
it's actually the white king that's in
more danger and of course black has the
two-pone Surplus as well I would play A4
to set up potential stale Matrix if the
black queen ever captures G3 with the
white King on H1 I know that's a lot of
ifs but I would have at least thrown
that move in given the opportunity now
ferusa has the chance to trade Queens
but that would involve giving away the
D4 Pawn that's not a worthy price to pay
and Ali Reza is still playing perfectly
can he go in for the Checkmate here he's
a mid in one no that's a big threat on
the board
the white might be the one getting mated
first well I don't know the White Knight
does hold some key squares The Black
Queen can't deliver a check seconds oh
he Retreats yeah watch your watch the
back of your position don't let the
opponent's Queen ever check you unless
you really have to and nice defensive
move there from veruga still under
control I mean F5 maybe just hold that
deep on with everything you got hmm try
something very similar but uh no scary
checks here the black king can always
slide back if it needs to black queen
now eyeing up the white a pawn he comes
back to defend it Daniel it was really
instructive to me that you're already
thinking about resources like stalemates
because that's how desperate it could be
for White and the Knight and the queen
are pretty easy pieces to give away I
love that Fabby played this move sounds
crazy but so easy to forget about
stalemate when you're on your last
seconds it's also easy to miss a fork if
I'd be doing a heroic job just like you
did against abducator of Notre back kept
his nerve can Ali Reza do the same
uh seven seconds it's not easy he's up
two pawns but with all the checks coming
in a queen and Knight combo it can be so
tricky to face this is far from over
regardless of what the eval Bar says
throw it out of the window wow Queen B5
he's saying any night end game might be
drawn or might have chances for white
there would have been Mutual past pawns
there too complicated to calculate so
farouzia says no I'm going to keep the
Queens on giving up the A5 Fawn was a
blunder oh maybe the queen just comes in
because there's no check with white and
he gives a check with the Knight first
king G2
he's going to save this now Fabi Knights
are terrible against these Rooks pawns A
and H pawns Knights are so bad at
stopping them they can only stop them
from one side so I think anytime the
Queen's coming through game David White
can win this one second
[Music]
completely slipping out of control
he's like oh my god oh it's a chick with
a check IG 4 and Knight F2 that's
amazing net
white king is okay for now only move
you're winning what happened he's
blundered the white king can now creep
forward oh my goodness
mating oh my goodness two seconds one
second he has to make a move there's no
moves
queen of Faith unbelievable
Wild game David yeah look at the
reaction Fabi laughing I think just out
of relief more than anything and
heartbreak for farouza who deserves more
plays a brilliant game with the black
pieces but chess is brutal like that and
Fabi being resilient and resourceful
kept targeting Black's King Daniel in
Sanchez listen these top guys they just
don't die you know they die they get up
again you kill them they get up again it
was impeccable technique for feroza he
was up to pawns he had all the squares
covered but you actually have to promote
some of those pawns and in trying to do
that he gave White's peace tandem
another victory of an active Queen and
Knight the scariest two-piece tandem in
all of chess what a turnaround win for
Fabi
just an amazing game of chess that was
we saw the eval bar in this case it was
the evil bar jumping up and down so many
hits and misses David you've got to take
us through what happened yeah and uh
Fabi you watched his magic he actually
pounced on a huge mistake from alireza
and it was in this position after a
check the white king sliding back
another check that alireza finally lost
control panicking with only two or three
seconds left on his clock here he gave a
check from the wrong Square he checked
on C2 if he had centralized his Queen he
might well have won this game
centralization and this white king is in
huge trouble it would have been a full
360 and it would have been white likely
getting checkmated instead he checked
from this Square perhaps forgetting that
after the king moves you're running out
of checks with black if you check from
this Square the white king slides
forward and no more checks it's actually
the black king next move that will be
doomed the White Queen will slide across
as we saw instead alireza found nothing
better than pushing his Pawn but he
resigned in this position realizing that
King G5 would be met by Queen G7
Checkmate heartbreak and it's so tricky
queens and knights are the most devilish
pieces on the board
and that's exactly what we saw what a
chested moment it's not over till it's
over in chess well just one more game
remains for these players in the losers
quarterfinals and it will be over for
alireza ferruja if he doesn't win the
next game on demand against Fabiano
caruana meanwhile Dimitri colas also
scores a big win in his match against
Jules Musa so Jules and alireza have to
win on demand and if they do that we
will have an Armageddon more a chess kid
action coming up after this twitch break
[Music]
just lost a dramatic game to Fabiano
caruana and he is in the losers bracket
and that's because of one man here that
is Dimitri colas he makes his debut in
division one had a big upset on day one
and yes he is World ranked 171 but
there's no way that you can treat him as
an underdog
[Music]
thank you
Dimitri kolas is part of the golden
generation of young German Grandmasters
he might have flown under the radar for
some time but now collars is really
starting to shine he is Mr consistent he
very rarely blunders he very rarely
posts bad results and both online and
over the board he has been performing
extremely strongly lately collars is
extremely difficult to beat and if you
give him an opportunity especially when
it comes to calculating variations then
he will seize it
this game came from a clash between
colors and Liam in the qualification in
the plane for the chess kit cup
here white has an extra Queen but in
return black has a rook and a knight if
black gets just one more move he will
either create a fortress by dropping the
Knight back white won't be able to break
through or he will create counter Play
by taking this Pawn collars had spotted
however that loose pieces drop off here
he gave a check
due to the diagonal here the black king
has to stay in touch with the Black
Knight but now this black Rook is
undefended and the queen drops back it
has lured the black king to a poor
square and The Rook is doomed collars
took the rook and took the full point
and that's exactly is a kind of crazy
chess that is the reason that Dimitri
kolas has had so many decisive games
this chess kit got eight back to back
and he does take the lead in his match
against ajoo's musad but it was a
complete focus on fabioli Reza because
that is David one of the wildest games
that we witnessed on the door yeah just
so many swings and roundabouts it was a
roller coaster battle and farusha
showing why he's one of the best players
in the world but ultimately just letting
it slip the nuts got to him and uh Fabi
tenacious Fabby taking the four points
and yeah I think the next game is going
to be equally unpredictable and speaking
of it will be unpredictable let's make
some predictions uh can furuja do it
will he make a comeback uh James will we
see an Armageddon yeah I don't think so
and the reason for that is just the
psych part unless you can get over that
real fast I was winning I mean imagine
you're winning the game or I'm doing
good I'm about to win and then you lose
like so in the end of the the break is
not that long so you're gonna play your
second game you need to win here he's
under a lot of pressure
and the seconds are ticking well the
girl is is that he played a brilliant
game the result was not in his favor but
for the most part of the game it was
alireza who had the upper hand and he
starts with the white pieces I think
we're gonna have an Armageddon what do
you think Daniel yeah it's really hard
to say Fabi one of the hardest players
to be on demand is because of his
opening preparation when he turns up
that opening dial he can basically on
demand get the kind of position he wants
to get for Asia we'll have to have
everything go right for him I think he
should play one E4 and stick to what he
knows best get a tactical position and
just calculate your butt off
the holy system
he's playing for the win but this is not
exactly the opening that we expect when
a player has to win on demand what's the
strategy of going for this approach
David
guess Cruiser just wants to keep as many
pieces on the board as possible it's
unlikely there'll be too many trades of
pieces at least over the next few moves
maybe some tension in the center with
pawns as well he's banking on the fact
that Fabi will have to make some
difficult strategic decisions later down
the line so interesting approach but I'm
also an adherent of uh playing what you
know best in these crunch matches
especially when you need a clutch win on
demand you've got to go back to basics
and after a heartbreaking defeat like
the last one I do worry that things
could spiral out of control if things
start to turn against ferrugand
obviously fabi's come prepared we had a
totally symmetrical position for a few
moves now things have opened up in the
center but Fabi has barely paused For
Thought which makes me think he studied
it before James absolutely I mean of
course you have a very easy play here
for both sides I think you just develop
you hit the center he hit it with C5
there my Bishops look good gotta develop
my night eye castle and I put the queen
maybe on C7 E7 try to push for E5 these
positions are really nice for both sides
I actually like to play them um from the
white side with Knight B to D2 and
actually just being him aggressive Queen
E2 and casting Queen side almost every
time I don't care what's going on I'm
gonna play castle Queen side and try to
get G4 in because it's very aggressive
here here it's a little bit different we
have the hanging Pawn structure now with
white uh we can still play for some
aggressive intentions like D5 at the
right moment and maybe you know we have
the Bishops open up so why still I think
for Choice here I like white actually
because of the positions how tactical
they can get but Fabi has no problems
everything's developed
yeah everything's developed everything's
covered and it's definitely onus on
white it's the burden on white to create
something from these positions what do
you what's your experience like with
these hanging pawns down here I tried
this opening a couple of times the last
us Championship with mixed success I
don't love playing with hanging puns I
feel like handling them is a little bit
like investing in Bitcoin it's like you
wait and wait and wait when you push D5
or C5 it's always the wrong moment and
it's always at its peak and you end up
losing the pawns Black's plate is easier
from a rapid play standpoint you can see
Rook C8 Queen C7 Bishop from D6 can
often tickle White's minor pieces from
F4 white has to accumulate those pieces
such that they aim at the king side and
like I said find the right moment to
push one of those pawns forward just
like you would David in an iqp setup but
that is all to the side because we've
got another game that is going on we do
have liftoff with ajoo's musad also
needing a clutch win against Dmitry
collage and he starts with the Spanish
so we can again expect a middle game
with all the pieces on the board and a
lot of tension
a lot of tension in Spanish until this
move yeah call us going for the open
variation uh of the Spanish this tends
to lead to many forced lines so if Jewel
hasn't done his homework he might even
struggle to get a game and that's my big
fear for jul musad right now needing to
win of course I should mention the first
game that sir Dimitri colors won it's
it's the ultimate demonstration of a pin
you pin and you win so any chess kids
out there wanting to learn about the
theme of pins go check that one out on
chess.com great uh demonstration there
from Dimitri colors in the first game
but this one yeah he's pausing on six
porn still theoretical position
extremely to put it mildly are one of
the leading modern day Experts of the
open Rye like you said so many four
straws here you gotta avoid them like
the plague if you're Mr massar James I
don't know maybe something a little bit
more non-theoretical should have been
chosen yeah absolutely maybe some
theoretical order some spice in these
games here too as well I mean nice uh
there's lots of courses out or even just
videos to watch on these of variations
too as well I recommend grandilius Grand
Roy Lopez actually from the white side
he covers this pretty nice
um it's also strong it's Neil's
granddillius but you play Bishop C2
right you played Knight D2 it's very
theoretical there's also a psych line
with a like Knight F2 but The Bishop's
not on C5 for air so I mean yeah I
probably would have went somewhere
non-theoretical play something a little
bit different just like his style is I
mean Jules is a very creative player
here but this is very theoretical
straight up so of course the stuff is
very straightforward Bishop C2 Knight D2
try to get the Knight off E4 and hope
for the best
yeah and you can already tell by the
kind of time usage so far that Jewel of
course he knows his stuff he studied
this before but he's a bit uncertain
maybe regretting his opening choices
because uh Dimitri has played instantly
up to this point not surprised at all
black is going to Castle on the next
move or two and a very healthy position
very decent position here so um yeah
it's all about getting rid of the black
knight from the center of the board
first of all that's job one and in a
must-win situation you just have to take
those kind of micro plans those
step-by-step kind of approach here you
don't need to worry about the result too
much WoW moving the bishop for a second
time theory talking of pins that's some
old school Theory because the bishop the
dark squid Bishop in the modern day
usually goes out to C5 which is the more
ambitious line Bishop E7 is the old
school line I remember Archer used to
Bob all those like old Soviet names
played it in some super tournaments in
the 1980s and the night from E4 often
Ducks back to C5 and later to E6 which
is a really nice blockading post
yeah all right now there's a big threat
on the board the Bishop from G4 David
you were saying about a master class uh
with the pin well this could be also one
of them there is a direct threat of
picking up that E5 but on 95 is coming
up if white isn't careful and it doesn't
feel like it's the time that you want to
trade on e4 either so how do you fight
against this chat do you start
developing on your own with your own
Bishop Bishop F4 is that a move I would
be a little scared about G5 yeah
defending this Pawn makes a lot of sense
but as you say Tanya you have to be kind
of wary of pushing uh these pawns for
black now and your Bishop has to commit
it either drops back and you lose this
Pawn in the center or you kind of walk
into the firing line and black will
throw pawns down a pawn storm against
the white king I've only had this
position once myself uh from like
recollection in practice and talking of
old school I think this was back in 2004
2005 against Victor mikhailovsky another
open Royal expert he's written a book on
it yeah exactly and I just remember I
don't know modern Theory it's all in
this position I've got to say but I
remember my preparation was to play this
move Queenie one big fella wow David man
you swinging out here big dog but this
is like Fritz free territory
engines that could calculate one move
the idea is to get out of this pin uh so
this point is not hanging and if the
Knight is captured yes you ruin your
structure but uh quite likely in a
position like this one you are able to
push this Pawn forward later on it gets
crazy of course there are tactics all
over the place but Jules surprised will
he go for something like this he's in
must win situation so why not imbalance
the position I love it love it Queenie
one I think it makes a lot of sense
given the Mad situation that Jules is in
but he takes another approach he plays
H3 and now that does invite a trade on
F3 if you recapture with the Queen the
E5 Pawn is hanging does that move
surprise you
or do you think he wants to capture one
I think it was Theory I'm not even gonna
lie I remember seeing H3 here at Bishop
H5 you actually go G4 but I don't
remember what happens on Bishop takes F3
because I'm like I mean he is just gonna
maybe you do take with the pawn in fact
and just play F4 but H3 I do remember
seeing this vaguely from some chessable
study not gonna lie but Ace three Bishop
H5 I think you just go G4 there and then
after G4 I don't remember if it was
Knight D4 to try to play F4 F5 too as
well it's something like this but H3 is
a move so I'm guessing if he takes on F3
he's gonna take with the pawn queen
takes you it is going to be 95 immediate
hit on the queen so as uh David pointed
out there you just take with the pawn
and just push F4 and you do have those
questions structure push him maybe as
Yasser says right so it's definitely a
spicy position at H3 Bishop H5 I think
we're going to see G4 yeah and I think
that will be uh kind of music too Jewel
massage is that just knowing that he can
kind of get this really uh kind of crazy
position in a must-win situation that's
all you can hope for for from an opening
I was question it a few moves ago
suddenly things are spicing up and
I think psychologically that will be
great for Jules but he does take moments
wow we know porn I think Joel doesn't
know which one which way he wants to
take he's like I'll figure that out when
he plays it across that bridge and I get
there now he's at that bridge I think
he's made a decision wait spicy buckle
up you know what I'm saying
Buttercup Sriracha I love the spice oh
yeah definitely more like Carolina
Reaper levels fast oh we all right over
there in the South we don't mess around
all right now
wow and that's just why not David that
if it was a queen capture 95 as we've
been saying would have happened hitting
that Queen on F3 and visuals he has
taken back with the pawn hitting that
night on e4 and now it does look like
the pawn structure is absolutely awful
for white and David it all relies on one
idea of pushing down the f file you've
got a march with that Bond F4 F5 if you
can get it in and that's what Jules is
relying on yeah it helps that you have
the bishop head this bishop especially
is unchallenged and while he doesn't
even go for F4 yet first he pushes B4
kicking this Black Knight it wants to
sit on this square of course but
suddenly it's a clear Target for White
staff pawns it's an avalanche and I'm
loving this suddenly for white feels so
easy to play as well your next few moves
are really natural
who needs to develop their Queen side
anyway it's like that old joke about
capablanca playing an amateur in the
simul and the amateur plays an amazing
game but capablanca wins and after the
game of Lanka says he played such a good
game but you didn't move your Knights
the entire game what's up with that he
said I just haven't gotten around to
learning how they move yet so apparently
the bonds are just going to decide the
game
wow and uh Dimitri colas already a
critical moment for him if we go back to
the game position maybe he's thinking of
some crazier Night Moves I'm not sure
where it wants to land up to be honest
but it feels like going back to its most
natural Square could backfire for black
so let's let uh Dimitri deal with this
dilemma no that's crazy woman for
Dimitri here he has to take a decision
96 the most natural looking move that's
where you want your knight but it comes
with its own set of troubles and while
Dimitri goes into a thing in this
critical moment we will take this
opportunity to jump back to the alireza
faruja Fabi game alireza once again he
has to win and we see with the white
pieces Harry the H Pawn has started it's
Advanced down the board in the last game
it was Fabi who did it now it's alireza
and he loses the pawn oh man I'm not
going okay so look the Kali with H4 is
probably some of the most fun chess I've
ever played first time I played the car
they actually played the Knight F3 B3
kanakali nimso Larsa and I won against
strong I am like sacked it was one of
the greatest games of ever for me this
is like very recently so like that H4
pawn and you got the Bishops all you do
is King G2 Rick H1 that's why you play
qh Queen H5 so he has to not trade and
then you have to try to figure out how
to get this Rook to the H file play D5
and you got yourself a uh something
we're cooking with some with some hot
grease here right it's definitely going
to be something if we can open up the
game and get a rook to the H file nice
move from Fabi trying to trade the queen
so that H Pawn push with these Bishops
and the Kali is really strong Daniel
what do you think yeah I'm just
concerned about the prospect of E6 E5
like if white screen dips if it dips
forward to B7 it runs into Rook C7 if
you slide away to B3 black might strike
first with E5 you might have to add a
big deal just get gives me a pass Pawn
with T5 but look at that C5 Square can
be accessed both by the bishop and by
the Knight but King G2 Rook H1 I mean
you got to play that move come hell or
high water right the question is is
White's played down the h-val going to
compensate for the pawn you've
sacrificed and for the squares that
you've given up definitely the kind of
position you want to have the problem is
it's not enough to get a crazy position
you also have to not be losing in that
crazy position right
and you definitely can't allow the
Queens to disappear from the board you
are a pawn down uh despite the fact
black has double pawns here it will be
relevant long term and yeah I just don't
see how white having the time here to
get the queen out of the way to get the
king forward and then bring a rook
across maybe then you have some
compensation maybe not enough even there
but uh it feels like you don't have the
time he's played Queen to D3 and maybe
your idea is still on tap here Dania
just playing E5 uh maybe maybe right
okay
but I think it works I think it works
too I pause that as well the whole idea
would be after Pawn takes porn you can
take actually
yeah
Queen takes and there's a nasty
nightfork King now all right dude King
F1 and H3
yikes Checkmate so E5 looks like it's a
very strong move here for Fabi maybe you
can just bring the Knight to this square
but I am reluctant to give white the
time to step forward with thing for
example and allow The Rook slide
crazy position okay so what happens on
E5 though like E5 then what do you just
go King Z2 now maybe that's probably the
time
I promise you need three or four moves
to deliver a Checkmate there and I'm not
sure you'll get that title yeah yeah
there we've got E5 is definitely a huge
Prospect here you probably spend four or
five moves lining up something on the H
file and that black just plays like F5
and slides the king 207 and no checkmate
wow Bobby needs just a draw to wrap up
this match he's up upon currently
fighting uh Ali raza's initiative but it
will take a couple of moves for alireza
to build that attack as we have been
discussing and Fabi plays it he plays
the most direct move he finds it we've
been saying this he is a calculation
monster he calculates all these tactics
E5 at first it looked like the pieces
lined up on the D file it would not be
possible but turns out Fabi is too
strong E5 D takes E5 you pick up with
the Knight and there is an attack on
White's King
yeah maybe C5
that's right up our alley but the C5 is
like I mean C5 takes and then why is
Gucci yeah yeah either way what's
happening there let's uh jump in you're
both curious about this move see what if
we take on C5 twice then and then take
this way with the bishop Queen takes D7
there's Bishop takes F2 right I don't
know exactly oh man this is spicy chest
this might be some sort of Perpetual
like King takes Queen H2 King F3
and maybe some quiet move like F5
no probably not
maybe you just play a move like this one
and uh yeah you either take here or you
go for your plan of uh delivering
Checkmate look at this white king so far
out in the open in the middle of the
street two pieces down though it's a big
sacrifice and a big decision for
farouzia whether to allow a creative
variation like that one it might be the
type of thing he needs though just to
kind of gamble roll the dice and hope
that it works out on wet's favor he's
rooting how do you mix it it's on the
box let's go C5 and who's Live Well we
live let's get it come on David C5 all
right Daniel we cooking watch Minor
pieces are about to lose their life
that's right absolutely C5
so you never want to fall back with the
bishop because then the C Pawn
disadvances down the board and the Deep
on joins the party as well so you have
to kind of capture on C5 with black Fab
he doesn't have too many options here
well do you think he's calculated I
think he is he calculating now take
takes takes oh man this is so crazy
logical logical taste taste takes takes
and then takes on F2 and like do you
think he missed C5 though or is he um
did he foresee this is definitely
yeah
C5 totally fun C5 totally blunder just
like bundled it wow it's nice to have
you back in the tournament
great to be great to be here David all
right
great that's excellent sounds just like
them C5 Pawn takes takes and yeah this
is a lie and now okay let's say he
doesn't take it then what do we do
Vision back that's what we wanted then
we played C6 yeah he has to take this
yeah right you can't allow that pawn on
C6 takes tape but then you have to go
down that line Bishop takes C5 taking on
D7 takes on F2 yeah this is he's gonna
spend some time here yeah at that
variation we showed with White's King
kind of leading from the front out in
the open there okay we saw the
evaluation bar still roughly in the
middle but for these players it's
impossible to evaluate they're just
going to be guessing at that point and
it's just pure calculation they have to
dig deep they have to go even five six
moves further than we did just to uh try
to get to the truth of that so it's
understandable that fabi's taking his
time now for farouza his hand was kind
of forced he needed to make it crazy so
I think he made a good practical
position he played C5 quite quickly
because there was nothing else simply
everything else was totally fine for
black at least so I like the practical
decision now Fabi I think he's gonna
burn three or four minutes over the next
few moves and then he's gonna go for it
because what else and look at fabi's
face he's like oh I didn't want to allow
that chaos but I pretty much have to and
sometimes you just have to play the best
moves even if a draw Suits You
he's gonna go for that Roxy d8 is a very
hard move in that final position yeah
that's just very hard to switch your
mind from check mode right to like oh I
gotta find a quiet move and as I say
that here we go here we go buckle up
what a move did you see the speed with
which he did it did you see his reaction
though he did not want to make that move
but he did because he's principled and
he knows it was the best one that's what
the top players do they know they have
to play ugly moves they have to gamble
but has he seen drug deal that's the big
question he sacrificed the piece so
Bishop F2 is the move that's on his
radar right now but that would be the
second beast sacrifice and he's he has
to find the big move rookie
oh
and he played it first but it doesn't
actually matter he's on that boy fast
this is amazing stuff
calculated the entire sequence of moves
Coe
you better calculate at home you better
be calculating get home you better
better be calculating this is incredible
yeah and I think the reason he played it
before checking on H2 is he wanted to
reserve the option of also giving Rook
D2 check in the event that the queen
moves all the resin could also play Rook
H1 forcing a end game with two Bishops
against her broken three pawns but black
should be safe there yeah what a move uh
he sacrificed two whole Bishops Fabiana
caruana but uh he has forced the white
king out in the open as you say Daniel
if the White Queen moves you have the
option of this check and this check and
either way that white king is living a
Charmed Life it might not survive too
much longer any sack his Queen he did he
did wow he gave the girl up he just wow
let's go back to Craig this is a wild
game action replay Queen takes Rook he
decided no more checks and no tracks uh
tricks there and he's brought his Bishop
forward so let's do a count it is Queen
for rook and two Bishops but black does
have three extra pawns look at that pawn
Mass these could decide the game if they
start marching
I just need to draw you can just start
checking as well white skiing is out in
the open yeah yeah one check though can
be blocked and uh there is now a threat
of trapping this queen
so suddenly there is a defense I don't
know who I'd pick to be honest I would
be flexible and playing with like a rook
E8 to d8 and set up more threats down
the D file oh did he play it or did you
find the boy
looking good he's gonna defend that but
the Rook on the second rank Rook C2 is a
move that comes to mind but it looks
like Fabi is on the brink of wrapping up
this match but despite what the eval Bar
says he still has to be a little precise
it's far from over right now
give white a couple of moves and if I'm
trying to think of how can white
actually create play here double up on
the H file mate on h8
yeah the problem for white as well is
there will never be never be shelter for
the King right there's nowhere that you
will hide your king safely forever so
while your pieces try to generate
something against the black king black
will always have counted play counter
tracks and uh I think that's maybe the
big issue combining your pieces is also
difficult here for alarisa
what a sequence that was yeah that's
just us crazy sequence we just saw there
guys and I mean I think I would probably
end up taking black at the end of the
day here wise King is just so hard to
defend you have to keep the pieces
around it and in the classical game okay
it may it's completely different you can
I think for 30 40 minutes to figure out
all the subtleties of the position here
but you don't have that kind of time and
it is difficult you can also maybe lose
by you know moving a piece uh or keeping
something undefended and then you you
lose to a check you lose one of the
pieces and the game's completely over
here white also needs to try to
coordinate our own play like we can't
we're not even attacking the king the
king is so safe so it's really difficult
for for white but you know I think it's
easier to play for black
have you guys ever had this material in
balance before Queen for rook and two
Bishops all the time I had it this
morning
yeah because I remember one of my own
experiences I had this exact material
balance uh rook and two Bishops for
Queen and pawns against Sebastian Feller
at the 2010 Olympiad he calculated a 15
move line oh my God went into this I
thought oh I have uh rook and two
Bishops that adds up to 11. you only
have a queen and pawn that adds up to 10
I'm a hopper material but my kids color
though yeah I found out later that there
was some shady stuff going on during
that game but uh yeah it turns out that
the white King was just too open in that
one and I'm having flashbacks here white
king is too open same material imbalance
but the queen is so much more potent
than the pieces right now it is a lot to
do with King safety in this position
not happy with what he's got on the
board Fabiano caruana looking confident
this action is on but we've also got
action on in our other two Division and
joining us is Simon Williams with the
update Simon what's going on in division
to do uh yeah hi there guys um well
we'll start with division three actually
because we were mentioning this big
match in the Wingers bracket between
Harry Krishna and pitcho from Argentina
and we were thinking that Harry was
favorite there but actually Harry
blundered a piece in the first game in
the opening which you rarely see a 2700
player doing Alan Petro has gone through
to the Grand Final of division three and
Harry's gotta try to survive the losers
bracket now division two very quickly
we'll just talk about players who have
been knocked out and who are going home
crying a little bit they don't get
another chance and it's a big chance you
know if you win division two you get a
chance to play these guys that'd be
fantastic in this big final with big
money so players who lost well Mama
jarov beat ilearnoff so Mama jar of
student with a chance we had Liam Lee he
won against Greg Mayer and then we had
Lee Tron he beat David Anton so David
Anton a very strong player from Spain
and he was the favorite in that match
has also been knocked out so a little
bit of action there and there's going to
be some sad people around but chess is
pretty brutal like that and uh well back
to this one this is this is looking very
very exciting and someone's gonna be
who's gonna be crying guys at the end of
this game uh who do we think
Simon that's the question we're trying
to figure out I want to ask you did you
see that incredible minor piece
sacrifices that Fabi played out and the
sequence of moves and how quickly he
played it I did it it was amazes me how
strong these guys are I mean they're I'm
sitting there with you guys in my ear to
help me out there but I'm like what's
going on here and it's like bang bang
bang and they're they're flying
everywhere so it's uh it was incredible
and uh you you just sometimes forget
just how good they are and how precise
they play it's it's another level it's
very easy watching at home or even in
the other room with a computer you know
we all do that and just watching the
evaluation Bargo yeah anyone can do that
you know just sack a piece but actually
when you're sitting there as I think
David pointed out without the evaluation
bar it's so hard to work out uh exactly
what's happening so yeah
you know it reminded me of this amazing
game you know swindolly Gail fund played
this Grandmaster from England forget his
name you know it was Simone Samsung last
name you know typical his name is great
game you know it's just made me think of
that okay now Tanya thank you again I I
did ask you to do an impression before
the show and that was pretty amazing but
I've no idea what it was of I know it
was a girl fan yeah
Tanya just keep keep them coming please
I love the English one you you well
Daniel I know you are one of the most
amazing chess commentators but if you
ever want another job
then there's one waiting for you as a um
I don't know like uh weird chess I'm
deeply honored
oh I could just do this all day
wow there is a lot of fun here at the
studio and it looks like Fabiano caruana
is also having a lot of fun in his
position he needs only a draw to win
this match I really like the way alireza
has set up his pieces boxed up very
wholesome position there on the king
side but the problem for our Ali razai
is that he needs to win yeah how does
white create his chances here yeah
that's a great question uh there is none
in fact I'm just kidding no but at the
same time here it's really tough I mean
look at the pieces there they're like oh
it looks all great cool but how you win
you like I mean well we didn't get that
far yet because it's very difficult here
but I can see one thing that can happen
is if black gets too ambitious if you
try to push all the pawns the Bishops
could open up things could happen but
until then I mean really it's just
defense which is fine it's why me right
all right yeah bloody bloody it's like
so good for for black hair all he needs
is a draw two as well but you know as we
saw in the last game with that time
scramble and then grenfield was winning
and then lost the game right so anything
can happen I think when the time gets
lower yeah all you need is love though
and uh look at those pieces they're
having a nice little cuddle in the
center of the board that white king is
being yeah just given all the little
kisses and cuddles there just smothered
by its pieces that's uh cute yeah
perfect kind of diagram of coordination
those pieces as you guys say though what
next you need to at some point create
something and Black's wall of Pawns in
the center and around the black king wow
okay the stepping forward I was gonna
say they're looking nice and pretty
perfect formation
and uh now I wonder two things firstly
can white get greedy and grab the A7
second weird pornograph that would take
some courage secondly do you just
blockade do you push a pawn forward and
block the advance of Black's g-pawn what
do we think I think that's a big
question that Ali Reza has to answer
right now does he allow the Jeep on to
March down the board and displace that
Bishop on F3 which is such a key
Defender for white skin and he says he
needs to go for the win he picks up the
material uh
G4 coming up Queen F5 putting pressure
on White's King this is getting risky
for white I mean it's terrifying but
this is the luxury of being an alirez's
shoes you know that you have to take on
A7 because you're not going to get
another chance to take that pawn your
Bishops just don't have any purchase in
the center the D5 square is so well
covered I think the apron is White's
only realistic chance of unbalancing the
game but Favi is not messing around that
is a scary looking move right there
maybe bishop F3 can move up to E4 the
king not getting called cuddled any
longer if the pieces are off to war The
Rook could swing over to A3 and if the
A2 Pawn is eliminated I just don't see
Perugia defeating the combined forces of
Black's queen and the pawn Phalanx in
the center yeah I think that's the uh
that's the huge threat okay Bishop
before on the board we're expecting now
we're up to A3 double attack hitting the
rook and eliminating this Rook D1 in
response Bishop D5 level staff so Rook
takes Bishop now would walk into the pin
uh that's been one of the themes of the
day the pin and this would win for white
so what instead I saw the evaluation bar
react here after Rook D1 okay three
happened Rook do one he's got to try it
you cannot Retreat your Bishops that's
right yeah maybe Queen is three it's so
scary though Rook did but maybe you've
got things on the board three the bar
reacts maybe a check game Nowhere to Run
oh my goodness
okay I'm telling you this is a tricky
little move oh my gosh Bobby's got to be
super cat Queen G4 hot H3 he's a queen
G4 the bar approves Fabi is all good
right now yeah nice move and the big
difference is that after a check you can
move your king because uh this one does
nothing Bishop E3 he blunders something
here let's see what it is
[Music]
have a good one
to the house
dang one move wonder he just dropped his
Bishop
you forgot to flick in it for a lot of
them so it's understandable
wow and he just turns off his camera
just like that that is not just game
over but tournament over for alireza
ferruga he is out off the chess get Gap
we've still got action and you're
Shields moves on Jordan run first will
be up next Jules musard still has hopes
alive can he make a comeback
certainly looking possible this one is a
crazy position if we do a quick count it
is level material but a bit of an odd
Pawn structure black has doubled a pawns
which don't make a great impression but
white hasn't doubled f-pawns and uh
everything else being equal I do
slightly prefer white and that's mainly
because the Black Knight as well not
necessarily well placed
what about you guys who would you pick
crazy Brothers here you're roughly
balanced after Knight C6 Bishop C3 now
okay
I mean yeah I like white because we have
the pass Pawn in the center too I can
put the Knight on D5 at some point like
I feel like I just have more than you do
I also hit the you know at some point
maybe able to grab these pawns I'm on
the a file that's going to be a while
from now though Knight D5 I guess he
wants 97 there that's why you move the
Bishop from E7 so you can you know move
the knight uh there it is 95 but 97
Hanks C7 so you have to defend that
first and then try to play Knight E7
definitely like white though I think you
might still take a stab at 97 because
Knight takes C7 Queen C6 I think your
idea is really strong also 97 is the
benefit of opening the path for the C
pawn and he's here it is he played
Deadpool solve his problems tactically
wow given Jules time less than two
minutes not a bad idea
Queen A6
and then um
yeah Queen he says Queen F3 you're
looking crazy what is that wow that was
a great move man Dimitri is like a beast
97 anyway
that's nine games in a row now decided
decisively in Dimitri's uh chess kid cup
so far I was like draw what draw what I
failed art class boy I don't have no
pencils no pins we don't draw anything
around here boy and I take C7 wow it's
on the board yeah maybe that variation
you mentioned James uh about to happen
long variation but uh very likely now
Joel committed that white knight does
have it root back into the game imagine
having nine decisive games but now all
you want is a draw you would give all
your money now right now if you're
Dmitry that's so funny
okay the queen traps the Knight the
Knight has to retreat giving back the
pawn
temporarily a pawn up for white but that
won't last much longer anything else
here I'm looking for tricks some E6 but
no there's just not enough kindling on
the king side you've got that Bishop on
C3 which is just itching to attack G7
but you need a Supporting Cast ooh
speaking of supporting cats Bishop A5
what a gutsy call there by Jewel trying
to orchestrate some more tension that
Knight is pretty safely defended by the
bishop I gotta say yeah great awareness
I wasn't even my radar
looks clumsy but if you can cement your
knight on that square it's uh yeah
you've won a pawn in the process as well
I do worry about the white king slightly
look at the black Bishop pointing
towards it the black queen pointing
towards it the black knight ever kind of
creeps towards that white king could be
real danger but for now under control
you'll Pawn up maybe he's gonna win this
one could we see an Armageddon I haven't
seen one for a while that's true and
it's possible it is very possible that
was a signal Bishop A5 definitely was
not on the radar there we definitely
were all looking 95 there Bishop Big
Five though and he's asking questions
what do you do next Dimitri what are you
gonna play now Queen G6 and Knight C6 is
tempting but once the bishop drops back
white once again has control over the D5
Square so it's not like the Knight on C7
is permanently stranded it can move away
and Dimitri instead he takes a different
route he trades on D1 first and now
slides this queen over to H6 all the way
to the right to attack that F4 Pawn
interesting call and this is going to
come down to a wild time scramble yeah
the good thing for Jewel is he can
defend both of these weak Pawns in one
swoop with his Queen and as mentioned
the Black Knight anytime it moves will
allow the White Knight back either to
the square or this square and uh okay
crazy stuff happening he's gone the
other way hitting the white Bishop this
bishop is most likely going to retreat
and White's still a pawn up beautiful
square right later the bar is like whoa
I mean look at the bar and a beautiful
Square for the white Bishop as well on
C3 just controlling all the jumping
squares for Black Knight Stakes control
of D4 takes control of B4 and once E6
comes you block out the connection
between the black queen and the Knight
there would be a lot of pressure he just
simply falls back and when you have to
make a move like that you know that
things have gone already very wrong for
black 66 or 57 I mean at this point I
think it's just over
could well be over just push forward and
the Black Knight if it ever moves as you
mentioned that Daniel white is the first
to crash through ring through against
the black king that's 100 D7 and Dimitri
with 45 seconds on the clock big big
trouble here he can't move the Knight
because of E6 well the good news for
black is the bishop and C5 still keeps
the Knight on E7 defend it but if not
Knight G6 it's hard to come up with a
move for black
I'll press that resign button yeah you
can hit the button you could definitely
hit the button absolutely 25 seconds
we saw that decision giving up the open
file a good tip for chess kids at home
do not allow your opponent's Rooks to
dominate open lines especially if you
have passive Rooks okay he's trying to
correct that mistake by bringing his
Rook down uh across and then down
towards the white king but it feels too
slow oh beautiful classic Schoolboy
right there if the Rook moves back to B1
it opens up the eighth rank tons of meat
threats on the seventh rank as well E6
is coming
this is such an easy position to play
with 30 seconds yeah and these are the
hardest moves to respond to your
opponent simply sidesteps with the King
you don't have a check you have to play
fast so hard to play a move and we see a
mistake that Knight G6 the e-pawn
advances the bishop had to fall back to
defend the G7 pawn and juice just
continues to put pressure E7 coming up
next this is game over
yeah he's so good especially with white
Jewel every time I see him he just
smoothly finds the best squares for his
pieces and then strikes tactically when
given an opportunity it's uh really
impressive Black forced to give up a
bishop for that strong white Pawn but
this is just delaying the end prolonging
the inevitable now white has a whole
extra bishop and it's not just any
Bishop it's extremely strong A3 what is
that
initiating the queen side attack
wow 10 seconds but we can't see it on
Dimitri colas that in fact it is all
over he does hit the resign button which
means boys we are going to have an
Armageddon super excited whenever that
is the situation this match goes down to
the wire we will be having the players
bid for their time and that is the
action that's coming up before that for
Fabiano caruana it has been a great day
in the office David he made it look
smooth
oh Fabiano yes he did make it look
smooth and uh it was actually decided In
The End by a heartbreaking blunder
blinking you miss it it happened so
quickly just an action replay of that
final move it was here actually after a
really tricky idea a real really
devilish uh kind of trap here from
farrugia he brought his Rook across
threatening Bishop D5 threatening this
pin along the diagonal Fabi reacted
really nicely with Quint G4 a double
attack hitting this Pawn in conjunction
with the rook and remember that this
bishop is attacked version here he
simply forgot that uh one of his Bishops
was loose he could have maybe flicked in
at check first of all or he could have
tried a trick of his own potentially
bringing his Bishop forward trying to
set up a mating attack to the black King
instead however he blundered after Queen
G4 he retreated his Bishop forgetting
that this one is no longer protected by
The Rook Queen takes bishop and Fabiano
progresses
a one move blunder but that was the
result of so much pressure that was on
the board some super GM level tactics
there sees a Fabiano caruana Advance
through to in the loser's bracket it is
the end of the road for alireza faruja
meanwhile the other match does go down
to the Armageddon and of course we'll
have that action coming up really soon
but before that we are being joined by
the winner Fabiano caruana from Madrid
Fabi hey congratulations
thanks Tanya
it was a really fun match to watch wild
chess did feel as messy as it looked
probably even more so yeah the first
game was it was a miracle uh that's I
think the only way to put it
I was two pawns down and
maybe on a very good day you draw that
position with some luck but winning it
is almost unthinkable
and at the end he had this queen E4 move
which was just completely winning that
would be game over but of course when it
gets down to seconds anything can happen
and um yeah I guess that he wasn't fully
there today because also the second game
uh this blender at the end really shows
that he wasn't seeing the the board very
clearly
yeah
but Fabi do you think that is all the
pressure that kind of precedes all of it
and the format of the situation because
we do see these mating ones which and
these one more blunders by the very best
in the world which are really hard to
explain
well I think Ali Reza's initial made in
one blunder was was probably a mess
although I'm not sure if we ever got
confirmation on that but yeah these
these games are super tense I have to
say and two game matches especially uh I
mean four game matches you have a bit of
leeway right you you don't feel as much
pressure in the early games because you
um you can always come back but two game
match very often that's just it uh so
like Hikaru uh you know against
uh against alireza right it was as soon
as you get into some pressure then you
already feel like you're going to get
kicked out of the tournament and um and
yeah when you're already in the losers
bracket you might feel a bit of extra
pressure because you don't even have
that second Lifeline so
so it was a lot of attention I have to
say that the second game right up until
the end until he blundered a piece I was
I was extremely nervous I
[Music]
um
because even though the position is
probably okay for me and I felt like it
should be okay and probably better a bit
earlier
um you know you can easily get a losing
position from this I mean he he has the
sort of material balance where if he
gets an attack it could just be the end
of the game so I was really really
nervous and um and it ended kind of
prematurely uh to my to my great Fortune
it was a very tense match and uh Fabi
you go through we've got a big
Armageddon coming up in the other
matchup with the Jules musad and Dimitri
Kola is going to ask you do you have a
preference of who you want to play
tomorrow and also a prediction about the
Army Garden
oh I you know I've never played colors
in anything besides like Blitz uh like
title Tuesday we played but I don't
think I've ever played him I actually I
might have played him in a blitz
tournament in Germany in 2019 and now
that I'm thinking about it but but we
haven't played too many like really
serious games so he would be a new
opponent for me and Jewel I uh I'm
actually quite quite friendly with him
but we haven't played too much as well
uh but he we played one match in the RCC
last year the the rapid championship and
and it was a very very fun match he he's
uh he's extremely dangerous uh colars is
a bit of a wild card for me so maybe I
would prefer Jewel a little bit because
I know a bit more what I'm getting into
I have a bit more familiarity with him
but yeah I'll watch the Armageddon now
that'll be that'll be very fun for sure
it gonna be a lot of fun and thank you
so much Bobby for joining us all
thank you
I'll be honor kaiwana does wrap it up in
two games winning the first one and
enjoying the second one we've got big
Armageddon action coming up don't go
anywhere we'll be right back after this
twitch break
[Music]
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing but chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking chess kid features a
comprehensive training program that
guides kids to level up on their way to
Mastery there are more than 50 000 chest
bustles and a whole library of
entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids chess kit is
easy whether you're a parent helping
your child a coach managing dozens of
kids or a school of hundreds signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
at Magnus Academy we've taught chess to
a hundred thousand kids with Summer
around the corner we're gearing up for
camps
at online chess camps kids learn about
Chess in a safe fun environment from a
team of All-Star coaches
kids are grouped by skill level from
beginners up to national champions there
are never more than eight kids per coach
so every child gets plenty of attention
you might even get the chance to meet
Magnus and ask him a question or
challenge him to a game
each week has a different theme like
opening traps learning from your losses
or Magnus Carlson's best games
sign up by May 31st to get a 30 discount
join the 100 000 Kids and Counting that
have learned chess with Magnus chess
Academy
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever
records and trophies first and only game
changing Innovations from the heroes we
admire to the joy of watching them play
our history defines us inspires us and
pushes us into the future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster
we've been seeing amazing shots being
played all around fighting Dynamic play
by the best players in the world and
well once upon a time they too were
chess kids this is the chess kit cup and
just a couple of days ago David did meet
a very special chess kid and it was in
London one of the biggest chest Islands
in England and we will be later on
showing the big story with badana
sivanandan who is truly someone to look
out for
[Music]
my goal is to become the youngest I'm GM
in the world or if not then the youngest
GM in the UK after that I want to play
in the world championships and get world
champion I think it will be Harvard I
still think I can do it
foreign
s and Ambitions and she finished second
in the English Championship for women in
Blitz some amazing performance there by
bodana and we're seeing some amazing
performances in the other two divisions
as well Simon we are indeed but before
we go there I do just want to mention I
played that young girl I went along to
uh Harrow chess club in England and I
was playing against about 20 people she
was about this high and I thought yeah
you know easy you know she had plunder a
queen after a couple of moves
and she smashed me absolutely destroyed
me and I was like who the hell is this
player she's so strong so she's going to
be really good coming up and I'm very
much looking forward to that interview
but um yeah let's have a look at the
results going on in division two and
three so we're going to start with
division two and let's remember there's
the winners bracket and the losers
bracket and you get a double Chance in
This and the winner of division two and
it's getting closer and closer to the
end we'll go to division one and get ten
thousand dollars so we saw uh there
throng go through against operand and
feather Seth was just a bit of a better
class there against sad wani so well
done there to those players are then
going on to the losers brackets everyone
in grade air has gone home and it's a
bit of a surprise there David Anton uh
KIRO Alex senko but lost a very strong
AGA King iliano and uh well we still got
some strong players in there but uh it's
really heating up there
how division to the losers brackets and
this is who's left in and the pairings
we've got coming up and this is going to
be really tough you can see that a
couple of players from Vietnam there
which is uh great to see but they're
both facing Veterans of the game Dimitri
Adrian King and Mama jarov so can uh can
these players from Vietnam put up with
uh these uh really tough players but
Liam Lee of course is a legend in his
own right Alan pitcho did go through and
he did beat Harry Krishna and this is
the the Winner's final or division three
and that means that Alan Petro is a
great chance to win that division so
there's been Lots going on lots to catch
up on and uh the players still in must
be getting very excited about winning
the whole thing now and here again
players more players going home here
players after players and uh you've got
Sam sevion winning a fantastic match
there against you Yang Yi Yu yangy
incredibly strong player
um and donachenko beating Vali Echo that
was a very close match and the legend
David Navara also progressing against
the Igor lysi uh gadakamski as well I
always like seeing garakamski through
and we got the All-American Clash who's
gonna win that guys I don't know that's
youth versus experience and there as I'm
a bit of an old man myself I'm gonna go
for the old man there come on you are a
legend after all and then we have
donachenko versus David Navara there
um so there's a lot of stuff going on
there isn't there loads of stuff to
catch up on I will catch a breath in a
second and just chill
that was amazing Simon thank you so much
for all those updates you were asking
about Sam Savion while Sam did win the
division three of the air things Masters
he's got a big one against the famous
fun Legend Gaddy garakamusky coming up
so Simon we look forward to you to
having you back in the studio to tell us
more about that but right now there's
more action with an army Garden coming
up uh Simon before we let you go what
are your predictions is there a favorite
in the armor Gardens
anything can happen here I don't know
whose favorite I don't think there is
one
wow it's a format that's so destructive
in chess that we call it the Armageddon
flagging is a definitely encouragement
there is no time increment at all we are
waiting for the player bids and of
course the question as always is how low
can you go and as we wait for the beds
these this is the format going into the
Armageddon the player with the lower bit
wins gets to choose the color black has
got result odds which means that if it's
to draw black goes through white has to
win on demand James what about you do
you have a preference of color in this
do you want more time or do you want
rods I always want the drawers because
of course anything can happen when
you're playing these guys here it's very
fast and like sometimes you should spot
a draw like oh I'll just take this and a
force draw somehow some way from a
mistake from your opponent we win the
game you draw I win I win I win I always
love that option
it is a big question the players have to
answer what time do they want to bid for
and David these are two players who
haven't had that much experience in the
bidding Armageddon what are you
expecting are you expecting to expecting
them to fall really low to try and get
black I'm not so sure I think both
players are very confident both players
have had so many decisive games at this
point that they would they wouldn't be
too disappointed with the white pieces
take the extra time go for the win
anyway in normal time in the early rapid
games both sides one with white so
actually having the black pieces having
less time not necessarily that big an
advantage maybe not as big an advantage
it would be for more solid players like
uh Carson and Nakamura as we've seen in
the past and if you had to draw a bid
line do you think 10 minutes would be
it's a reasonable line now I will add
that both of these players very
accomplished in Blitz and bullet Dimitri
is about 3050 chess.com lets he's
improved a lot in the last couple of
months Jules of course he needs no
introduction just very well entitled
Tuesdays so in a Time scramble it's very
hard to choose a favorite but both
players they're experienced enough that
they're comfortable to go pretty low but
Dimitri has struggled with the black
pieces overall in this tournament so
that factors into his consideration I'm
sure as well Tanya wow and Daniel we are
getting news that the bids are ready and
let's reveal the bids as they are Jews
out with 10 minutes 47 seconds he loses
the bid to Dimitri kolas with nine
minutes 29 seconds Dimitri colas will
play with the black pieces Jules starts
with 15 minutes has the white pieces the
shoes has to win and oh my God guys we
were talking about the bid line it is
around the 10 minute Mark using nine and
a half minutes is that a pragmatic bid
by Dimitri kolas
I think it's logical from both sides
nine and a half is still plenty of time
it's enough to play several Blitz Games
or even bullet games if you want but uh
of course having less than five minutes
or having sorry more than five minute
disadvantage deficit compared to your
opponent could be significant a bit
later on color choosing black which is
predictable I think most players they
want the black pieces but again the
opening Tanya it's going to be crucial
the first 10 moves
I really wonder what he's going to do
and another open Voice same we've seen
before when I have a I don't remember
was it today yes five minutes ago it's
good to have a Goldfish Memory in chess
sometimes you forget the defeats and you
just focus and interesting that jewel is
the first one to differ he won the
previous game but he switches things up
now by dropping his Bishop back uh
normally when you kind of copy an
opening when you play it again you
assume your opponent is going to come
prepared with an improvement something
better than the last time and uh yeah
the players barely had a break but uh
clearly Jewel has studied this and same
position but now there's no pin Black's
light Square Bishop cannot come to the
G4 Square because white has shuffled the
pawn up to H3 very very tense position
uh what do you make of this uh James Is
it wise to repeat in a must-win
situation for white uh yeah probably
repeat uh I mean especially if you
looked at the line like hey oh you know
what I'm just going to check the line
real quick just real fast and make a few
changes and then we'll go from there if
he did that here but I think it worked
form and Roy Lopez is nice it actually
is solid and it gives you great chances
everybody knows about the Roy and it's a
potential and how rich and complex the
game is with that I think actually
Theory why is that the move is Knight D4
and you play F4 F5 in many cases so see
what he see what he comes up with here
man you could go Knight D2 as well
yeah makes a lot of sense to get rid of
that black knight in the center of the
board there we go black tries to
entrench the Knight but on passant
capturing the pawn as if it just moved
one square and uh Black's Knight forced
back so black does have the queen side
majority but Black's King slightly less
safe because it only has two pawns for
shelter whites has three and that could
become relevant in a blitz uh finish
later on Daniel yeah but I like this
Choice by Dimitri because with the open
Center there's a high probability of
minor piece trades Bishop E6 to F5 comes
to mind and with every trade the further
the position simplifies the easier it is
to play so the next five six moves going
to be crucial you could also bring your
Rook into the center with Rook a to E8
and typically white plays very
positionally for the dark Square control
Knight D2 to B3 and then to D4 so that's
what you want to try to prevent if
you're Mr callers eight minutes though
he's gotta watch his clock very very
carefully no increment here and rookie
eight is on the boardski yeah he spent
about 40 seconds for that move and he
doesn't have that luxury too often with
only eight minutes left you can't really
afford to spend more than a minute on
any other move and I'm expecting like
you say Jewel to uh start you mentioned
knowing how the knights move he's got to
start juggling uh jumping around with
his Knights right now those two Bishops
especially the white dark Square Bishop
stuck needs to activate
I would be inclined to maybe go towards
the white king I'm just a scaredy cat
I'm scared I'll get checkmated if I
don't to bring my knight uh back towards
it to help out with the defense but also
the White Knight jumper to B3 very
logical strategically desirable so uh
very tense white still has a five minute
clock Advantage he needs to speed up he
needs to maintain that for later and
that's really important for Jules he has
to play the clock as much as the board
he can't let slip out the clock
Advantage because that would just give a
clear draw odd to Dimitri colas let's
again remind everyone that Jules with
white he has to win this game a draw
means that kolars he goes through and
with the trades that we are seeing we
can expect more pieces to be traded off
on the e-file ideas of the night jumping
on F4 Knight H5 Knight F4 a potential
King side attack is it fair to say James
that Dimitri should be happy about the
opening outcome absolutely I mean all
his pieces are developed I mean that's
what they say In classical and just easy
chess principle chess say if you will is
develop develop your pieces get him off
the back rank make sure everything's
connected connect your Rooks calcium
King he has everything he also has an
open file he may be able to work with
stuff like maybe even Knight E4 and
sacking on F3 there's a really crazy uh
opportunities here 985 to F4 is also a
thing maybe bishop H3 at some point if
you get a bishop to D6 lots of ideas for
black but you do have to time everything
correctly here there's a weak Pawn on D5
not isolated but weak just a little bit
you have the pieces defending to get no
Pawn really but I do like both sides
actually I like the dynamicism of black
because my pieces are already ready
everything's just compact together
everything's developed I do like black
slightly here but you do have to be
careful because the king is slightly
weak for white for black
yeah it's interesting you would take
black I think I would take white just
because my king is safe it's just one
factor and Blitz you don't get checked
mated you might win on time it literally
looks a little confused he he hasn't
made a move and
something happened there
you've been disconnected Something's
Happened oh let's see does he have three
bars seem right
once I was playing title Tuesday my
mouse ran out of battery halfway through
it happened to me many times oh man
probably in the chest says this is a
dangerous variation
but it cost him a whole minute one move
and this was one of the most logical
moves as you mentioned Daniel yeah there
was also Knight F6 to E4 trying to go
more ambitiously in this area if you're
playing this with black you have to be
ready to part ways with a pawn sometimes
even a bishop on H3 but you also want to
steer clear of variations that require
heavy calculations so a practical Choice
by Dimitri Joel can trade the Bishops on
F5 and play Knight F3 to D4 but you have
to keep a very close eye on the pressure
on the F2 Pawn because after Queen takes
F5 black will have two heavy pieces
doubled up on that f file yeah you've
got to be really careful here for
example after a nitrate I'm really
worried that my head that might be a
queen sacrifice definitely don't go for
this and uh okay I'm assuming that in
this position maybe what white will do
instead is just to trade and then jump
forward with this Knight to one of these
two squares kick the black queen away
from Adventure Zone
and uh sure okay he does go for the
trade the White Knight is going to
Spring out now surely maybe this one for
example the white The Black Queen goes
back somewhere and the white Bishop can
just sit nice and pretty
well I don't know black Bishop as well
gonna start hitting the White Knight it
feels like Dimitri's got a very healthy
position but only seven minutes left
yeah Fabby confirms Knight f60 E4 there
was an important move to keep the
objective balance feels like Jules
starting to get what he wants massaging
those dark squares in the center
repelling black pieces from the King
side he's got a small Edge and he's kept
a pretty sizable advantage on the clock
yeah for now but it's being eaten away
slowly it's uh only now a three and a
half minute Advantage he started with a
five and a half minute Advantage from
move one so Jewel not keeping the same
Pace as Dimitri
okay he did kick back the black queen
but what next he needs to generate
something with white at least Force
Dimitri into those longer things force
him to calculate as you say
and uh yeah I'm not sure what I would do
here with white you gotta start with
principles like you have to get the
pieces of the bank look at the queen and
the bishop and the A1 Rook have not
moved you just gotta get him off the
back right the question is where Queen
D3 okay thank you thank you appreciate
it I'm just trying to figure out what
he's gonna do and that's what he played
queen of D3 get that off the back ring
good start there maybe go Bishop G5 and
Rick a to d okay Bishop D6 now
some Queen side squares oh thank you Wes
maybe A4 at some point okay yeah it's
interesting lots of ideas but you've got
to decide you've got to move quickly
now three minute and Counting the
advantage of slipping away visual you
just need to decide commit maybe bring
your Bishop out trade works whatever
just make a move
objectively the position does look
absolutely fine for Dimitri colors but
this will come down to a Time scramble
the last movie is hinting to trade off
the minor pieces to destroy white skin
side Bond structure and control that E4
Central Square try and jump in with that
Knight at the right moment you have to
watch out for the D5 Pawn as well Bishop
G5 played James you were talking about
develop your pieces it's on the board
David yeah and uh the previous comment
that the previous tweet by Fabiano said
he was planning to try this with white
LOL
has been revealed that's the problem at
top level chess if someone else plays
your idea before then everyone becomes
aware of it and uh there we go Fabi
tuning in shout out hey and uh well done
today mentioned that he'll be following
the Armageddon all right congrats Fabi
congrats fabulous Bobby see how we baby
we gotta get some gear to you you
already know Fabiano Carolina in the
chat good to have you after a really
cool win against Sally Reza absolutely
no Armageddon was needed in that one fun
but let's get back to this so the bishop
and knights have been traded at night
has jumped on e4 the good news is that
white can't capture that Knight on e4
because there's a rook on yet that does
defend it even though the D5 Pawn is
banned and Fabi was also commenting
about 94. I think he meant a bit earlier
but that Black Knight on e4 looks just
as powerful now now as it did uh and
okay H6 is he getting ready really to
kick back that white Bishop you don't
really want to push too many points in
front of the black king here as Jewel
yeah you just got to move quickly just
bring that rook in bring activate the
last piece bring it to the party and
some threats now suddenly for white I
don't like H6 I think he did fall in
love with the G5 idea maybe he thought
White's Bishop has to retreat to E3 then
there are some exchange sacks on F3 but
the bishop can go all the way back to C1
in order to maintain the contact between
the queen and the G3 pawn and from my
experience in non-increment positions
the last thing you want is permanent
King weakness because that literally
forces you to sink so much time into
making sure that you don't blunder
something like a check on it could be
very very unpleasant the Knight on C6 is
also hanging so a check on G6 could be
utterly devastating as it is in the
variation that David is showing yeah G5
on the board I think he's gonna retrieve
his Bishop did cross my mind that it
takes might be an idea but I'm too lazy
to calculate that one Rook takes Knight
utilizing the fact that there are some
pins here
woof Rook takes Force for example Queen
takes rook and all of the trades all of
the captures at the end my goodness
there's some craziness that was too much
let's just Retreat the bishop and uh
yeah Black's King extremely weak
looks good this porn was so vulnerable I
don't really see what Black's next move
is
in this position nothing easy at least I
think Jewel should just make a practical
decision here just Retreat the bishop
the whole way back and Black's King
is going to come back towards him later
in the game
turn G5 on the board lots of pieces
hanging the Knight on e4 the bishop on
as we were looking at these lines if
Jose was to retreat with the bishop it
will force Dimitris to burn the clock
and that is the big strategy in
Armageddon you leave all the big
decisions for when your opponent is down
on the second it's not about getting a
winning position out of the opening or a
big Advantage just keeping as much
pressure as many pieces on the board and
so far
Queen 67 he takes on D5 and takes on e4
I think he might have overlooked Rook to
d8 at the end of that line or there's
some tactic I don't know exactly I guess
Rook D Queen B3 but this smells really
badly David there's also Rook takes F3
right there must be a tactical flaw with
this move yeah Dania talk us through
your thought process here white has just
nabbed upon the whole idea is Queen
takes Bishop will be met by Queen takes
Pawn check and next move you want to
take the Knight but as you say you can
for example move your king and this Rook
d8 moves this is what he's missed surely
yeah miraculously you have Queen B3 but
Rook takes F3 this actually it might be
what he missed
my lands girl is that forced yeah if you
take I guess black just recaptures this
Rook is poisoned you don't even get a
draw after gf3 which would be tantamount
to a loss you actually lose the Rook
after Queen takes F3 check so this isn't
even a Perpetual it wins the game out
right Dimitri got a gift here he just
has to go down the forced path and does
he have enough time under five minutes
you need the discipline now to sit on
your hands and calculate your whole way
through if you just take this picture
oh my
oh my God and now this bishop is not
trapped it can Retreat it can escape
white has just won a pawn for free I've
seen Dimitri find harder tactics in a
bullet game that's what nerves do to you
whoa key moment and he just didn't have
the time I think he was panicking he was
looking at the clock under five minutes
just gotta move but uh it would have
been kind of a great investment there
just spending one or two of those
remaining four minutes he would have won
the game on the spot and he would have
progressed to the next round
wow that was super dramatic and it often
also happens that you just tend to trust
your opponent they go for this sacrifice
these tactics and you feel it has to be
right it's something that they couldn't
have missed and had Dmitry just slowed
down and calculated that line to the end
this would have been his match but now
it's another game on our hands Dimitri
goes for 95 trying to trade up more
pieces but it still feels under control
I see the eval bar it loves White's
position extra Pawn D5 weakness is it
going to be hard to hold this one with
black
it's just so open also look at the white
king there's going to be a trade of
knights in the center of the ward any
moment but the white king can just
Shuffle to the H2 Square where it's so
nicely protected it's like in a bubble
uh surrounded by its own pawns and
whites King's gonna be safe the black
king if any white pieces break through
it's a bit like that game between heroin
and uh farouza oh yeah if any white
piece breaks through that black king is
going to be so open also the white
Bishop has a beautiful perch in the
center of the board on D4 yeah as Fabi
says then the twitch chat Rook takes F3
at the end of that long long variation
easy to miss he would have needed to
calculate like seven or eight moves in
advance we can forgive him for that but
it was a critical turning point no we
can't we should kick him out of the
tournament right now one six move tactic
and an Armageddon game unacceptable
all right poor Dimitri it's going to
turn on that one moment it's as if it's
like poker your opponent has no good
cards and they've kind of shoved
everything in and you just sometimes
you've got to call the bluff the game is
not over far from over but it feels like
he's so close to crumbling here there's
Rook takes you for related tactics this
king is weak Joker just centralize his
Bishop on D4 double Rooks in the E file
and start trying to bleed black Black's
clock down there's also B3 and C4 which
could undermine that Knight on e4 it
goes Rock F1 that type of move trying to
rest control of that important Avenue to
Black's king and a lot of the chess kits
out there might be wondering which
pieces should both sides be trying to
exchange what do we think here
what does white want to get off the
board well okay Rick F5 actually
happened yes keep the bonds on the board
right maybe that's right yeah of course
I mean we're up we're up a little bit
right three six so yeah we got the pawn
I figure we just grabbed the ball and go
grab it we got five Queen D5 get into
zmz
one point rotates Queen takes D5 rotates
Rook takes and queen E4 whoa what is his
idea then yeah I think he's just uh
hoping that he can survive that end game
the problem is with pawns on both sides
of the board the bishop will be superior
to the Knight if the Queens are off
we've seen the queen of night combo
together how dangerous they can be so
get the Queens off just as soon as
possible avoid any check mating tricks
and I think Jules gonna go for it I
might go G4 first is that possible
licking G4 hit the black queen makes a
lot of sense as well
because I don't like Queen takes taste
takes in a knight G3 I mean obviously
I'm still winning there yeah G4 there we
go and you snap it awesome oh but this
checks you gotta be careful here
let's check buddy
Retreat it nice Square nice Outpost for
that Bishop now front for black is if
the queens and Rooks disappear then long
term black has weaknesses on the king
side those black pawns on H6 and G5 are
fixed on dark squares easy targets for
the white bishop and the black king will
be forced to stay around that area of
the board to defend them so even if the
queens and Rooks come off no safety for
black no closer to the draw it's not
clear what you hope for here with uh if
you're Dimitri colors uh one good Trump
in Black's position is that Knight only
four it's an active piece it's something
that cannot be challenged and it
controls a lot of squares gives activity
for white it gives activity for black
white just has to play around it another
Rook trade has been offered you don't
want to relinquish the control of the
app file so it's hard to avoid it
yep to E6 just defending the black Rook
uh the one thing I would say for Dimitri
is look at the clock times they've
nearly level down now only 30 second
difference so who's gonna flag who later
on that might be a big question uh it
could well come down to a Time Scramble
with 30 seconds left this game's still
far from being decided Rook F3 he's
saying okay we can trade but it's on my
terms
really really tense that's a nice move
just forcing the opponent to burn a bit
of clock deciding what to do with the
tension yeah sometimes I forget actually
that there is no increment you know when
you get the Armageddon and sometimes I
mean it's easy to forget you have no
increment yeah you've been playing
increment this whole time for forever
and now you have none so you actually
have to move a little faster you had to
calculate a little bit quicker here Rick
F3 was a nice move Queen G6 now Bishop
F6 is a funny looking move but I
wouldn't I wouldn't play around with
that kind of stuff actually might have
been nuts but Rook F6 actually might
have been good to force the Rook trade
yeah Rook takes takes in any case he's
just kind of maintaining the tension
here of course white has to be very
careful not to allow some sort of
Perpetual right when the Knight moves
away Queenie one check you have to keep
an eye on that he repeats once
is not to be trifled with but again
keeping the tension don't repeat
whatever you do maybe now's the time
just to take that Rook enough seven and
replace the Rook on F3 with a queen yeah
I think he's gonna go for it he's messed
around enough he's seen enough ghosts
enough forks and uh just get the Queens
off there we go very logical stuff from
Jewel
and it's night on e4 that we've been
talking about white wanting to trade on
his terms the black does capture that
Queen the Jeep on gets undoubled not
only that takes control of the E4 Square
so Queen F3 would not be an ideal trade
in this position for black how does he
maintain this tension does he simply
sidestep with the queen queen to E6
how White's Queen is coming forward as
well though exactly I don't know it's
really hard to keep things together for
uh Dimitri here he just needs to move I
actually think his best bet is on the
clock okay he's trying to force the
trade again on his terms now I'm gonna
credit you had to play Queen E6 because
Queen F5 there actually failed
tactically but I could have picked up
the F Pawn now I just cannot see him
saving this 30 seconds down David so
important that pawn on H6 being a
long-term weakness white maybe has to
open a second front on the queen side I
think he's gonna make it happen though
yeah Bishops versus Knights pawns on
both sides of the board you know which
one you pick every time it is the bishop
the long range piece the Black Knight
can hop about short kind of short range
no matter where it goes though it can
never gobble up any of those white pawns
and the white king is coming easy access
as soon as the white Bishop kind of
moves out the way the white king you can
see it darting towards that side of the
board and yeah hard to plug all those
holes hard to keep everything covered
where's he dancing okay he's going back
to cover the entry Square on D4 so he's
going to sit on the Square with the
Black Knight and hope he has a fortress
but this is the flimsiest Fortress I've
ever seen it's not going to stay intact
for too long two minutes against three
minutes what do we think enough time for
white not at all oh for white yes
absolutely for black now this is very
easy in game here I mean just up upon
clean we make that we push when we need
to the right moment wait I know about A3
though that created an unnecessary
Target I would have gotten G3 H4 H5 and
really fixed that weak Pawn in H6 and
then at the right moment pushed C4 right
and open up a second front whatever you
do don't give away all three of your
queen side pawns and don't go C4 now
because that blunder is a fork on E5
yeah A3 you're right just really
unnecessary to commit to that move why
not just move around for 15 moves first
and then push pawns and put pawns on
light squares opposite colors your
Bishop that's what you should be doing
in these end games all right now what
you should be doing is making a move
because it's come down to about two
minutes on the clock and the good news
for Dimitri is that he's got a night
night's can be super tricky when it
comes to these armageddon's first a
black gets the king to the center to
defend that D5 Pawn looking for a way to
jump around the board with that Knight
I'm expecting a maneuver starts with
Knight A5 you can't push that beep on
the Knight would jump into C4 things are
not easy regardless of what the eval Bar
says right now it is going to be about
who Flags who
when you get his King to the center that
could be problematic as uh okay wait 94
and Eva went crazy four forces the king
back to F7 I thought Dimitri should have
started with King E5 yep if he had
gotten his King to E4 yep white would
have been making backward progress
correct what happened that Dimitri
reacted again he leaned back as if
Something's Happened has his mouth
Frozen has
Something's Happened
his clock is not Frozen
there's definitely a problem with the
internet there
look at jumu side he does not want to
win this way he's not even looking at
the screen right now he knows
something's happened and
I don't know the regulations if he gets
disconnected no increment it's the worst
possible game to experience internet
problems you aren't getting this time
back yeah to be fair it is he's back but
he's lost 30 seconds on the clock yep
he's back he's lost 40 50 seconds on the
clock there and every second counts he
was level on time
but now Dimitri surely not enough time
to save this game
G3 I would throw that move and he goes
A4 C4 he's a lot of night jump but the
Knight falls back on C6
white is going to break at some point
with C4 Pawn to C4 he might even do it
now and that white king is going to come
that black a pawn is a huge Target
remember how bad Knights are against
these Corner pawns the a h pawns if
white gets a past a pawn it's game over
trying to get all the pawns off the
board though however Dimitri call us
oh
it's reacted again yeah something's
going on Something's Happened that's
tough I was juled musad's move right now
but we just hope that Dimitri's
connection holds but of course there are
problems on the board as well and a
small point you notice how the H Pawn is
the right color it may or may not matter
at some point but the white Bishop a
dark Squad Bishop the H Pawn if it ever
comes down to it the h8 square is of the
right color the Knight jumps in
King D4 less than a minute on the clock
hopeless position as well unfortunately
the Black Knight can only fight on one
side of the board and at the right
moment first he'll prepare it but at the
right moment the white king would Dart
it will Sprint towards that black Apon
even now you would Google can you see
five you can even give away your king
side pawns but there's no reason to do
that and for the younger people watching
Jules ultimate Allegiance is to the
moves on the board he's taking as long
as it needs because he knows that he can
convert an extra Queen with even 20
seconds on the clock now it's smooth
sailing H4 bang undermining the Knight
and that's it even with one pass spawn
would be almost impossible to save with
two it's game over yeah the only hope as
Tanya mentioned is actually to give up
the Black Knight for the white g-pawn
and somehow get the black king all the
way into the A8 corner but you're far
away from doing both unfortunately
so um yeah very classy move Bishop G5
very very classy right cutting off the
king and getting from the g-pawn he did
it with a knight on G6 with Bishop G3
and on Knight on D5 Bishop G5 dominating
that Black Knight
yeah really nice pattern when you have a
knight if there's two squares in between
put your Bishop there and the bishop
controls all the squares the Knight
wants to jump to okay where's he going
now okay seven maybe yeah Knight C4 and
A6 you can even sack the bishop in
certain situations again because the
Knight is so incompetent at stopping the
pastor but you don't need to I like how
he's put the bishop
away so no folks on the board no Force
please so before with Jordan against
King and pieces on the opposite side of
the board against Knights that's the
safest most practical way to do it 20
seconds each though is this gonna be a
race oh the queen happens though with
the Queens yes Brian Rosen trap maybe
but White's not even giving the queen
away for the night this feels like it's
just gonna end with a lot of checks
yeah pick up the night he took a second
oh
all right Joel 10 seconds E6 don't go
for it oh man 37 yeah
heartbreaking moment there for Dimitri
colas and he reacts it's been a tough
Armageddon by Jules Musa does go through
and he will be facing Fabiano caruana he
did keep everything under control and
even though not getting much out of the
opening Daniel he made sure that enough
pieces remained yeah and obviously
Dimitri had his share of chances the
internet problems it was a contributing
factor but that's just part and parcel
of online chess that's just what happens
sometimes I actually think 94 instead of
Bishop F5 in the opening would have been
a good chance to seize the initiative he
had his share of chances even in the end
game but ultimately with less time on
the clock fighting the other enemy of
the internet problems and with Jules
excellent technique it was not meant to
be great run for the young German
Grandmaster nonetheless great technique
that by Jules musad David was there ever
a moment that Dimitri could have held it
together I'm not sure there was after
that one critical tactic that he missed
earlier in the game when Jewel grabbed a
pawn and wasn't punished for doing so
and uh just to remind the audience this
one key moment is one to check out in
detail later on if you want to do some
analysis Bishop takes porn turned out to
be a bit of a blunder here it was a big
Bluff though and queen takes Bishop
would have won the game for Dimitri
colors this relies on the tactic that
Queen takes porn can simply be met by a
king move and after Rook takes Knight
there's this skewer the queen has to
retreat to defend its rook and now the
difficult one this is the one that he
most likely missed Rook takes Knight
after a trade here we would have seen
Pawn takes and the black queen swoops in
decisively to win the white Rook instead
as we saw Jewel wasn't punished for
grabbing that pawn he won the pawn and
went on to convert it in the end game
as Fabi mentioned the Rook F3 that was
the difficult move to find the things
would have been very very different had
Dmitry kola's been able to spot that
incredible tactic but failing to do that
it was an all Jewel show and there we
see in the Armageddon playing on seconds
he did win he goes through we will have
a Fabi versus Jules match up as these
are the two winners of the losers
quarter final bracket what amazing games
we've seen and more action continues as
we will be going into the winners a
bracket after the stretch break
foreign
[Music]
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids chess kid is
easy whether you're a parent helping
your child a coach managing dozens of
kids or a school of hundreds signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
and we are being joined by the winner of
that armaged
shoes is with us congratulations
thank you now this is too much for me I
cannot
crazy much tell us about it and
especially the the Armageddon how were
you feeling after getting the white
pieces
honestly I felt good
all of course
the wins
lost
through two games against future she
only made one draw so I felt very good
about it but my openings are very bad so
I don't know
wow Jules you've been uh last minute
replacement here at the Chaska cup and
you're still in the race to win the
tournament uh how are you feeling about
your chest so far
yeah my chest not very good because like
um I'm getting lucky I feel like even
this summer get them
um I think that my Bishop C7 was a bluff
kind of
um but I think he got some internal
issues and he lost focus at some point
so I'm feeling very lucky to be still
here fighting
Bishop C7 uh while the game was going on
did you see what was uh just working
with you did see that the Rook actually
idea no but uh yeah but no first I
thought that he has to block with Rook
F7 and then he cannot take on F3 with
the Rook because he's pinned but then I
thought what if King moves to G7 I guess
and then he can take on X3 and I don't
know it's a mess I'm not sure I have no
idea
I have no idea what's happening I mean
you know it's my first event like this
online and I'm feeling so much pressure
I cannot think like I usually think
and um like I I don't know it's weird
we are fitting but I'm happy to be here
of course
absolutely Jules while you've been
playing some very fun and entertaining
chess uh tomorrow you play against
Fabiano looking ahead your thoughts on
that matchup
no but you know I have to take revenge
from my uh country country friend
because
I took Revenge from him so now it's my
turn to do the same with Fabi I hope
so you're looking at it's a bit of a
grudge match there
we wish you all the best for that big
fight and we'll see you tomorrow
thank you see you bye
wins his match against collage Dimitri
after an absolutely a wild Armageddon
and the action of course continues we
will be having the Winner's bracket but
before that we have a very special
surprise
he's on three Army nominations for his
amazing role in the office the very
brilliant actor producer Rayne Wilson is
joining us to talk to us about a very
special project welcome rain
hello thanks for having me this is
fantastic I love being on the on chess
television this is fabulous
we're so excited as well to have you
here with us because we've heard about
your love and passion for the game but
before we talk about that uh uh rain I
have to say I'm from India I've been
reading all about the incredible work
that your organization lady Haiti has
been doing to empower girls and women in
very difficult communities I really want
you to tell our audience about the
amazing organization
great I'm I'm happy to so uh my wife and
I along with a bunch of friends in Haiti
uh in the Caribbean have been uh have
organized a non-profit that is an
educational initiative and we work with
about 900 girls in about 10 locations
it's called liday Haiti and uh we do
arts education and literacy we have
scholarships we have tutoring we have
health care for the girls these are
girls in very remote rural areas of
Haiti uh that otherwise wouldn't get an
education and we're really excited to be
partnering with uh chess.com for a
special fundraising event centered
around chess
yeah absolutely it's so inspiring to see
the work and the fundraising event that
you're talking about it's happening on
the 2nd of June tell us a little bit
about that
well
um Maurice Ashley is going to join the
Grand Master
um we've got some Haitian Chess Masters
that are going to join
um it's all about raising money for our
arts and literacy programs for these
girls and chess.com is starting out the
fundraising with a ten thousand dollar
gift and 400 chess sets and we want to
figure out how we'll get the chess sets
to the girls but uh figure out how to
teach them chess out there we haven't
quite spotted a a chess teacher in the
areas where we work but it's going to be
really excited it's exciting it's going
to be several hours of Chess playing and
banter and fun all for a great cause on
twitch.tv chess that sounds like
do you believe that Jessica
in this dream of empowering girls and
women who are in very difficult
challenges
yes I think chess greatly expands how
you use your brain how you use your mind
um it opens up possibilities it gives a
person confidence and I think it would
be really exciting for our girls to
learn chess and to have that as part of
their curriculum and you love playing as
well you played in pork charms 3 how's
your chess Journey going
well
um my chest goes up up and down when I
work on it I get better of course like
anything else it's just like working out
in the gym
um I'm a little flabby these days but
yes I was on the high school chess team
and uh I play with friends on chess.com
and um
I got into some shape for POG Champs
where I came in I came in second so I'm
getting ready for uh I'm open for other
chess tournaments uh and we'll see what
happens
we're excited to see you on the chess
board as well Ryan and I want to ask you
who's your favorite chess player in the
world
come on seriously
Magnus are you kidding me not even not
even a close second I'm really sorry to
everyone else uh but
um he's uh he's he's incredible so oh
there's me wearing my Magnus yeah Puma
chess shoes
wow that that's really fun and we can't
see rain there with the Clyde says thank
you so much rain and we're so excited
about the event on 2nd of June on
chesscom we wish you all the best and
continue doing the incredible work with
Lee De Haiti thank you thank you thank
you so much thanks for having me nice to
say hi
rain Wilson There He is uh Justin
a brilliant person Berlin the actor
doing amazing work there in with Alida
Haiti and right now we are back to the
amazing chess that we are going to be
seeing in the Winner's final it is
Jordan van Forest Dutch number two
taking on not the back Abdul satrobe now
Jordan bonforest did win the Tata steel
Masters in 2021 he has been on fire in
this chess kid cup not the backup De
Soto he's 18 years old he's an absolute
Phenom he has won the Olympic gold the
youngest level World rapid Champion so
many feathers in his cap and there could
have been one more feather in his Gap
and that would have been the Tata steel
Masters in 2023 if it wasn't for Jordan
Barn Forest who beat him in the very
last round Daniel is this a grudge match
for Northern back 150 200 there is
nothing better than a head-to-head match
uh to quell the desire for Revenge I'm
just a tour of is in great form to begin
with he's in the chess mindset being in
Stavanger getting ready for Norway chess
he always has his hands over a set from
the start of the game to the end if he
plays like he did yesterday against Fabi
Tanya I worry for Jordan
wow there we see not about with his paws
the chest pose that we've been seeing
him all along absolutely focused ready
to go this is the big Winners a final
Jordan banford starts with the white
pieces uh David are we expecting some
fun opening by Jordan yeah I think we're
at least hoping for some fun openings
from Jordan and he might need something
a bit magical to beat Abdul Torah if
Jordan's been great so far we should
mention he beat Hikaru Nakamura in a
match for example and oh my goodness
I think I've seen them before wow okay
some tech issues here it was a great
game don't get me wrong deserves an
action replay absolutely this was the
game between alarism and Fabiana caruana
but now we are at the game between
Jordan van forest and Abdul satorov it's
the Queen's Gambit declined
and uh Carlsbad Pawn structure what do
we think of this so far oh completely
boring but at the same time it is a
classical chess I mean you said Queen's
game of decline is the World
Championships opening right so it's
definitely a structures you need to know
the Carl's bat very easy to play right
Bishop F5 black uh I think absolute
Edition tour of great choice I mean
going with Queen's gaming declining is
somebody is creative as Jordan is I
think it's already pretty equal so far
down yeah this line is kind of like the
Berlin end game of one D4 openings it's
been popular for well over a decade of
Vladimir kramnik like this from the
black side of course black is the bishop
pair but in return he's got you know
completely ruined King side structure I
think the latest consensus that white is
a smidge better but black is just so
solid if he knows the defensive plans
here David I think you'll co-sign this a
lot of these games end in pretty
uneventful drools yes fully agreed I've
looked at this for both colors myself
I've never been brave enough to play it
with the with the black Pieces Just
because I'm a sucker for nice harmonious
important structures and I hate blacks
double death pawns but as you say if you
know the setups depending on what white
does if you know how to react then often
you are completely fine the one problem
piece for black actually it does turn
out to be that light Square Bishop the
black Bishop on G6 because often it does
get trapped behind your own pawns and uh
okay abduced a tour of bringing his
Bishop out creating a pin just uh saying
okay I don't need to commit yet your
White Knight on the edge of the board
looks nice and pretty it's on an outpost
technically but you don't have any
threats yet so a very flexible plate by
blackened I think this is good strategy
against Jordan who often wants those
attacking positions once that dynamism
in here it's very slow very strategic
and abdisator he's one of a kind he
knows how to handle those types of
positions despite his young age
absolutely very slow and uh the pawn
structures are always the ideas in fact
the skeleton of the punch or the
skeleton of the game it tell you what
the plans and ideas should be obviously
we want to have a minority attack so I
like this move Bishop B4 which kind of
deters the minority attack that you see
in the car Carlsbad structure he plays
A3 and allows Bishop takes C3 I actually
thought Rook C1 was to move there but he
uh allows the open file that you can't
really use yet Rook B1 is not a move and
unfortunately now Knight B6 to C4
something could happen there uh usually
they say that the square in front of the
pawn is the most important so I like the
Knight H4 idea from Jordan here as it
controls the F5 Square so we want to
maybe put a piece there B5 from Abdus 12
was really nice he took it really fast
just like prep or something like it must
be too fast kids these days they don't
care about Pawn structure they don't
care about Bishop pairs they just want
to play Dynamic chess what get open
lines for their pieces I'm scared for
white actually suddenly if Jordan isn't
prepared suddenly one of the black Rooks
might enter the B file and just crash
into the white position
and uh okay Rook takes Pawn also that
eight Pawn I mean A5 here is totally
possible followed by Knight B6 and A4 I
mean that Pawn's gonna be up your grill
before you even blink wow you're right
yeah this isn't that good White's
neglected development as well so it
might be a queenless position uh kind of
mix between a middle game and an end
game here but the Queens are off but
watch out for that white king if that
black Rook on h8 ever swings across and
gets down then you might regret not
having uh castled or at least having
developed a bit earlier in the game
with all these ideas the bishop and G6
controlling that B1 Square the a pawn
marching down the board it might be time
for white to start considering trading
that night for the bishop develop your
own bishop and get your Rook to be won
before black captures all the open files
are on the board that a pawn can be
super dangerous there's still stuff to
play for for Abdul satro of here
yeah just the speed which with which
they're going normally takes me like
three hours to get to move uh 17 let
alone her three minutes but uh King D7
it shows that both players must have
studied this before and I would slightly
prefer white even if you're forced to
make the really kind of
undesirable decision to play Knight
takes Bishop at some point Black's
Bishop doesn't necessarily prove to be a
good piece long term but it is peering
down at B1 as you say sometimes you have
to make a move that you're reluctant to
make like this one so the bishop for
Knight I prefer white but black has
everything covered black has a nice
structure now after recapturing this
Knight which way would we take F or H
chord I'm definitely take it with the uh
if I just want to you know have a better
strike like you said you like the sucker
for the structure huh and you like the
structures there so take with the F Pawn
can't take with the H obviously but I
definitely like taking with the F Pawn I
like the decision from the order not
taking this bishop and now we can put
the bishop maybe on D3 beforehand if we
want to win Bishop B3 we take and maybe
the C4 square is just blacks for the
taking right so after taste we have
Bishop D3 maybe slide The Rook over from
H to B1 he took it this way wow that's
very very crafty accent opens a file
yeah I guess we're always taught to
capture towards the center but uh yeah
that I was really unsure actually I
maybe it's based on concrete uh kind of
principles there because capturing the
other way looked nice and nice and nice
and healthy too now white has the
potential to create a past H Pawn of his
own I think that's the downside James
that you were mentioning and even if
black players are five white could
eventually play F3 and G4 and really
reinforce that idea so perhaps noterbeck
underestimated the power of H4 of course
white could also bring the bishop out to
D3 and the other reason you wanted to
take on G6 is to give your Rook the B1
Square so The Rook could come to B1 at
some point and harass the Knight on B6 I
think the likeliest outcome is a draw
but I'm with you David I think white has
a pull here
yep it at least looks easier to play and
maybe lower risk for white if it goes
wrong for black it's going to be
disaster either white will crash through
on this side of the board or yeah
potentially this Pawn could drop off or
maybe a rook could end up on the seventh
rank if it goes wrong for white however
it feels like you should still be
relatively safe so the margin's slightly
higher for Abdul sotorov at this early
stage
and F5 is on the board trying to make
sure that white G4 doesn't come
immediately still needs a bit of
preparation and Jordan reaching out will
he develop first take out that Bishop
threaten to attack the Knight on B6 or
will he continue with the pawn storm
down uh the king side and the one good
tip for chess kids out there the knights
are such bad Defenders Against The Siege
pawn and we've been saying it but we
can't say it enough number of times that
if Jordan does get that H Pawn down the
board it can get extremely dangerous for
Abdu satrov for now Bishop development
Rook B1 always in the air
another tip for chess kids watch out for
your air quality always open the window
you can breathe fresher you can play
faster you can play better and uh Jordan
that's very high CO2 levels over there
in uh
Netherlands I'm not going to try and
pronounce kernigan but uh
wherever he's sitting he's uh he's
playing well though so far into C7 after
satora's last move just protecting the
Black Knight getting ready for any white
Rook to slide across he doesn't need to
defend in future
very solid position for black hard to
break and it's quite blocked which does
tend to favor Knights In general but
it's blocked in White's favor at the
moment
what do we think here otherwise got to
try and get a break in right the F3 G4
ideas that we're looking at to try to
March down the board with the H Pawn
because Rook B1 doesn't make much sense
but there's another plan that Jordan has
in mind he goes G3 the funding H4 so
that seems to imply that he wants to
just free up The Rook from H1 might want
to go Rook C1 and then C4 that's a weird
middle ground but if everything is
traded black will experience problems
with the C6 pawn and of course the a
pawn is both a strength and a weakness
yeah it's a past Pawn but if you don't
if you aren't ready to defend it with
both of your Rooks it could end up as
more of a weakness than a strength so a
lot of options here for white you can
play it safe with rugby one you could
still resort to the F3 plan a lot of
decisions to make
yeah key moment and that tends to be
where the players burn the most of their
time when it's actually planning when it
comes to calculation these guys are
super fast they're able to calculate
long variations just like Daniel in the
space of one or two minutes it's
normally when you have to come up with a
long-term plan like now or a committal
plan when you have three or four options
that's where you see the players spend
several minutes
an instructive moment for chess kids
because whenever we're playing these
imbalance positions Bishop versus knight
there's always a question of where to
place your pawns and we see here not
about has placed all his pawns on the
same color as his opponent's Bishop as
Jordan's Bishop now it might seem that
these can become targets but the upside
of that is that you really take away the
activity from your opponent's Bishop so
in this case it's not a weakness it's a
way to take away most quests more
activity and really tie down that white
Bishop
yeah and this was already tied down
right now you can't move many places I
mean I thought rookie fire actually saw
this idea Rook A3 and then obviously our
idea is to double the Rooks or we'll
Rook B1 okay that that's a move too as
well but definitely doubling the Rooks
and maybe something like Bishop to C2 at
some point to put pressure on A4 but you
can't Knight C4 is now even a fork there
which maybe Rook A2 might have been a
move
um just to be able to free up the bishop
a little bit to move it here I think it
will probably just end in the draw here
it definitely is uh like slower for both
sides hard to make Pawn breaks for
literally both sides here black may have
some some action with this pawn and
maybe a C5 break at some point but even
then I don't ever have to touch the C
Pawn um being white here so I mean it's
very very level it's super equal here to
be honest can one dream of uh putting
that Rook on B4 and start marching with
the King on the king side King E2 King
F3 just step by step trying to walk away
not only from the fork that James
mentioned but also to keep the king more
active it's a very nice plan actually
Tanya try to get the king to G5 actually
but I mean maybe we play F6 somewhere in
there but then that makes me that's like
the H5 and then it takes intake on F5
with the King very strong yeah really
like it uh black has to do something
black can't just sit on the position uh
just to put that one that you mentioned
there James on uh on the board yes you
can block off the white King's entry but
H5 will break through maybe there's
something even better but uh suddenly
the pawns might start dropping although
will be weak long term can black do
anything active he has played Rook A8 on
his last move
before before there it is okay both C5
is possible but it's just a one with
thread I mean white doesn't even have to
take on C5 The Rook could move away then
you've created another weakness
long-term weakness on D5 that Bishop on
D3 such a nice defensive piece because
it completely keeps that Knight at Bay I
think that white still has the
preferable side of what is probably an
equal position objectively but Notre
back he has to figure things out because
Tanya's plan that is not to be trifled
with if I'm on the board don't you
dad is surprising I'm not gonna lie okay
wow now white has a weakness for the
first time in the game is the idea maybe
to drop the bishop back at some point
and start coming forward with the King
just I'm inspired by your idea there
Tanya
decision there by Jordan to change the
pawn structure the way he did but we saw
the eval bar it remains where it is Rook
C5 definitely gives more play to Black
and King E2 played so he might be headed
in the direction that we were talking
about King side is weak it's been
abandoned by all the black pieces time
to March down the board King is a piece
in the end game just get advice
this king is a very important piece
maybe the most important piece in the
end game if you have a passive King that
doesn't contribute you're basically
playing a piece down after all so what
can black do White's plan is pretty
clear now I think uh abdisator of has
been made aware of that by the last move
white wants to go for the King march how
does black react bit tied up and you
know what's funny if we would have taken
with the other him absolutely we're
taking with the F Pawn and undouble the
pawns then it'd be harder for my king to
get in there right I could I could just
play F6 maybe or even F5 in some cases
but I mean now with this Pawn flanks
that we have um with uh F5 G6 and F7
here it's much easier for me to try to
break this down if you move one of them
then the other become weak so this is a
great playing time playing with the King
just over here on that side of the board
right and go crazy King F3 King F4 King
G5
and the good thing is with that plan
it's so easy for white to make the next
couple of moves and in these formats to
have that flexibility to be able to play
fast you just have a plan to not think
about concrete moves is such a luxury
black plays King C6 King F3 is possible
what's his plan maybe Knight C4 and then
Knight E5 check trying to liquid I mean
it's a drawing operation try to
liquidate and take the C3 Pawn but when
you have to defend using specific
tactics like that things get really
really flimsy because this depends on a
lot of moving Parts uh being in place
but I do think that might be his idea
Knight C4 was a move that white took the
sting out of by Shifting the king from
D2 to E2
yeah we're struggling to come up with
anything productive other than King F3
and just to show that line you mentioned
there Dania Knight C4 could be
potentially extremely important black
can't sit and wait any longer for the
white king to come in so Knight C4 hits
The Rook if we now capture this Pawn
then after a couple of Trades and
there's two moves here I guess Knight E5
check I was attempted by this one but
there is a way for the white Rook to
escape so a knight check forces the
white king to be honest forces it back
and Rook takes pawn and uh everything's
just being hovered off the board it
feels or vacuumed off the board it feels
like this is headed towards the draw so
okay Jordan didn't go for this yet he
dropped his Bishop back forcing the
black Rook back where it came from to
defend this pawn and now the question
again is can you King march
yes you can
how do you stop this with black that's
the next question
more difficult question that was a very
great move I think Bishop C2 was a very
nice subtlety there going there first to
stop the idea that uh Daniel pointed out
with Knight to C4 right so Bishop C2
first ties you to the pawn now that
you're tied all the pieces are tied to
the a pawn then we move the king over
here and of course it's uh what is this
principle of two weaknesses is what they
call it so you have a weak King side
over here with the pawns and you also
have a weak Pawn on A4 two weaknesses
sometimes you can't defend both of them
at the same time it's difficult to be
able to do that so I think white
definitely has a nice plan here
and even though
the valve says it's equal is it
overstating it if I said that
notification should be worried a little
bit here
I would be
about you guys I'd be terrified just
playing Jordan in general but uh yeah
especially this position it feels like
everything we're looking at it's black
trying to force a draw somehow and
that's the worst type of scenario you're
just playing for two results okay King
C5 talking of King asking matches
what is this move Daniel do you have
anything I'm just trying to find him the
problem is you can never move your
knight because A4 Falls right your king
is tied down defending the Knight if you
move one of the Rooks away you can do
that because Bishop takes A4 might not
work tactically what is the point of
that like after King F4 yeah you could
play like even Rook C8 but why it's just
going to continue with King G5 or even
H5 which is a possibility once the king
reaches F4 Jordan is wondering the same
thing maybe five maybe yeah Rook B5 was
not possible on the last turn and now it
is and uh this is really the genius
genius stuff these players are so good
uh we have to show that black is tied up
here as James highlighted this Pawn is
tying down Black's Army you want to
maybe trade a set of Rooks for example
after King F3 but suddenly Bishop takes
would walk into a pin and after a bunch
of traits black would be down upon so
instead you move your king forward and
now we're expecting uh the idea of Rook
to B5 because now Bishop takes Pawn is
not possible this is no longer a pin so
black can simply jump out of the way and
actually black is uh maybe not this last
move maybe you just Retreat and black is
winning a piece due to the pin still
complicated I've got to say still very
sharp position but uh looks good for
Abdus so we're expecting this move Rook
B5 any second now that's a really
unpleasant move because Rook D4 runs
into Rook B2 exactly and if a pair of
Rooks gets off the board then you could
set that a pawn in motion once again by
finally getting to that A3 Rook so
things about to get very very tactical
it's on the board great call there guys
Rook B5 amazing find by not the backup
this outro I'm just moving that King up
absolute tactical sharpness even in the
end game is required and now the big
question you don't want to trade The
Rook on B5 after the king jumps in the
Knight coming on to C4 the a pawn can
become an absolute nightmare if not
sidestepping Rook D4 are we expecting
this to become a fighter by Rook D4 Rook
B2
but that doesn't look very pleasant for
white at all exactly I might have to
take a video exactly that's a sick idea
Rook B5 is very sick you might have to
take Play Bishop D3 and then Knight C4
and then maybe move the king Take on C4
and then try to play with the tempo the
problem is after we have all of this
happen like for instance Rigby five King
takes Bishop check night King C5 or
whatever like even we block with the
Knight on C4 King G5 our idea is
eventually we are going to take maybe on
but maybe we don't yeah after King C5
you have to take the Knight and problem
is Black's King can go around through D3
C2 to B2 and then Rook on A3 would
actually be trapped right if it doesn't
move if it does move you allow the a
pawn to move forward so it seems like
black emerges on top and most of these
Pawn races of course white could start
gobbling up the king side pawns and
ultimately sack The Rook as is very
customary yeah but Black's not gonna
cooperate okay seven are we talking
about not about potentially being the
one to push for a win in this end game
yeah actually I mean a rugby five move
was so sick I mean really it is because
it makes you for it forces you to do
something you allow Rigby too or you
take it and you allow as something to
come to C4 at some point which is very
strong we have more beautiful ideas
James you're totally right Rook B5 the
trade happened and white had to do
something couldn't just stay and trying
to create play on the other side of the
board H5 now you don't want to take that
pawn right David and give up the F5 Pawn
that looks like a bad idea disagree
completely I would take this one off in
a second I actually I really thought
that this was the danger for black long
term I thought this was the pawn that
was going to promote so I'm happy to
take it off the board and he does so
instantly yes you've ruined your Pawn
structure look how weak these are
isolated isolated isolated isolated but
it's going to take an eternity now for
white to create a past pawn and it's
going to become a race no matter what
this this end game so uh yeah black has
an ugly Pawn structure but might be
ahead in the rest you guys highlighted
kicking away this Rook next move
and uh still very sharp of course
computer says level but that doesn't
tell the story at all no that's an end
game for all three results and
probably the least clay as David you
were pointing out black cannot allow the
H Pawn to March down the board an
unpleasant choice to make but now it's
all about timing he's got to start
jumping with that Knight Knight C4 is
there something that he doesn't like
about that
the problem is even if white plays Rook
A2 and black plays A3 every step that
the pawn takes is like a Herculean labor
then getting try getting that Rook off
of A2 that's another three or four Tempe
eventually White's two moves away from
creating a passer King F6 and King takes
F7 and then White's gonna have to burn a
bunch of moves shoving that up on down
the board so it's not like a race
between Ferrari and a Lamborghini it's
more like you know Ford and a Reliant
Robin or something like that
and a little snail just yeah exactly wow
guys yo white or black who would you
pick both have their own trumps it's a
tough call James I probably go with
black this Pawn is very strong here it's
very very strong A4 I mean my king is
very active yes wise King is active too
but you can't actually use my Pawn jet
which you need to try to get a pass Pawn
here like we saw in the Jordan game
where you play kolars and got that past
Pawn played G5 ran H Pawn down created
his chances right against past spawn
against past Pawn this one is no pass
Pawn yet for white
and the moves that we were talking about
are on the board Knight civil played
Bishop D3 would you agree with James
that Black's the one who's got the
chances here it appears so now I'm very
curious if nederburg plays King C5 and
unpins the Knight Jordan's
procrastinated by one move but then he
has to decide is he taking that Knight
off the board my intuition says no
because of the path that black skin can
take to B2 I think he's gonna drop his
Rook back to A2 it feels to me that
blackis has the upper hand here it also
occurs to me Tanya that after Rook A2 A3
Black's Rook is tied down to the to the
pawn and forget everything he's taking
on C4
whoa King D3 King C2 King B2 traps The
Rook on it see what he has in mind here
this is we looks so scary why is the
eval bar still equal is my big question
yeah
we need a helping hand from the computer
here how narrow is the path for white to
survival is there any one move to save
this game yes before E4 or you're dead
for Jordan and he just reacted there
he's has he missed something because E4
is automatic the whole idea is to try
and bring the white king back to prevent
the black king from coming round towards
the white Rook that is difficult here
you get that by process of elimination
he does
classy move star move he had to foresee
this several moves ago I think E4
whoa and the race continues
but Black's King can't get in what a
moment it was the only move that Jordan
van Forest had to keep the balance and
he founded E4 to stop the black king
from marching down on over to the queen
side and the problem now is if you go
with King D3 the white Central Pawn is
just too fast you capture D5 and you
march down the board yourself which
means that White's King comes back to
the defense just in time
just in time what a game his middle name
now at this point Jordan just in time
this was uh yeah really by the skin of
his teeth saving this game but
yeah it looks like he might have built a
fortress that white king blocking out
the whole black Army once it retreats to
E4
completely crazy to think about ideas
like D4 sacrificed upon and then get
your king onto the other side and start
running after white truck geez sorry
that's a sick move d4 is kind of
annoying too before okay and now we do
have the past D Pawn I think we'll be
able to sack The Rook at some point I
mean and if I well let's say I went both
the pawns are not react to that didn't
react wow it's a move oh my goodness
it's a move you go this way
yeah yeah these pawns I guess will just
be too strong but you can take this Pawn
maybe you take on D4 and
oh my God it's a race I don't want to
calculate this you can run back with the
King you could also make an argument for
cutting off the white king
I have no idea what's happening we have
to count like 15 20 moves in advance to
King versus King uh the final position
here but uh this is the type of thing
that's going on in obtuse satora's mind
the option I mean this is the ambitious
one as you say Tanya the option I guess
is taking here and the problem is now
the king cannot creep in you're a bit
stuck and he goes for this so uh the
white king Force back that's uh true the
white Rook stuck still take black here
every day of the week but how do you
make progress no pass pawns on this side
of the board at least
you need a Second Avenue of attack our
F5 has been played taking more squares
away from white white skin is stuck
guarding Black's King from coming down
to D3 it just looks like everything in
White's Camp is so passive but can black
make improvements here maybe F4 try to
undermine the g-pawn and create another
passer so instructive how White's rook
and pawn are holding Black's entire Army
at Bay and he's just played it F4
notarbeck's still trying to win pulling
out all the stops that's what he does
but Jordan says I wasn't born yesterday
I ain't touching that pawn I'm gonna
keep that H Pawn at Bay as well now just
like Drive the pawn to F3 and try to
switch his attention maybe even give the
a pawn eventually up for the F Pawn I
think yes probably it's still going to
be a draw though you're
this is scary the pawn is pushing it's
the idea to bring the Rook across try to
kick back the black king and I think
you're just in time because now after A2
you can check oh and the black key has
to go back sick and suddenly you're just
in time with a king slide to stop the
poor Jordan Justin Time For Us in time
done it again and he's holding this one
oh Rook H1 how does black draw this
again wait a second this is uh that's a
huge threat if I have to move the Rook
preemptively to like A8 or something or
maybe to D5 E5 maybe E5 or D5 you've got
to keep that H Pawn guarded gotta move
the black Rook that's that's for sure
yeah
wow and the another bag is down to less
than three minutes on the clock so
Jordan up on the clock but it's been
amazing to watch the kind of pressure
that not a back move by move has built
the apron down to A3 F Pawn down to F3
everything on the third rank James
momentum might have shifted now though I
think we are winning a pawn here somehow
uh I mean after you move the The Rook
anywhere I check first and then you have
to go back and I take and then I go Rook
back and then I may have just in time to
go King B2 just in time just
JV fjit just in time today that's insane
well yeah I think you need to shift your
Rook there we go shift so check and then
you bring your king to B3 is that the
idea Black's gonna seek counter play
against the white F2 Pawn
I think uh yeah
you should be holding here King B3 you
have A2 actually very important to lure
the king to the second rank that's cute
because if you play rookie two
immediately no that's also probably
possible white can't do everything at
once right you can only take one Pawn at
a time H5 will fall with check but then
White's gonna have to choose between
eliminating the a pawn and defending the
F2 pawn and you can't let that A3 Pawn
reach A2 if that square is defended yeah
really nice touch just to show this one
if King B3 the pawn does drop down to A2
and if you do take it check and
everything is just gonna get there's
some work to do here for white by the
way I would be very scared the boss
dropping the three on the board it's not
about the number it's about the quality
yep oh A2 you've got to play it and uh
yeah if this Pawn might decide the game
f for Van Forest
[Laughter]
s right yeah starting a forest fire here
fan forest fire with rookie two or A2
A2 is too flashy not to play though
two-time thing two minutes though for
Abdi satorov and uh he's choosing which
Pawn to go for which Pawn to push
yeah this was a hard end game this is
like never rescue page 574. I mean
literally and then there's three
chapters on this end game yeah that's
crazy but James yeah of course no
there's actually there's three there's
three no it's four chapters on pawning
games and three on Rook I've only
studied those those are the most
comments you don't even get to the queen
one Jack which is another four chapters
of like bro what's wrong with you why
did you do this devaretsky but it is the
best Ending game books of course
obviously and 82 on the board and this
is the reason why Rook Pond endings are
can be so fascinating we're seeing all
these tactics and these dynamic
Jordan he goes with the Rook he wants to
safeguard the F2 Pawn can he afford to
pick it up with his Rook
oh that was nice what a check crazy corn
races here I've got to say you might get
it wear white you might get an engine
where black is an H Pawn and a queen
against a queen and those are actually
really hard to save yeah oh King D3 Rook
defense
oh not gonna happen but King D3 don't
play it oh my God oh my goodness this is
a family what geometry spotted by Ben
Forest it's gross yeah and uh just to
show what you were mentioning that if in
this position before giving a check if
you're taking this Pawn we would see a
crazy race suddenly actually is it that
crazy a race the king's coming the
king's coming the pawn runs
and this I think this is the one you
meant here this is the one I meant and
this would be very hard to hold no time
on the clock even though it is a draw
theoretically this
is meant to defend yeah in these
positions right now he's giving a check
uh and naughty back slows down so King
D3 will not happen but it's so easy to
fall for that in these time scrambled he
falls back inviting a repetition
yeah the problem is the black king
cannot evade the checks if it runs too
far away white can go for that race that
we just showed on the board racing the
pawns because the black king will take
an age to go for White born on F2 so it
looks like a fourth drawer Jordan here
just calculating you can see his eyes
just kind of looking one side from the
board to the other he's checking uh to
make sure that race doesn't end well for
white and when he realizes he's gonna go
for this draw it's going to repetition
of moves what a game it's been though
the least boring draw so far yeah of the
tournament wow
oh with 43 seconds on the clock we are
expecting not about to go back with his
King to D5 and then once again are we
going to see a repetition here third
time it will be over looking at Jordan I
think that's where it's headed
and there it is King D5 it does end in a
three-fold repetition the first game
ends in a draw a peaceful result but an
absolutely crazy game Daniel what a game
and Notre back with an interesting
opening Choice going for that early end
game demonstrating fluent knowledge of
all the ideas creating that best Apon we
felt that black was in control then at
some point we felt that may know maybe
White's taking over the initiative on
the other side of the board both players
grappling for the initiative showing us
how interesting these unbalanced ending
games can be in a very Justified result
in my opinion this is a match between
two players in excellent form Tanya
super interesting end game David what
was a big chess kid moment the big chess
kid moments it was all about Yoda just
in time Jordan is worth calling him now
it was a really difficult position for
him but he showed his incredible form by
finding a series of only moves to save
the game here Black's Knight is
threatening to kick away The Rook it is
attacking The Rook if the Rook moves
black would win the pawn would run down
and white is playing without this piece
instead he spotted he had to capture
this Knight and the Beautiful move here
he had to step forward because now after
a trade the white king is just in time
to block off the entry of Black's King a
really well played draw by both sides so
it's just all about being just in time
that is what speed chess is about and we
are seeing a fantastic matchup and game
one has set the tone for all the action
that's coming up let's bring up our
score line going into game two the
players will fight it out in a best of
four the first game has ended in a draw
the action has just started we will be
right back
foreign
[Music]
thank you
an aerofocus concentration performance
air things put you in control of air
pollutants that cloud your work from
home space
shifting your state with every breath
find your air of clarity now
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever
records and trophies first and only game
changing Innovations from the heroes we
admire to the joy of watching them play
our history defines us inspires us and
pushes us into the future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster
it's forever faster and one such fast
kid is putana 700 and we're so excited
to show her story to all of you she has
Big Dreams big Ambitions to become the
world champion one day take a look
we're here for a special event but
Hannah is going to give a clock symbol
against six of Harrow chess club finest
I'm gonna try some of the games
[Music]
foreign
one of my dad's friends was throwing
away some things I
started asking about some pieces and
then I said that I wanted to take them
away but then my my dad said we needed
them and then he taught me how to play I
liked that I could win games and more
trophies and also I could go to more
countries and make more friends
[Music]
these two I got on my first
International Tournament in Serbia
there's another three somewhere here
which I got in Greece but I'm not sure
where they are because there's so many
of them I quite liked this one because
straight after I got it I started trying
to like break it off because
this far kind of breaks off it
Knight F6 good Mr taste H6 yes Queen
shade three nice check
mate well done you supported the queen
sacrifice immediately did it did it just
come to your mind yeah I'm impressed
you're getting them all I thought that
would be tough but no
my dad doesn't really want to play
against me now I think he doesn't want
to get beaten we haven't played for a
long time so I think I would beat him
though
[Music]
my goal is to become the youngest I'm GM
in the world or if not then the youngest
GM in UK after that I want to play in
the world championships and get world
champion I think it will be hard but I
still think I can do it
final score was put on a five points
Harrow chess club one point
it's our two twin sisters well whenever
I try to teach them they just run away
like I started when I was five and a
half and I keep shouting at them saying
you you don't even play chess yet
that was amazing to watch and they were
just the way she was solving those
puzzles oh my God so quick yeah actually
I gave putana a few puzzles that I've
shown to Grand Masters and it took her
seconds it took some of the grand
Masters several minutes so uh yeah
extremely quick tactically extremely
impressive most of all she's really
mature her family as well shout out to
uh the whole family there her twin
sisters the parents they're so lovely
she's got the perfect support network
and she's gonna go far I'm excited for
England uh having her on our team in
future that's so important to have that
support system at that age David what
would be your advice to all the chess
kids out there being young being
ambitious what's the path to Improvement
yeah for the chess kids out there just
play as much as you can but also
dedicate some time to analyzing maybe
with your friends a coach a parent and
for the chess parents out there just
support your kids uh if they're enjoying
it loving it especially if it comes from
within then yeah try and bring them to
whisperings as possible you might honor
a star
uh and Simon mentioned that but Anna
actually defeated him in one of the
games yeah
yeah I shouldn't say this but I played a
few Blitz Games with her and she was
close to defeating me too so she's a
very impressive player wow chess kids
across the world are impressing us with
their performance and of course the big
platform for learning chess it's fun to
play it's educational and the safest
place for the kids to play chess that is
the chess kid website and chess gate and
Magnus Academy are working on making
chess accessible and empowering for kids
but we're wondering if schools should
play a role in this too what do you
think Chad should chess be taught in
schools what are the pros and cons you
got to drop your thoughts in chat this
is also the weekly referendum question
for our Discord Community if you like
debating stuff like this you should
check out the chesscom discard server
using the command Discord in chat Justin
schools James that would be so cool
absolutely they already have it in fact
in some schools already in America like
New York um a few in Michigan are now
starting to do with Chicago I've seen
too as well it works the math part of
the brain analytical decision making and
It also says that it deters Alzheimer's
as well so people don't know these
things about Chess actually so it
actually helps in business too as well
as you see big companies recruiting
chess players I wonder why right so
definitely Chesterton schools is a huge
thing wow absolutely and it helps all
across and that's why we say that
chassis is Art science and Sport and
while the chess kid action is on WE of
course also had an art competition a
joint competition that leading up to the
chess kit cup and it was the big
question was who could draw the best
portrait of chess players from across
the world of the division one players
and we got some really really fun and
cool entries we will be announcing the
winners later but take a look at some of
the art that the chess kids came up with
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
oh that was amazing to see a lot of
talent across the world and these were
the chess kids from a chess club in Peru
thank you so much for sending in your
entries lots of hikarus there yeah lots
of hikaris lots of fabianos some
drawings better than the others but uh
yeah either way thank you so much
everyone for sending in those pictures
we loved it loved it and there was also
one of naughty backup just right now he
will take on Jordan ban forest in their
second game Clash we saw a long Marathon
fight a rook Bond ending but a
fascinating one in game one it's going
to be a fighting match what are the
chances of this going down to the wire
to the Armageddon now the chances are
pretty high but Notre back with the
white pieces has been a buzz saw against
every opening he has shown a tendency to
play D4 and this is music to my ears a
king's Indian ass
let's go Kings Indian let's go we got
one finally bro I feel baby how you took
a couple days
what do you love so much about the
king's Indian just the fact that it's
unbelievably Dynamic and no matter what
white plays you're going to get an
unbalanced position you're going to get
winning chances it's also you know it's
like a pair of jeans that you've worn
for 15 years it just feels so
comfortable it fits well it's all I've
ever played and I'm a little bit
disappointed because Jordan is playing
at benoni Style with C5 but this is the
way that modern players often treat the
king's Indian and Bishop to D7 you don't
see that move every day looks very
awkward but he might be preparing a
benko Gambit style idea with B7 B5 uh
David are you surprised with this
position
yeah if it wasn't Jordan van Forest I
would say that's a mouth slip Black
Knight normally wants to use the square
as a kind of launch pad it does feel a
bit clumsy I guess the Black Knight on
B8 that's undeveloped will want to use
the edge of the board before kind of
re-centralizing later I should mention a
few years ago when Alpha zero first
became a thing I was lucky enough to
play a couple of games against it and we
played the king's Indian it used this
line with uh Bishop E2 Bishop E3 against
us so this is Alpha zero approved uh
this setup for white and it did exactly
the same it jumped forward back with its
Knight and it had this set up
of course we got crushed I was playing
as part of a team but uh yeah it's an
interesting setup interesting choice
opening for both sides and that pose by
another bag is a hundred percent Alpha
zero approved it is so much Focus that
we are seeing from Nutter back and he's
playing fantastic chess as is uh Jordan
van Forest Bishop D7 another unique
opening idea we asked him yesterday that
Jordan how do you do it how do you come
up with all these uh different offbeat
openings and as David you mentioned an
old idea but Jordan is prepared with
this and it has thrown not a bag a
little off balance it reminds me a
little bit of what Magnus said
anti-young player chess yeah I can see
young players that's hilarious there
yeah this kingzillion here is definitely
strange as we mentioned Diane yeah I'm
used to actually using seeing the E5
version in 96 Knight C5 with A5 right
instead of doing uh this way so we're
gonna see this benoni style here see how
it works I'm definitely interested to
see what he has of his sleeve and maybe
we can use it later to win our own Kings
Indian games at home there so I'm
learning cool yeah Bishop D7 take and
maybe obviously the B5 option right yeah
if C takes D5 very common tactical
semi-tactical idea with B5 because the
E4 Pawn hangs in a lot of lines so you
do see more positionally minded players
often recapture with the e-pawn and
maintain the symmetry of the pawn
structure but also discourage B5 The
Exchange stack on E3 is not unheard of
in these types of lines because it gives
black dark Square control in the center
the engine actually doesn't hate it
either so this actually might be
Jordan's idea very consistent with what
he's been displaying thus far in this
tournament the level of creativity and
gumption that he's shown yeah and which
way if we were white I know you guys are
biased towards the black side against
Indiana don't ask me what I would do
with the white side because it's already
lost exactly Which Way left or right
sipon or E Pawn to capture I would want
to capture this way but as you guys say
this is a bit scary
can what consider this
one to B5 we're all hesitating here in
the studio because it gets tactical zero
one
it gets sharp the idea is the uh B5 Pawn
can be captured but suddenly the White
Center does for the black uh the Black
Knight now can take because the White
Knight has been deflected away and this
gets sharp this gets crazy I don't want
to calculate this too much I think I
would be inclined to take with the E
Pawn but obviously nordebec form far
more ambitious than I am and potentially
scared of this sacrifice on E3
I would be amazed to see if Jordan
actually does go for this rookie 3
sacrifice I completely agree with you
Daniel that it's consistent with his
style of play these unique ideas but
rookie 3 fe3 I say an exchange give it
to me I'm happy prove your compensation
yeah but once you put the queen on E7
that domination over the E5 square and
eventually the bishop on D7 could slide
away Knight could take its place but
that's a moot point now because not
Rebecca shows in the more combative path
we are going down one of these lines
where the center will liquidate and we
will get a wild ensuing position yeah a
wild ensuing position that could be very
good for black if he can activate if
Jordan can get his pieces to active
squares but long term
oh I do feel for black partly because
the D6 Pawn is a huge Target and okay
Knight takes E4 White Center has
collapsed so small gain here for black
you would think strategically but does
white have anything in mind is he gonna
trade this Knight in the center is he
going to just post up his other knight
uh the White Knight on D2 is he gonna
post it on a nice beautiful outpost on
C4 questions James I don't know I
already like black I mean okay with
Kings in there like whatever the
possession was he was gonna like black
but here I mean the bishop is so strong
on B2 you have to worry about that right
we also have I mean Knight A6 to C7 get
rid of that we do have to worry about D6
maybe we kick the Knight away with A6 we
also maybe play F5 Bishop E5 at some
point we do like black obviously because
this bishop it reminds you almost as a
cattle and in Reverse with this bishop
of how strong it is we even don't take a
rook for it if we're able to take an
exchange we don't even take it because
the bishop is very strong here but after
the nice C4 move
quite annoying we just play A6 probably
kick it away Knights somewhere and a
good squash to retreat that's the
problem otherwise this would look really
attractive for weights right 94 rookie
four and then what happens there okay so
maybe instead just trading some pieces
but at least now black has ideas maybe
sledding The Rook across the B4 still
later in Dreamland you could maybe
consider sacrificing but uh yeah
meanwhile this piece most important
piece here MVP most valuable piece right
now it goes for black
well the Silver Lining to the line you
showed with the Knight on A3 is that it
does keep the Knight on C4 nicely
protected so I do actually think Notre
back is going to play Knight A3 I don't
see anything tactical here in a knight
C3 saxophone could be considered to get
Black's Knight off of E4 so I could see
a case being made for that he's at least
going to think about it but I don't
think Knight A3 is the end of the world
either but a very interesting decision
here from Notre back yeah retreating to
C3 towards the center sacrificing the
pawn maybe the most ambitious but
I'm not sure whether the position okay
wow he goes for it why did I question
his ambition here oh he's gonna get the
B file as well a good poster Brooke on
B1 and that Rook could infiltrate to B6
or B7 so this is actually starting to
appeal to me because the Knight on B8
right that's gonna have a really hard
time developing because you're gonna cut
the contact between the queen and the D6
Pawn after the E4 Knight disappears yeah
just to show its disappearance we're
predicting Knight takes Knight Pawn
takes and black might as well suffer for
something might as well be a bit greedy
here take this Pawn as James mentioned
actually sometimes you don't even want
to take this Rook because then Black
start squares would become weak around
the king and uh yeah I guess white World
Dodge however
yeah it's this position is this Knight
just as terrible as it looks or is there
a way out if you ever move then this
Pawn will drop and your whole Position
will start to fall apart so if you're
stuck with uh black then maybe this is a
bit of a problem Knight takes night
we're headed in this direction and watch
out for this Pawn becoming a huge Target
in the near future The Rook entering as
well to B6 will be seven
I'm talking myself into loving this for
white Daniel that's why you don't play
C5 in the king's Indian right
traditionally with E5 that's right the
more I look at this the more I'm just
impressed with notorbeck's feel for such
a wide variety of different positions
this is reminiscent of magnets doesn't
matter what you throw at him King's
Indian C5 E5 he just seems to
immediately sense the most annoying the
most practically difficult path Knight
C3 is one of those moves that's really
easy to gloss over but so many of us
would just play Knight A3 automatically
why sack a pawn he feels how hard it is
for Black to deploy the rest of his
Queen side Yeah you mentioned it reminds
you of Magnus is he the new Magnus is he
a future world champion uh just the way
he's playing right now just so
impressive oh he's already a world
champion now through Rapid of course
right very very strong player here that
was that was very impressive there as
Dania mentioned the C5 line here it is
more benoni-like and of course in a
benoni you want to get B4 B5 in and use
the B file but that's usually when you
have a knight already off the back rank
on B8 but here that is the problem here
it's very very strong wrong from
nordbeck I think with this nice C3 Pawn
sacrifice saying your pieces are gross
mine are all developed yeah I'll give
you the little Pawn but I have space
with D5 you can't really move yet he
might have to go something like A5 just
try to get the Knight off the A6 or
maybe Queen E7 to maybe move the Knight
to B7 and eventually have something
there but white has a lot of initiative
over this Pawn
engine doesn't even like it's equal it's
like oh yeah I can take the pawn and
it's equal right you have a pawn but
it's equal you know something's wrong
with the position right
that's why I advise just chess kits at
home try to stay away from just
following computer evaluations it's so
deceptive this is like the least equal
position uh ever maybe if both sides are
playing perfectly no mistakes it will be
a draw but I mean anything can happen
here in Practical terms black has huge
huge problems to solve I have a crazy
idea to play Queen H4
Knight takes D6 with Rook takes E3 and
that actually might be a Perpetual there
with
um Bishop E5 G3 Bishop takes G3 it's a
kind of a classic pattern I'm just
throwing stuff out there so much so much
easier to sacrifice other people's
pieces right but you're forking the
Knight and the Checkmate threat forcing
white to play G3 which force is black to
take which forces white to take which
forces black to take which forces point
to play King H1 and of course this is
how the game will end without any
questions obviously now watch Jordan
actually do that it's a very yeah it's a
very uh Jordan kind of solution yes it
is exactly Queen H4 really crazy it's a
good point because if you take 96 the
first thing that comes to mind is why
not Bishop E5 directly and David the
problem with that would be that white
has got the smooth G3 and it hits the
queen defends the main and now you're
losing The Rook on E8 so rookie 3 is
super precise yeah and he didn't kind of
uh well he stopped halfway on the path
at least he didn't put it on G5 sure uh
I'm not sure I don't think mile slip but
uh at least he's activated his Queen
he's hitting this Pawn of course but
more importantly he's defending from the
side freeing up his Knight to come to D7
the Knight will no longer block the
Queen's defense of this Qi D6 uh D6 Pawn
so interesting solution I preferred your
one they're down here Queen H4 that's
the type of move that scares the
opponent that uh forces them to
calculate forces them to burn Time Queen
F6
and I doubt afterwards will take a time
out to defend that pawn on C3 he wants
activity he wants active play
how to generate that though
that's a good question rigby1 definitely
is very tempting I mean you just put a
rook on the file right and this is C3 is
not even hanging anymore because D6 so
definitely just take advantage of
activating more pieces Rick to B1 maybe
put something on B7 or Rook to B6 is
also possible or queen A4 G4 to try to
Halt the development of black snide also
comes to mind right Queen four is very
nice yeah really nice play you know what
the opponents desired next move is so
therefore you stop it that's kind of the
type of player that I struggle against
the most they see my plans coming A
Million Miles Away and they stop them
before they've even formed in my head
and uh you just feel as if you're
playing against like a god-like creature
it's like they can read your mind and
here Jordan definitely wants to move the
Black Knight next uh next turn so why
not prevent that I think you might be
right there Daniel one of those two
moves looks very appealing or both of
those moves look very appealing to be
honest bring the White Queen out stop
the black knight from developing to the
D7 Square I do tutorial looks really
interested in this position it feels
like he's spotted an idea that he likes
as well
which one is he going to go for James
your move as well it's really really
natural just open Line occupy it with
the white Rook
what could be more logical eight minutes
against 11. Jordan was the one who chose
this opening to be honest and if I were
him I would be regretting it slightly it
feels like one-way traffic yes he might
be fine objectively but difficult from
practical terms and therefore the queen
comes out stopping the black knight from
developing
it is hanging so with
you've got to move the Rook somewhere
they're a good Square okay he got
ambitious for the move like rookie four
trying to pin that Knight or is that too
much problem is there might just be F3
and as flimsy as it looks the Knight
defends the bishop the queen defends the
Knight The Rook cannot find a parking
spot on the H file Rook H4 just seems to
be going the wrong direction Bishop can
drop back to F2 and before you know
you'll get your Rook chops and queen E8
check no that's out of the question
you're just gonna have to drop back in
this case back to E7
and that doesn't look safe either I
think Notre book's taking over this game
you can just see it happening
yeah I'm also wondering what the threat
is for black maybe I can just kind of
shuffle my rook and
are you going to take this Pawn maybe
I'm just going to come over over and say
okay you've burnt to Tempe and I have
full domination looks extremely strong
for white uh where'd you put the Rook
or one of these two squares as you said
Daniel looks really ugly but at least it
does facilitate the development of the
Black Knight to D7
sometimes you need to play ugly moves
maybe he has to go for something like
that I don't see anything else here for
black
yeah it looks like things have gone very
wrong for Jordan van forrest's King's
Indian in this one meanwhile things are
going super well for two very well-known
Grand Masters in division three and
we've got Simon with an update
yeah hi there um just a quick update for
division free and this is the losers
bracket so if you lose once it's okay
but if you lose twice you go home and it
shows that still experience can beat
youth
because I realized the other day that
I'm actually quite old uh in chess
tournament I went there and everyone's
kids has anyone else felt that before in
the panel yeah a couple of head shakes I
see there yeah they're all these little
youngsters come along and just played
too well
um but camski defeated in the
All-American Clash Sam sevillon so that
was a great result for kamski showing
that he's still got that magic touch and
Navara also beat donachenko which was
another a great result for uh experience
so it means those two players are going
through and unfortunately Sam Savion and
donochenko have to leave division three
and that competition
thank you so much Simon for that update
and before you go I want to get your
thoughts on the action that we're seeing
here now uh David James and Daniel have
been saying that this is a nightmare
position with black when you play the
king's Indian what do you what's your
take on it on this
yeah I totally agree I mean I love
playing the king's Indian defense as
well it's such an exciting opening to
play but the thing that's really
impressed me is just uh naughty back
um how how good he is and you were
mentioning it how he understands so many
different positions and uh I have to
admit that I quite like Black's position
I thought yeah Black's got everything he
wants he's got his Queen side break he's
got some tactics it's looking really
good and then a couple moves later I'm
like yeah no actually White's doing
really well so it's like it's amazing
how naughty Beck just uh turned this
around into his favor and I think this
is going to be a very very tough game
for Jordan to hold now he's just too
passive with his pieces at the moment
things are looking tough for Jordan van
Forrest which is why he's trying to
trade off ease the pressure as much as
he can in the position 95 played and the
trades have been accepted but now white
can control the B line the C3 Pawn is a
little bit of a weakness though
it's no longer on C3 steps forward
protects its body there on D5 and white
has that kind of beautiful combo pawns
on light squares Bishop on Dart squares
white also has a rook on the seventh
rank that's where you always want to
leave for those heavy pieces however
black is less cramped black no longer
has the problem piece that black knight
which could barely move has been traded
for White's beautiful Steed and suddenly
it's not one-way traffic whites Queen
slightly distracted maybe black can whip
up some counterplay James definitely
it's equal it's equal here there are so
there's some counter play you do not
like or work on the seventh rank but you
can't actually do more Avengers with one
Rook right now so that's good that's a
good thing for us for Kings Indian
players and he also plays Queen E4 I
like this move it ties the queen to A4
if we wanted to try Queen C6 I mean we
also have Rook C8 anyway but now he
plays Bishop G5 hits The Rook
where do we go you got to be careful
where you go because Queen is jumping on
to D7 and that can be really tricky for
black to face you might need that Rook
on f8 to guard that F7 tender spot it
might be immediate oh immediate Brook
Cafe big decision for Jordan now he has
eight minutes but a difficult question
to answer and just to show your idea
that Tanya The Rook is hit if you move
it you might want the open file then
Queen to D7 could be disastrous Calamity
on the seventh rank instead he does try
to eliminate the very powerful white
Rook on the seventh rank seventh heaven
here however it's a pawn sacrifice I was
wondering whether you could play Queen
takes A6 here
we gotta show that David uh Queen takes
porn deflecting this black Rook the
problem is maybe you don't need to take
the White Queen and then I might regret
my decision but uh here Rook takes the
bishop drops back and I thought I was
checkmating here along the eighth rank
because black is pinned tied up but the
black queen can swoop to the defense uh
maybe this one isn't quite winning for
white instead the other way to accept
the pawn sacrifice would be Rook takes
rook and then now Queen takes but you
have to be really careful of counter
play first black can deal with
background problems I guess push the
pawn gain some time against the bishop
and suddenly I'm worried about Rook B1
coming I'm worried that uh there might
be some ideas against the white one and
then Queen D3 is an absolutely
devastating follow-up and that's far
from the only move but I could also Play
Bishop G7 to D4 at some point and
there's a lot of exciting resources
in a lot of these positions it looks
like Notre back has lost you know as
soon as I praised him he's lost a good
amount of control over this game and now
Jordan kind of has the position that you
would want to have out of a king's India
all these pieces are active and that
Bishop hasn't made its presence felt
just yet
this is getting dicey and spicy now
that's what we like in the king's Indian
right that's every game we want a spicy
and dicey game here kid 4 Life first
there work B8 and yeah we're feeling
great it's the chest kid cup the chess
King's Indian defense cup that's right
oh my goodness oh man give them raise
give them a raise guys I have to point
it out once you put the pun in there the
next Netflix comedy special GM Howell
coming out tonight some really Niche
word player
though what a nice move from Jordan it
shows you do not need to be
materialistic in chess I would have been
hesitant to play this move I'm like okay
I'm dropping a pawn but you get counter
play you get activity and especially in
rapping in Blitz chess you scare the
opponent and that could be key on the
path to Victory look at the time
ah huge five minutes because eight
would that decide the game do you think
maybe long term
still plenty of action action left while
the Queen's remain on the board has
definitely going to decide some decision
making very quickly when you know of
course obviously when you get lower on
time then sometimes you make bad
decisions we've seen in many matches
we've seen it time and time again it
happens all the time even to the best
you get lower on time you panic a little
bit and you make some inaccuracies which
sometimes leads to blunders here so this
is a huge time Edge for you working and
he has to counter play something you're
looking for in a kid it does look pretty
good for him now yarn Bond forest with a
double the amount of time on the clock
and we've been talking about this being
potentially a good position for widebit
Wow Queen A6 on the boat David great
call by you we were looking at a
different idea for black Bishop D4 that
is a very yardanesque move
key tip for everyone at home think on
your opponent's time Jordan he was aware
he spotted this trick this nasty tactic
and he replied instantly three minutes
now against eight white is a bit tied up
White's King a Target Daniel
after Rook takes B Rook takes B Queen
takes D6 first of all black as Bishop
takes F2 check now I saw this a while
ago you can't take the bishop either way
I think you get mated now after King H1
there's Rook B1 and I thought that black
is winning because why you can't avoid
the background but there's Queen d8 two
F6 takes F2 defending the bishop and the
rook and white wins of the game so I
really hope that Jordan hasn't missed
one of these details norderbeck might be
able to Slither his way out of this but
now he's done five minutes on the clock
and obviously black is under no
obligation to take on F2 he could start
with Rook B1 he could keep the Rook on
the eighth rank it's not about the pawn
count here it's about who mates who
Yeah you mentioned Rook B1 as well
equally scary and notibeck has to judge
that his King Will Survive he's only got
two minutes left now Bishop page six
he's leaving his Queen up for grabs
don't take it however this will end in
Checkmate who's mating who that's the
big question in this position White's
meeting like that one is Bishop ethics
on the board a brutal trap there set up
Bishop F2 is still not possible black
does need that Rook to come to be one to
make that a reality how do you counter
this move because this just feels like
naughty back has kept the tension on the
board
yeah he's just passing the move back to
Jordan he's saying okay I'm keeping the
tension look at that kind of
configuration you'll never see it the
queen The Rook the two black Rooks just
staring at each other neither one
willing to commit there's like Bishop F2
Rook takes Queen B1 does that actually
work that's like strange does that work
Tanya wait Bishop takes F2 King H1
Bishop takes F2 Rook F2 Queen B1 let's
show this oh that is way amazing I mean
I am Daniel's brother incredible move
and if I take then takes and I can go up
and exchange right of course the party
spoiler move is King H1
is such an annoying concept because the
thing is actually even safer on that
square but beautiful beautiful stuff but
then King H1 and then I don't know it's
the bar drops
oh Queenie two yeah Queenie two going
for checkmate wow
but man figuring all of this out with
you know seconds on your clock is crazy
well the good news for Jordan is that
he's got about six and a half minutes
and that's exactly what you want in this
kind of a position you want time to be
able to think and navigate these
variations for white the thread is clear
now you want to take on B8 you want to
take on D6 so Black's gotta finds
something now
Bishop F2 King H1 and we saw the bar
maintains itself so maybe there is a
good move there for black
wow good luck finding it though yeah
even with six minutes left Jordan okay
he centralizes this Rook looks so
natural but bar hates it oh my God she
just simply picks up the D6 spawn and
now Bishop F2 tactics they still don't
work
maybe the best bet was it was ugly but
to put the Rook on d8 just protecting
the pawn forcing the White Queen away
and then you'll could have broken
through potentially to A2 what does he
want though Queenie one
it's a tempting move but Queen F4 I mean
why does so many ways to defend F2 Queen
F4 this is what he wanted to say two he
picks it up
whoa Queen if he doesn't have forgotten
about that he's definitely forgotten
about that Daniel just we have to put
this on the board he was banking on the
fact he could play Rook takes porn Here
black looks like he's about to Checkmate
if you take this Rook this is game over
but what it gives the Checkmate first
what a spot there in this position Queen
to f8 giving up the queen forcing you to
capture and unbelievable kiss of death
to the black king whoa
and exactly what you said he just plays
all kinds of position to Perfection
queen of it is a big threat you can't
take on F2 how are you fighting this
threat you're okay eight maybe just go
back and play down a pawn yeah that's
interesting you have to though
whoa not too bad well Bishop takes porn
but the king just Dodges each one is
tilting I think that's it that's GG as
the computer says white has to play this
move otherwise it's Checkmate but uh two
six point F6 or maybe Queen F6 directly
it's Queen D4 there so if you're why do
you gotta watch the back Rank and get
the move order right oh
wow Peter says white is winning let's
try and spot The Knockout blow here how
does white finish this game in his favor
still not easy still some tricks two
minutes for nodderbeck
wait oh yeah no you take any of the
Rooks there's still a background problem
after Queen F6
silence in the studio do you just take
on A8 and then just play like H3 or okay
three if the white kings are breathing
space no background checkmates that's a
very practical option
we can see the engine says only two
winning moves they are the two most
natural moves in the position however
there's tension on the eighth rank take
that black Rook on A8 take it in the
corner Force the black the other Black
Brook out of the action and then you can
decide the best winning move though is
to slide the white guy across to F6 and
then after Queen D4 maybe you drop the
queen back for example to F3 oh yeah and
that Bishop on F2 is immobilized because
of Seven hangs so maybe it's something
slow like that yeah I was trying to
figure out what to do after Queen F6
yeah you're right it takes Queen F6
Queen D4 and then just move the queen
out of the way that makes total sense
let's show this down here you want to
just Retreat the White Queen and there's
a pin it doesn't work Rook A1 probably
there dang okay one Jesus okay one back
rank the white king is so weak on this
back rank wow in this position if you go
Queen C6 after Queen in that Queen F6
he's he starts with queen f6.
black has to play Queen D4 it's on the
board
he finds it of course it takes let's try
and work out the knockout blue okay
Queen C6
is that an idea David let's try Queen C6
hitting the Rope you cannot move now
because of a nasty Checkmate taking the
other rook and gone Queen F3 beautiful
now one has to be played right but then
you take and go Queenie two with a fork
on E8 in the bishop oh no attack on
Checkmate actually checkmate's
Unstoppable here
whoa beautiful geometry here hey I'm
just a tour of it's just and now he's
threatening Rook take steps too that's
the critical thing because rookie one is
met with Rook F1 it's over
loafs of Steel wait that was unnecessary
unnecessary
what is he doing he did all the hard
work and all he had to do was pick up
the bishop let's get a replay on that
that just happened so fast was there
something we were missing it's exactly
what happened there so that was well
let's just show if we back up two moves
F5 was played by black this Pawn was
Under Fire but just Rook takes Bishop
there's no background Checkmate because
you can Retreat world and King G1 I
think he just yeah he just that's crazy
crazy Miss
and now he's down to a minute on the
clock well suddenly Jordan's Back
so many surprises in this game Suddenly
It's a quintos 50 seconds against four
and a half minutes who are you picking
here
so after that problem I'm actually
taking black now I mean at first it was
just with me it was brilliant from
norderbeck brilliant just everything
like wow Unstoppable but now he's about
to have 30 seconds here in a position
there he was winning I mean not his Pawn
is weak on D6
yeah what just happened that you could
have just picked up the piece in one
move I think you just completely forgot
that the Rook comes back after the back
crank mate it's a blind spot yeah
definitely 20 seconds now oh my goodness
do you remember that bluff with Jewel
moussard as well he basically blundered
a piece didn't take it and it turned
this could be another situation we need
six he's gonna pick up that D7 Pawn
Notre bag's gonna try to defend it but
takes takes a pawn up
Bishop C7 is a huge threat still a third
result game wow anything can happen you
trade the Queens the bishop a white
Bishop will hit that Rook on d8 black
will have to give that up for the pawn
this is a crazy crazy game
Tracy game but notabeck at least has
Consolidated he's taken most of the risk
out of the position once the Queen's
depart the board very worst scenario for
white you'll be defending an end game
just to pawn down but it should be
holdable still some tricks for black to
avoid though takes takes and Rook A8
comes to mind to vacate the d8 square
for the bishop
maybe you have to take and C5 then it's
uh
it's anyone's end game Queen D5 played
and Jordan one for rest about four
minutes on the clock 27 seconds for
another back it could have been a very
different game but not about just picked
up that piece and he did everything to
Perfection up to that point one thing we
can hope for is that he's completely
forgotten about that because if that
plays on his mind it's so difficult to
come back maybe he's still not aware
maybe he doesn't realize he was winning
I don't think he did otherwise he would
have paused he seemed to pre-move D6
instead of taking the three piece so I
don't think he's aware he's just playing
in the moment he's staying in the zone
which is great yeah he's defending
really well but still down to Pawn King
F7 was and Rook C8 meets with Rook A1
check and Rook D1 otherwise black would
have been losing order back with Rook C7
I think he could put a bishop On Da but
you run the risk of losing that Bishop
to a skewer on G5 still a lot of
minefields to avoid I would put a rook
on d8 Bobby in the chair says Jordan
with the hypnosis Jordan with the
hypnosis guys Rick 58 on the board King
E6 coming up to pick up that D7 Pawn so
NADA back has got one move to try and
defend it
problem is if the Rooks come off the
board even if black wins that Central
Pawn it's quite an easy draw so I don't
think we'll see a winner despite all
these twists and turns
while Bishop D2 he's getting ready to
meet any king move if the black King
enters E6 for example the white Rook
will drop back with the check any king
move will be answered with a check maybe
black doesn't even win the D Pawn
okay first kicking away the white Rook
yes
you will win that pawn but he's probably
not going to win the game three versus
two not enough on the same side of the
board
it doesn't help either but Black's H
porn promotes on a light Square his
Bishop is a dark Square they don't match
this one is headed towards the drawer
now you can't even create a passport
without more trades
just don't trade the Bishops and that's
it keep moving the Bishops keep that
King on G2 I think both players know it
but what a game this has been another
one that ends peacefully with an
absolutely Wild Ride
yeah Bishop F4
I don't think abdisator should go and
check this game with the computer he'll
be kicking himself for that missed
opportunity
Wizardry followed by you know the cookie
was there all he had to do is eat it
nice chocolate chip Bishop on F2 and he
didn't take it if these are the first
two games of this match what will the
last two games look like wow and we have
a result it is a draw after all of the
action
what a game and these two are really at
it and it just looks like amazing a
chess that we are witnessing from two of
the most talented chess players on the
planet and the second game also ends in
a draw another roller coaster of a game
absolutely up and down anything could
have happened in that King's Indian
David yeah anything could have happened
and eventually it fizzled out after both
players played equally inspiring chess
it was however this position where Abdul
Torah could have decided things he found
a great first move he should simply
calmly dropped his Queen back there's
now a pin the black Bishop cannot move
because the White Queen would break
through on F7 after F5 however all he
needed to do was spot he could take this
bishop and after a check he can block
maybe what he had missed was after Queen
A1 he can simply sidestep with the white
king another check can be met by a queen
Retreat everything's covered he emerges
with an extra bishop and he would have
won the game instead he let that black
Bishop live and he let Jordan van Forest
as Escape yeah this was such a big
moment and we can only hope that naughty
back update hasn't realized it but the
one player who did realize it is Jordan
and I think he checked it right after
the game and he reacts to that moment
this is a blind spot it happens to the
best in the world Jordan in absolute
disbelief there which means that both
these crazy crazy games have indeed
ended in a draw the result is still
Level between these two fighters we've
got two more games coming up and of
course we can only imagine the action to
get hotter from here we will be back
with more chess kid action after this
break
[Music]
foreign
tonight
[Music]
an aerofocus concentration performance
air things put you in control of air
pollutants that cloud your work from
home space shifting your state with
every breath
find your air of clarity now
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever
records and trophies first and only game
changing Innovations from the heroes we
admire to the joy of watching them play
our history defines us inspires us and
pushes us into the future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster at Magnus Academy
we've taught chess to a hundred thousand
kids with Summer around the corner we're
gearing up for camps
at online chess camps kids learn about
Chess in a safe fun environment from a
team of All-Star coaches
kids are grouped by skill level from
beginners up to national champions there
are never more than eight kids per coach
so every child gets plenty of attention
you might even get the chance to meet
Magnus and ask him a question or
challenge him to a game
each week has a different theme like
opening traps learning from your losses
or Magnus Carlson's best games
sign up by May 31st to get a 30 discount
join the 100
000 Kids and Counting that have learned
chess with Magnus chess Academy
[Music]
it's been a lot of fun in the winners
final two draws the score is leveled
between yard and Van forest and not the
back of this such of but the chess has
been intense and so much action David
I'm still thinking about that one
movement uh Jordan reacting after the
game when he realized it how do you
explain that at top level chess I guess
it's just the clock ticking it's the
pressure the high stakes this is the
winners final
um so much at stake but I think no deck
he's going to be kicking himself I'm not
sure he would have wanted to play
through that game he might have had an
even worse reaction than uh Jordan that
even more dramatic what a move that was
what a moment that was in the tournament
and then we saw Jordan in absolute
disbelief and then he laughs and he says
what he can't believe it himself what he
missed it wasn't just him but not a
backup there's such a a bishop hanging a
one move win and that's all that it
would have taken for not a bag after a
perfectly played game wow what around
that was and after all that Madness
James what are we expecting from game
three yeah he's gonna have to tighten up
him and Jordan you're gonna have to
tighten up a little bit there okay
because if you do not tighten up Abdul
satorf is coming for you he's being very
very good the only thing that messed up
was the time okay he got a long time and
when he got low he made a mistake which
happens we see it all the time but if
that keeps happening you know we're
gonna see North back definitely take a
run away with this one so gotta be
careful the one thing that we have seen
in this matchup is that nottyback he is
struggling a little bit with the clock
he's always the one who is down on the
clock he's got to make sure that doesn't
happen so that in those critical moments
you are you don't end up missing the
kind of moves that happened in game two
white for Jordan in this one no Kings
and then we're gonna see he's gonna
start with E4 it's hard to say he
started the first game with D4 he's
obviously an E4 player at heart so these
matches they fall into two categories
there are players who insist on
repeating whatever they prepared before
the match and then there are those
players who are willing to be flexible
let's see if Notre back repeats the
Queen's gamma Decline and he
cool
wow and for all of us all of you out
there who might be new to chess when
black does take that pawn on the second
move it is a Queen's Gambit accepted
just accepting that pawn if not we call
it the Queen's Gambit Decline and this
is Mainline Theory David still Mainland
Mainline Theory it's always kind of
bugged me the name Queen's Gambit
because you normally win the pawn back
within a move or two as has happened in
this game so you haven't really gambited
anything it was just a temporary deficit
there and uh meanwhile this is the key
position for white white has seven or
eight very logical moves he plays one of
the most trendy pushing a pawn forward
I'm really glad he didn't capture that
black Pawn on the center on C5 we would
have seen the Queens depart from the
board and things fizzle out slightly uh
so you're doing a very ambitious and uh
sort of reacting by pushing upon getting
ready to fianca to his Bishop
David Rao they're not happy with that
name because the pawn is picked up and
the question begs to be asked what is
your favorite Gambit I'm going to start
with James oh well let me go actually
Scotch Gambino aka the scotch Gambit we
actually have a chessable course in the
works with that one so it's gonna be
after my job London course but
definitely a scotch Gambino fan for life
what about you Daniel gonna have to go
with the night Earth game
um I like the Smith Mora I recommend it
to a lot of newer players Super Fun Line
and I avoid it with black so definitely
enjoy some of the games arising out of
the Smith Mora I think Mark Esserman
really enjoyed that answer
the Smith Mora comes after the Sicilian
David gonna throw that to you
voters Gambit is
it's nice right she could win with the
botos Gambit you're a truly great player
that's classy wow well I'll say that's a
tough one to win from but we have seen
that happen the potassium it was a queen
sacrifice yeah sacrifice is a generous
word for it honey
well in this one it is a Queen's Gambit
accepted but as you mentioned the pawn
has been recaptured and we see a lot of
play on the center of the board black
hasn't castled yet is it time to go for
King side castling that looks like the
safe option you do have a choice here
and a lot of peers a lot of players at
home might be wondering why not capture
this white knight in the center it's
intruded into the black half it does
double the white Pawns in the middle but
you do lose control over some key
squares or at least you give your
opponent time as well so in this
position as Tanya mentions the safe move
the logical move complete your
development when in doubt cast your king
it can nearly never be a bad thing
unless the opponent has a direct attack
the option here Knight takes Knight I
think could potentially backfire because
once the Black Knight moves I'm not sure
which Square white has access at some
point into these Key Dark squares and
actually the front Pawn the E5 Pawn acts
as a thorn in the black side it supports
a later jump so for example uh yeah here
if the Knight is kicked away I think you
can jump in immediately because there
will be some tactics you've unleashed
the bishop and any quintix pawn move
will be walking straight into a pin so
don't get tempted I would recommend
those Tanya says just castling whoops
made my arrows there sorry constantly
King side looks like Black's safest
option what do we think well uh well I'm
not a bad answer is it he's the brave
one he does go for
a formic line that you were pointing out
the 95 D5 this is going to be another
firefight
another firefight yeah so brave from not
to Beck bro it's not bad
there's a fine line between the two yeah
maybe he just wants to Castle here I
don't think you need to give white Time
by kicking away the White Knight yet
keep that one up your sleeve for later
I'm not sure Jordan delaying the jump of
the night I feel like he's he's a little
bit of a trusting going on these last
couple of games
yeah strange decision the bishop doesn't
necessarily want to be on this square
and after black castles now you most
likely want to jump into the center
anyway so uh strange to delay it but I'm
sure Jordan has something up his sleeve
do you think these decisions also come
from the fact that this time control
this time format it's rapid play you
want to make things interesting
objectively it might not be the most
accurate move but the one that makes it
more difficult to come back maybe in a
classical game not a back would have
chosen a different option yeah he's
trying to unbalance the game and I think
his decision is aging very nicely
because he's going to put a rook on d8
and at that point the Knight C4 D6
maneuver is going to lose a lot of its
luster
yeah I don't like it either just feels
really slow played by white he's
delaying again jumping in with the White
Knight
and once black gets fully organized
structurally black is doing great long
term look at that three versus two porn
majority on the queen side
pieces fly off the board it's only going
to be one-way traffic I actually like
plans here I think Queen C2 was nice I
also was looking at it I mean I'm very
creative like aggressive chest so like
Rook C1 C4 to G4 it's crazy but you're
gonna have to deal with the queen now
too as well and the idea here is Rick C1
Rick C4 Rook G4 obviously he might
attack it you move the Rook to G3 we go
Knight E4 and you go Knight F6 this is
the whole idea so you can probably do
the same thing with the queen now Queen
E4 Queen G4 Knight 84 Knight F6 just
attack right bring pieces to that side
of the board and attack him you know
this is very slow play which can be
played but for the aggressive crowd here
this is definitely a route Queen E4 over
to G4 the Knight looks like it can jump
around well now it can because the
rook's on d8 the B7 was uh was loose
there Rick now it's not because of Rook
D7
that's a really fun idea do you not care
at all about stuff like Knight E3 are
you really going for the kill with Queen
C4 can that be something that you have
to take into account yeah now you do the
902 is loose so you I mean it's a
problem and queen C4 will be hit
probably with Knight E3 takes takes
takes is there a rook F7 there Rook F1
Bishop F6
now you know what I'm doing crazy oh
yeah Tanya knows exactly what I'm
looking at but yeah I don't think we can
get away with it now though yeah Rook D1
it's gonna be very slow today slow play
but
that's a new one
Black Ops the pressure though on the D
file those two black Rooks stacked up
doubled up ready for some tactics there
and white decides to jump into the
center with his Knight so unfortunately
that does block the path over for the
White Queen or Rook but at least the
White Knight is nicely posted up
it's very tense it's hard to know how to
improve the position for either side
actually yeah like what does White's
next move but before you figure out
White's next move what does wax next
move and the standard reaction is just
to play H6 and then the white will play
H3 and they'll start this awkward waning
and white black will play A5 and
eventually someone will have to do
something but both sides delay it as
long as possible maybe 96 is possible
there is a pin with the dark Square
Bishop on E5 should black recapture it
with the Rook so Knight D6 actually
might be White's next move given the
opportunity yeah just to put that on the
board Dania important to H6 maybe Knight
D6 now maybe it's a threat as you
mentioned yes uh here you can touch this
Pawn in either direction he does drop
back the Queen the whole point here was
that Queen takes walks into this pin
obviously the Knight Falls because the
queen is standing behind it and uh maybe
the less obvious pin is this one you pin
and you win as uh Dimitri Collins has
shown today and here you win material
with white so really really clever kind
of strategic play here he spots that
that's a threat he drops back with Queen
instead of H6 there and
of course you cannot jump in because the
Rook can simply capture or if you jump
in then at least you're sacrificing
material for real Bishop to E5 can
simply be met by a retreat
really tense position here I'm not sure
who I would pick to be honest in the
game position
feels like black is doing really well
long term but white has some kind of
nasty tactics like that one we just
showed
I always like to Pawn on E5 I mean if
you have a Pawn on E5 it does signify a
king side attack but your pieces need to
actually be in position to attack
correctly it's very difficult because
everything like the pieces are all Queen
side in fact yeah Queen B1 okay it's not
going to be a sack anytime soon here in
black is fine I mean everything's
developed double works on the D file
Black's doing quite well in fact Queen
A8 comes to mind black does have ways
you can tighten the screws a5a4 is a
queen side idea so an outer bank is just
so alert I mean doesn't miss Knight D6
and I think he's kind of over the hump
here yeah I love your move down here
just I hate getting stared down by the
opposition Rook when I have a queen so
uh the white Rook on the C file opened
up against the black queen just shift
her and actually standing in the corner
she's just as active as any other Square
on the board
really nice and it supports any pawn
pushes on that flank as well
looks like it's gonna happen not about
just checking there are no tactics
that's the one downside for black you
always have to check there are no night
jumps you mentioned James some Knight F6
jump sir at some point here you have to
be aware of that a bit later on
that's it there we go Queen A8 into the
corner backing up her Bishop her lights
going Bishop there the queen
looking good for black I think I take
black here every time just better
structure long term if there's no
immediate uh tactics maybe working
double on the D file in order to because
Knight D6 is really the only idea that I
see
now maybe Rook D2 fails tactically you
already have to start calculating Knight
takes E3 but for the time being the
Knight on e4 is well enough protected so
if I'm Jordan I'm choosing between a
waiting move like H3 healthy waiting
move and move like Rook D2 which is a
little bit more ambitious
I think after all the kind of back rank
problems he had in the last game well
both players had in the last game H3 and
H6 would be a healthy inclusion for uh
both of them okay so you know how
aggressive we are what about Rook C4
anyway can you just wait Knight E3 no is
93 possible Rook C4 anyway though is
that late in the day for these kinds of
tactics or too early in the day
depending on yeah where you are or I
think Rook Seafood is it just Bears it's
okay it's not terrible but Rook C4
exactly the idea is just like I'm trying
to get Knight F6 in obviously or like
sometimes there might be like Rook D5
Knight F6 Rook over like there are some
nasty ideas here but Rook C4 has to be
played correctly and then you have to
figure out how do I get to the night
maybe Knight D6 Rook C4 is a move
very interesting idea is to build an
attack but first the players start with
h386 making sure that there is no back
rank stuff well we might be seeing Rook
C4 at some point and The Rook
transferring over to the king side
yeah I think they just needed to do that
give the king some lift give the king
some air at least uh there will be no
repeat of the previous game where both
sides were on the brink of getting
checkmated on the back ranks and okay
odd Bishop Retreat from uh Jordan that
must be lining something up and uh black
gaining space on the queen side does
black want to go A4 in these positions
and try to create a weakness on the
queen side
that's pretty good looks likely at least
he's forcing his opponent to deal with
that Potential Threat strategic threat
black wants to create a passport on the
side he's stronger when in doubt push on
the side you have more pawns more pieces
very logical stuff oh Queen B2 does
prepare an id6 but it runs into Knight
takes E3 right it relinquishes the
defense of the name maybe Jordan
overlooked that a lot of things that
white has to keep tabs on and if you
play A4 then you weaken the B4 square
and then the pressure on the E4 Knight
grows even more critical maybe that is
what white should do but Jordan suddenly
has a host of problems he has to solve
now order back is in control of the game
again wow
beautiful night and as you pointed out
there Dania Queen B2 you want to line up
just in case this diagonal opens but
Knight takes Pawn a killer blow just
because uh we'll I'm trying to do some
counting here you can simply take back
and Bishop takes Knight at the end the
queen no longer defends positions
falling apart and uh Jordan in a bit of
trouble maybe on the board and clock
tactics are everywhere and I'm just
wondering with white hair you want to
try to create your own chances maybe
it's time to think to start thinking
about sacrificing that E5 Pawn notice
how that Central Pawn on E5 is a pawn
and White's position you want it 63 yep
90. oh my gosh on the board look at
Jordan's face he realizes immediately
ran right into it because eventually a
piece is gonna have to take D1 it's
either the queen or the bishop both of
them defend the Knight Notre back is not
going to miss this he solves these for
breakfast he sold these for breakfast
seven years ago yeah he spotted it
instantly
wow he's spending a minute and then it's
on the board it's resignable it's not
just a pawn it's the whole the health of
the position collapses completely that
Bishop on anyone is pathetic and
Jordan's like I missed that one again
yeah Elementary stuff you always look
for forcing moves checks captures and
threats first in any position and this
is just the most forcing and it was
appearing in all sorts of positions this
was on his radar he just forgot to check
it he forgot to uh do a quick scan of
the tactics before he made his last move
and uh
I think we might see a resignation we
mentioned Tanya what you said like uh
what it would take you know after these
games here or after the last game here
especially for Jordan it was like he has
to tighten up you can't allow these type
of tactics and all one more tactics here
in the last game was the same thing but
Norbeck missed it but this one he didn't
miss and he has time on the clock so he
uses time well he found the right tactic
this is GG
yeah and the point I was just going to
make was that maybe just sacrifice the
E5 Pawn golden Knight D6 give up that
point and open up your bishop and try to
get some compensation with a bishop but
Queen C yes in this position David and I
see the eval Bar says black has an
advantage but at least here you've got a
bishop there you can continue fighting
for the initiative but Queen C2 another
big Miss and we have been seeing that
throughout the match the last game in
game two there was an entire piece
hanging missed by both these players but
not a back with 10 minutes on the clock
will not miss these tactics kids chess
kid moment loose pieces drop off always
look for these moments where your piece
has got too much responsibility that
queen that Bishop defending E4 and also
the Rook on D1 and some really cool
motives there David yeah let's just put
it on the board this is the current
position and it's so lost for white now
because you have to take this Knight
back your queen is attacked but after a
couple of trades on the D1 Square now as
Tanya mentions the queen and Bishop are
overloaded they both need to defend and
that night but unfortunately that one of
them needs to go and take this black
Rook as well the piece is overworked and
at the end you're left with a ruinous
position such as this one a pawn down
Black's going to create a majority here
you're left with terrible weak pawns
you're left with a stuck Bishop in the
corner as well and uh yeah at this high
level this is totally over and it is an
elementary tactic after all he simply
missed it and I like what nordebec did
he spotted it instantly he spent 30
seconds 40 seconds just double checking
and then he went for it don't rush even
if you think you see a promising move
yeah he calculated everything to
Perfection I mean to me if you're doing
an autopsy of the game yeah the proximal
cause of defeat is the fact that he
missed Knight takes you three as he
tries to muddy the waters with a queen
sacrifice desperation there with takes
B7 but there were mistakes leading up to
that he missed that early night jump
which would have given him the opening
initiative but this one's not over yet
Jordan will die on his feet what's going
on here which piece does Notre back take
what is this actually he made I think
just Queen takes B7 Maybe okay the
Knight F6 and take and take GF and
Knight takes a one and you're gonna end
up two pawns up in an opposite colored
Bishop end game some practical chances
maybe okay fair play to Jordan he's uh
complicated things slightly he's at
least making nordeback pause and as you
say maybe you have to be slightly
careful here with black and just before
we show that variation maybe we can get
stockfish's help how many moves give
black the advantage are there more than
one or two it might just be one honestly
but let's see two moves give a winning
position one move throws away the bulk
of the advantage and uh luckily here for
another back those are the two most
obvious moves so he will play one of
these two for sure I think the safest as
you mentioned there is quintix B7 also
the best move giving away the queen
returning the sacrifice because this
check jumping out the way with the white
knight will win the queen here you can
maybe even take with either piece either
piece uh take it with the pawn the
safest after the queen is recaptured
Knight takes bishop and uh yeah two
pawns up should be more than enough
majority on this side of the board and
majority in the center as well and it's
happening David as you're mentioning
this is the best option for Naughty back
he finds it the queen will be given back
but it has a big potential for black in
this position up on the clock up on the
position is this close to another back
win
yes very close
he's gone with the bishop and I think
this is even better oh yeah surgical
Precision again from Notre back that's
that's what he did against cartwana
doesn't give these guys a single chance
he always pauses the right moment he
never does anything automatically
who says that a lot
enough two extra bonds one apostle
Apostle the queen side and
I'm at a3b3 received for God in mind for
his once that Rook slides up the board
to the third rank you are targeting all
the white Pawns Yeah you mentioned that
term surgical Precision there Daniel and
I think this last move really key if the
bishop had just moved to a kind of
random safe Square white would have had
the time to push the a pawn up one and
maybe at least create a blockade of
Black's Queen side majority there but
now White's Rook is forced to decide
where to go black I don't think will uh
give white that luxury of setting up a
blockade on the light squares
I think the weaknesses are going to
count maybe there's something even more
kind of immediate than just slowly
advancing those black pawns really just
clinical play Here by notabeck
opposite color Bishop so maybe there's
still work to be done here good
technique to be shown or not the third
Pawn drop there's another one maybe
bishop C8 takes B3 Rook takes E6 can be
tried as a last digit tab the bishop C8
is pathetic you can play King f8 I would
try it though I would go Bishop C8 yeah
my dirty bullet mine supplying the one
move tricks but a class beginning and we
do have a result Jordan Von forest does
resign after that last move as the third
Pawn will fall which means that not a
back takes the lead in that match Jordan
has to win the final rapid game to take
it to the Armageddon what a game with
the black pieces by notabeck David what
was the key moment I think the key
moment was a moment of blindness
tactical uh tactical blunder here by
Jordan van Forrest actually any random
move any kind of neutral move here would
have kept the balance even if white just
Waits even if white passes with a move
such as Bishop B2 the onus is on black
to actually create something white has
everything protected and there's no
immediate knockout unfortunately however
he put his Queen on a vulnerable square
and the lesson to everyone at home is
look for those tactics look for those
forcing moves checks captures and
threats in that order and here capture
was the one that did the business as we
saw the White Queen was overloaded in
this variation if the Rooks had come off
and uh it was actually Jordan in the end
deciding to go down fighting sacrificing
his Queen and he was punished with some
nice play by nederbeck
tactics everywhere and you always always
have to be on the lookout for them
especially when you're playing against
appear like not the back and that means
that he does take the lead in this game
three a big win with the black pieces he
starts game four with white Jordan man
first has to find a way to create his
chances with the black pieces but if
there's anyone who can do that with the
kind of crazy chest that we've seen it
is a yard and run for us and we will be
back with more chess kid action in just
a few
foreign
[Music]
Focus concentration performance
air things put you in control of air
pollutants that cloud your work from
home space
shifting your state with every breath
find your era of clarity now
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
we've witnessed moments that will last
forever
records and trophies first and only
game-changing Innovations from the
heroes we admire to the joy of watching
them play our history defines us
inspires us and pushes us into the
future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster
the players being forever faster
fighting to win the just a kid cop but
meanwhile we do have the winners of the
just kid drawing competition and they do
get a one-year chested gold membership
they sent in some amazing amazing art
take a look at the winners
amazing portraits chess kid and the
Champions Chester will feel confident of
the future of both chess and arts
[Music]
by Jose Alonso matero Reyes Fabiano
caruana by Olia
foreign
[Music]
by
Alida Hoyle
Alexander shimanov by Michaela Arana
van Forest
Paul welhauser
oh my gosh I love it we've got to bring
those on again guys let's take a look
and let's do a little breakdown and try
and recognize everyone some this one's
uh James this one's so cool I love chess
yeah that's really I mean it's the
detail there these are very talented
kids here I mean you've got all the
pieces right look at the board they
didn't miss mess anything up that is a
very nice picture right there one E4
best
this one oh who do you think this is
sabiano caruano I wonder I like the
little speech bubble that's a nice touch
with the proper move notation very well
done attention to details the glasses of
course love it
okay oh wow oh I thought this was me for
a second
this is notibeca and a really nice
drawing uh really accurate actually nice
attention to detail and you know the
detail I love the most about this one is
the metal if you see around his neck oh
and that reminds me of the Chennai
Olympiad where this big team did win the
gold medal so that is fantastic stuff
wow well done guys
nice this is uh this has got to be the
cutest drawing I love it this one gets
my wart oh yeah Dimitri call us you
wouldn't think that he's not shaking for
anybody else in the world anyone you
wouldn't think he's such a warrior on
the chessboard with a cute face like
that one look at that
it's looking very fashionable and very
stylish there
definitely stylish I can see it okay
nice that's a lot going on all right
yeah the space looks like after a
blunder it's all red that's probably
what they oh I get it now because
they're going far I got it
oh
jvf himself Jordan in about 75 years
oh my gosh yeah love the colors your
Garden van right out of the forest would
look like that
and there we gosh Musa he did win his
game today and wow and these are the
winners of our chesky drawing
competition and we really thank you for
all your submissions from the chess club
in Peru just amazing amazing stuff and
we are seeing amazing action all around
in all the divisions and once again
we've got with us Ginger GM but before
that these are the kids who submitted
their drawings with their artwork
combining sure making chess chess is Art
science Port all of it
yeah that was in it's only karpov I
think chess is Art science sport drawing
apparently art in the most direct form
but great to see involvement from all
sides and uh just the level of
Engagement really elevates this
tournament to a different level
and they win a one year gold membership
on chess game it is the most fun and
entertaining platform for kids across
the world to learn chess to play chess
to become Masters all the players that
we see in the chess kid in fact started
their Journey on the platform and
speaking of all the fun that we're
having there's been a lot of fun in the
other divisions as well and we've got
Simon with us in the studio for some
more fun
yeah hi there
um I've just got to get over that
picture of Jordan though that might
might give me some nightmares there just
gonna blank that out of my brain for a
little bit
um great picture though yeah loved it
um and yeah I'm gonna bring you all the
action from division two and three and
there's been a lot of action and the
winners semi-finals and let's remember
whoever wins division two goes into
division one so it's a biggie and you
can see that uh trong went through there
against operin and we have a feathersev
going through against sadwani there so
that was the first results and then in
the losers section who's going home
where everyone who's been grayed out is
it is packing they're all going back and
still in the competition some big names
AJ king
um and Lee mavajarov and Liam Lee as
well so there's lots of uh good games
going on there and then more results
here and we see that age raking and
mamajarov still in with a shout there so
even bigger names this is how many games
have been played uh during the whole
um season of uh division two and uh yeah
that's gonna be division three even so
uh and let's have a look at division
three now and um yes this one was a bit
of a shock we saw that picture had
managed to beat Harry Krishna and Harry
Krishna is still in with a chance
because he's got his second uh roll of
the dice there in the losers bracket but
that was a great result for pitcher and
then going to the losers section of that
so again the players in Gray have been
knocked out but through gatakamski Sam
sevilleon uh donachenko and David Navara
and they went on to the next round of
course a lot of pages on there and the
next round gadakowski took down Sam
sevilleon in the battle of the veteran
and then David Navara beat donachenko so
I think we're getting there now lots to
catch up on there's been so much action
going on there it's just you know a lot
to take in
um but I want to pick out one moment
which was quite beautiful from one of
those games let's see if you can spot
the tactic at home and this is from the
division to losers bracket and it was
Dimitri adri aching a very good player
with the white pieces and he got this
very dominating position so get the
brain whirling what would you do as
white here there's some nice little
tactics the black king is looking rather
dodgy there it's a bit naked a bit
exposed to the elements needs to put
some clothes on and you'd like to go
Queen takes Pawn but that doesn't quite
work here because after our Rook swings
over trying to do the lawn mode
Checkmate black and block with the queen
so you've got to try to think of a way
to distract that Queen so let's go back
and can you see a nice little idea
there's a couple of ideas but I love
this mood the night just switches back
to attack the queen and uh they say
retreating night moves are the hardest
moves to find now the black queen has to
move Now it only has really one square
to go to it it moves to that square and
the same idea it can come across to
block The Rook so again if you take the
pawn and uh the king takes the Rook
checks the queen comes across so you've
got to think of another way to make sure
the queen can't come over there and
these guys are good aren't they I mean I
know everyone on the desk here will see
it in a heartbeat I've been very
impressed by your tactics today it's
been it's been good stuff great to watch
and now the bishop just slides in very
elegantly in way of the queen and that
is such a beautiful move and the point
here is let's say the bishop is taken
there's nothing else you can do now we
can give up the queen oh yeah that is a
beautiful beautiful way to finish game
and look at that that's what we call the
lawn mower Checkmate or the guillotine
Checkmate or the blue line checkmates or
the I'm not sure what I'm talking about
checkmates and uh we call it the lawn
mugs it's like you know you're you're
doing that I think is that right I guess
so yeah I might I'm just making sure I'm
not making that up
um so very nice game there and that
means that Dimitri adrakin is in a very
good position after winning that one and
remember division two whoever wins
division two gets in division one and
gets ten thousand dollars not bad uh so
all pretty good going there and uh yeah
yeah so lots of action there that we've
caught up on and uh I'm sure we're gonna
get more fantastic moves there coming
through in there in the next uh next day
or so
Simon those are some incredible tactics
that you just showed us so instructive
and I'm also thinking about the one that
you showed with Fellowship the night
jumping around big fish oh my God he's
on absolute Fire arena Royale Gotham
Knights MVP of protest League ruling
division two currently just amazing
stuff we're seeing all around and thank
you so much Simon for all that we've got
some amazing news for chat by the way uh
Ginger GM has got a surprise Simon
what's going on here
you got 40 off on all your courses I do
and apparently I've only got one set of
clothes as well which I always wear my
gray jacket and my black t-shirt but you
know I might have to diverse if someone
buys a course I will buy another outfit
how about that but yeah I've got many
chessboard courses out uh it's a great
way to improve your chest to get better
at chess to get better at your openings
and they're all on sale at the moment at
least 40 off so go and check them out
get yourself bargained do you want to
play like ginger G I'm strong and
attacking with all those tactics and
some really cool openings definitely
check out his courses Untouchable with a
very cool 40 percent off and right now
we will be back with the very cool
matchup but we're not back up to satrov
and Jordan van Forest the players are
ready to go not a back needs just a draw
to win the match how and where does
Jordan create his chances is it time for
chess kid
King's Indian defense that's the most
dynamic opening of all against one
divide oh a switch up though white goes
for the fear cutter variation solid one
Daniel that's a buzz so that's one of
the least favorite responses that most
Kings Indian players face the same ish
is annoying but the fianchetto is as
solid as it gets but it's not just solid
it's also principled it's a great way to
fight for the advantage now black could
transpose this into a grundful type
setup the recommendation of some recent
King's Indian specials is again to play
this benoni style with an early C5 let's
see how Jordan handles this I've mostly
played D6 Knight bd7 and E5 which is the
sort of old school traditional method
and it does produce a guaranteed
imbalance yeah James what do you make of
the body language of Jordan right now
looks like he's hating life yeah he's uh
you know you have to especially when he
saw the fin Shadow variation he wasn't
too happy to see that either but uh
definitely in the zone I have to be
focused here I have to play just
whatever the position gives me he's
going with the Knight C6 version this
one's actually pretty topical as well
usually can do things like Ace six just
have E5 here he plays Bishop D7 more of
a waiting move to uh as well I mean you
can get chances here but it's really
difficult because it's extremely solid
for white playing the fin Shadow
variation
Jordan van first with the king's Indian
defense trying to create Chaos on the
board but a really good match approach
there by noribbeck Abdul satro going for
the most solid response against the
king's Indian defense and that's because
players with the black pieces who want
to go in for this opening are looking
forward to all the fireworks to all the
attack and play on either side but the
G3 fan Shadow system just kills all of
that out and this is a no fun King's
Indian defense no this is actually the
least fun he's Indian defense that's why
I don't like playing Knight C6 the
Knight is now stuck on the rim and the
traditional way to play this is to push
the pawn a C5 and prepare B7 B5 we saw
this in the previous King's Indian games
Jordan hasn't had enough of the pawn
Breakers there are some tactics Down The
Long diagonal but they usually don't
work because white can Garner two minor
pieces for a rook yeah and maybe we can
show one of those variations Dania just
on the last turn it did look like white
had weakened himself along this diagonal
but if for example you jump into the
center with your knight then this will
backfire the Knight is simply captured
black does wind material temporarily but
two loose pieces two undefended pieces
you can attack them both in one Fell
Swoop you attack the Knight attack the
bishop and as you mentioned white wins
material so he has kept the tension here
Jordan and uh he's aiming for that break
that you mentioned how do we think white
is going to deal with this one ignore it
or deal with it instantly
if there is a way
resign time to resign that's it yeah I
guess I would be tempted to just kind of
put the bishop on this Square just to
hint at some attack against this Knight
if uh black now goes for this Pawn push
at least there are some weaknesses
I've not been a huge expert here I must
say feels like black has got some
chances to imbalance things at least at
least chip away at this really strong
white Pawn chain if you see your
opponent has a strong chain like this
hammer away at it and try to open lines
I mean it does make Nordic think here
like he is not found any response yet
because B5 is coming whether you like it
or not I mean maybe even
Queen D3 doesn't really stop it I mean
we want to do it anyway so you play
Bishop B2 definitely double finchito so
take all as well says 92 as possible now
to protect the pawn you could play C
takes B5 you know the world doesn't end
if you break up your Pawn chain because
the D5 Pawn is pretty well protected and
sometimes you see the knight from F3
hopping into D4 and then into C6 but
normally you don't want to do that
unless you have to
he goes 94 straight away and his idea is
D take C4 B4 and then once he sticks a
knight on C6 it can't be captured
because the pawn will trap black snide
on B7 incredible tactical Vision already
beautiful stuff B4 here if the Knight
Retreats nice E6 hitting the queen
beautiful attack here actually only one
kind of I was gonna say legal move here
but uh to keep the game going you can't
sidestep because of a nasty night Fork
you have to sidestep the other way but
uh to show dania's idea wow this is the
most dominated Knight you will ever see
trapped and okay he didn't go for this I
was wondering whether maybe in this
position before it's too late before you
blunder uh after B4 maybe Rook B8 Queen
B8 but uh he did not dare go for this
and instead we're left with this
position white has a semi-open file on
the C file beautiful Knight on D4 but
I'm wondering where uh the White Knight
hops to after the move B4 for black this
time kicking this piece away from his
dream post on C3
looks susceptible to Black for black to
me I don't really want to retreat with
white I don't know where Retreat go to
the side go to the center lots of choice
I think he has to go for this Jordan
there we go before on the board the
question where do you work and whites
try to maneuver the night you said you
don't like the move Knight B1 but it's a
long path getting to C4 but we could be
seeing that happen right now not a
backup to satrobe is in the think in
this moment it is definitely impressive
how Jordan from that G3 fanchato King's
Indian has still managed to well
imbalance the position we see that one
Pawn on the queen side the beep on
controlling two of white spawns C7 is a
little bit of a weakness the bishop on
G7 it's a monster of a piece there are
there's a lot to play for and things
could potentially go wrong for white and
let's not forget it was with the black
pieces that Jordan went Forest defeated
Notre back in the final round of Tata
steel to give us for Anish giri the
victory of course a niche also beat a
guy named Richard report
so hopefully Notre back has pushed that
away from his mind in that game Notre
Beck played one E4 it was a Tamanna of
Sicilian so this is a completely
different opening but Jordan knows that
it's possible and he could meet a move
like Knight B1 perhaps with E5 in order
to expand in the center I think he's
done what he has to do out of the
opening now you actually have to beat
notorbeck from an equal position yeah
you have to outplay him and there are
enough out balances uh with which to do
that imagine lightning striking twice
twice now up to satoroph in Vikings and
here needing just to draw against Jordan
with white
it would be so heartbreaking if he fails
and uh I don't think you could recover
from that he needs the draw here now
okay Bishop for Night Exchange black is
really saddled Now with uh weak light
squares but his structure is superior
what do you think of this uh this kind
of transition James this rockstar I
actually like uh what black has with
this nice C5 move you can't put the
Knight because the C file is very weak I
mean obviously I put the queen on C2 you
know I just have pressure all the time
Knight C6 square is mine in many cases
obviously you have to deal with the
tensions of the Bishops on G7 and B2 but
Queen C2 looks good but then you have
you know Knight to C5 there we also have
Pawn brakes E6 E5 we can go uh maybe F5
that's a that's a long shot of course
he's going to make E6 very weak we do
need to deal with this D5 Pawn at some
point but I think this is a great move I
think from uh from the order here was
Knight D7 Knight C5 and it targets the
week A4 Pawn
yeah it feels like Abdul satorab needs
some energy in his position now he needs
some tactics maybe Daniel Knight C6 not
really a tactic but if you trade off all
those pieces you can stick a rook on C6
the queen comes into D4 and mainly you
eliminate black spin keto King's Indian
Bishop so I'm a little bit worried about
Jordan's winning chances in this bishop
versus night position yeah the Knight is
better than the bishop technically but
there are other factors at play the B4
Pawn is weak can be targeted with Queen
to D4 and Rook B1 you pointed out the
past a pawn
I'm kind of skeptical about black
chances here of course D takes C6 is
also possible and neuterbeck clearly
calculating lines like these yeah this
feels relatively safe for white and
that's all you need if you're up to
sator of right now and uh just to
mention James idea as well if black does
get a knight to C5 and blocks kind of
plugs the C file then he will breathe
aside relief so it does feel like here
and now is the moment for Abdus tour of
to do something you don't really want to
take a time out and play a quiet move a
slow move because blacks Knights will
take over the queen side and also you
mentioned this Pawn a huge Target so
yeah I like it Daniel just jump in and
if there's no downsides it kind of it
really helps your task if you can get as
many pieces off the board as possible
just from a psychological point of view
you know you're in no danger there with
white
10 minutes for update he struggled with
the clock it's been tactically sharp and
he jumps in we'll see all of those
trades happen now there we go very quick
lots of forcing moves the bishop has to
be captured pretty much
and which way will white retake this
Knight with porn or Rook looks like Rook
It's gotta be real
yeah you want to keep the pressure on
the C7 pawn and that D5 pawn it looks so
good just cramping down why a Black's
position there he does it Rook C6 double
up triple up on the C line and go for C7
there is a clear idea and of course the
a pawn can if it does get to A6 it's
going to be quite the dangerous pawn and
A5 A6 how are you fighting it Rook it
K8 maybe B3 the black B4 Pawn needs
protection
I don't like it okay the Knight tries to
block but now just give a check in the
center what could be more natural
improve the White Queen
just lifeless after rugby one I mean if
the B4 Pawn is eliminated how on Earth
is black going to win this game yeah
what was your advice there
just automatic gestures improving pieces
he's not doing anything flashy I think
apart from that one tactic uh in the in
the previous game the last two games
I've just tutorial he's just playing
sensible moves he's putting the pressure
on Jordan it's up to him to create
something yeah we got nothing out of
this from a king Sandy and fin Shadow
variation it's very likely and probably
one of the most annoying variations to
face uh in the king's India I mean we
got nothing out of this the bar Square
Bishops are gone in fact even Dania
mentioned in the beginning with the
early night b2d7 E5 the classical way of
doing the king's Indian is usually where
you always get yourself some type of
game there always some type of imbalance
here this doesn't seem like we have the
chances yet to create anything that we
need to play for a win in Jordan's shoes
yeah I don't know if you're worse here
but you're definitely not better with
black and that's the big problem
it's not about uh it's not about drawing
this game it's not about holding it it's
about creating something and white has
full control look how active white
pieces are it's just that one problem
piece for white the bishop you kind of
want to trade everything off and be left
with a good knight versus a bad Bishop
but that's a dream right now and it's
such a nightmare to try to create
winning Chances with black in these
clutch win match moments so I want to
ask you David I'll start with you all of
you actually that in such a situation as
a player what do you do when you have to
pay for a win with the black pieces
what's the best approach yeah I when I
was younger I used to think okay let's
just take massive risks and just burn
our bridges and uh kind of hope that it
works out but as I've got older I've
realized that actually just keeping the
tension and playing on the opponent's
nerves is the key so Jordan here he's
running out of material to do that with
but uh if he could somehow keep the
tension just get a slower position
slowly outplay the opponent while
they're kind of making negative passive
decisions playing for that draw and that
would be my advice but you'll play
Someone Like abdicator of I don't think
that will help he doesn't seem to get
nervous
and Harry the hitchport and making an
appearance that black king defenseless
as well if that pawn pushes even further
down the board yeah
we were talking about the APR now h586
H4 and we're live James James do you
think that is also uh the approach just
trying to create tension rather than
forcing matters keep more pieces on the
board absolutely of course I mean well
first things first I'm trying to pay for
a win and playing King's Indian like
this the number one and the number two
yes you do want to keep pieces on the
board and go for challenging lines like
of course you do have to take some risk
play the board play obviously what you
like and then try to attack of course I
mean attacking is fun and play what you
know best so Jordan is an attacking
player things like that but this was not
an attacking King's Indian at all this
was more positional which of course yeah
we got a nice position it's okay it's
playable but it's when playing for a win
it looks like white is the one playing
for the win right now in fact it looks
like White's the one who's going for the
attack how are you stopping 8586 do you
want to commit with H5 yourself I have
no idea because if you play H5 you run
the risk of meeting with G4 and then the
game could end in like three moves and
when I say the game could end you could
get checkmated or all the pieces could
get traded and the match ends either way
so
I just don't the problem is black is so
tied down to the C7 Pawn like any time
you move the queen away from d8 White
gobbles up that pawn it's really as easy
as ABC I think Jordan is is just
completely running out of ideas he's
doing everything he can but I just don't
see it I don't see any Avenues of
complicating this game at all a
notorbeck with 10 minutes on his clock
to figure out whatever Jordan throws at
him yeah and that's the problem here I
would love such as Queen to B8 trying to
somehow get the Queen's off Force to
draw but a draw isn't good enough and
here for example I think you might be
okay just because the black Rook will
get so active for example you could take
a timeout I don't know if white can save
this porn long term the black Rook will
come down or maybe even just step across
but even at the best kind of case
scenario even if you win this Pawn back
yes you can hope for that should be a
draw so okay he's forced to keep the
Queens on the board Jordan but this has
come at the cost potentially of this
Pawn just white take it now that's the
key question or does white just take a
time out to defend this little guy on A2
yarn does look pretty disgusted with the
position that he has playing the king's
Indian defense expecting fireworks but
really nicely handled there by notabeck
and right now in a thing about whether
to allow this activity with blackstroke
coming to be it the queen coming on
picking up that pawn on A2 questions to
be answered with the lines that we're
looking at it looks as if it's all
ending well for white hair Rook C7 does
Black start with no 986 I just realized
oh my gosh I didn't see that until two
seconds ago that's such a devious little
idea that retreating Night Moves maybe
Rook takes C5 should be considered by
Notre back I know it sounds drastic but
that exchange that could give him some
good chance of course he sees it
yeah it's just like Simon said
retreating Night Moves backward Night
Moves
I think that would have caught me out
for sure tricky tricky but uh okay he
just sidesteps with the queen getting
out of that fork defends this pawn and
now threatening the black C7 Pawn for
real and oh you wouldn't I like what
he's doing I've got to say defending
this Pawn but also threatening to slide
in a bit of a scary movie comes in next
okay some trances here coming in behind
suddenly this white Rook is trapped and
uh you might not be able to win it but
if you can keep it caged keep it boxed
you might be just be playing with extra
pieces for black
like 97.95 as well I'm just
I'm just attack on the king side h586
Queen D4 but this does allow a check on
E1
8 B1 suddenly
we're at King's Indian again somehow or
somehow Kings Indian just working here I
miss how it is the magic of the king's
India we did not get in the position
that we would like for an aggressive
Kings Indiana to play four win but we
now have some chances that you know we
didn't have before which is really nice
to see for King's Indian players here
but this is not over yet yeah I eat all
my words I was being too harsh Jordan I
think I underestimated his just
resourcefulness in his creativity and
even getting a playable position like
this and
I think nudibex is going to start
getting nervous he might still have that
kind of uh cool exterior but inside he's
going to be thinking not again not again
not like Tata steel and uh suddenly
contemplate he's lost control and
he might still save it he might uh still
be fine here with white objectively but
Panic is going to be setting in do you
think it's
it's battled right now for not a back
with those Nightmares From Tata steel oh
definitely oh my gosh treating now I was
just taking this move Queen for somebody
I was like Queen C1 feels good at least
right it's a great move it covers all
the key squares the queen can reroute to
E3 right now right and it does and I
think he's gonna hold it yeah he's gonna
take C7 E7 also H6 still there you got
to be careful of your own back ring too
if you play Rook B1 King H2 and then we
take and we're threading almost made on
the back rank okay very resourceful
Queen C1 was a nice move yeah White's
Bishop is terrible it's blocked in by
its own Pawn but the good thing about
Bishops is especially fearing chattered
Bishops they are great Defenders so even
if the black queen and Rook slide behind
that white king will be safe he'll be
protected by its uh good friend now on
G2 meanwhile the pawn is going to be
recaptured black oppon up but you can't
defend everything Queen C1 just uh I was
saying Panic what Panic just so calm
retreating giving up a pawn who cares
just centralized the queen again good
classical chess wisdom he's so good in
Queen end games after satoroff and he's
centralized perfectly there I mean black
ones are centralized the queen gives a
check first and fall back to F5 hitting
the pawn on H5 as well and taking
control of the king's side so really
nice play by both these players just
keeping the game alive green F5
F5 and we live sitting there now if I
white I would really want to just kind
of Slide the bishop up to F3 just to
protect that white H Pawn I wouldn't be
really reluctant to open up the H file
that line that the white king sits on
just in case
but uh yeah is there another way for him
to keep control there we go just defend
everything black really doesn't want to
open up his own King taking that white H
Pawn and meanwhile still in a dual
attack against two other black pawns
whites were threatening to break out of
that cage
by taking on C7 maybe just Queen D7 and
hold on
hold on to your extra Pawn like a grudge
I mean I don't know white will play H6
and then set up threats with Queen D4
that's the depressing thing even with an
extra Pawn
you don't even feel it because black
spawn majority is so immobile
oh I just saw some cool tactics but I'll
wait for them to happen on the board
here Queen back to D7 does black want to
trade off that white Rook it feels like
an intruder in the black Camp uh
looks like that might be the way to go
though retreating with the black queen
if you want to win this game at least
there might be other safer Avenues
still so tense yeah Garden man forest
with an extra Pawn but still the peace
activity that white has and the attack
on the C7 Pawn the attack on the E7 Pawn
gives another bag enough compensation
and a big decision a committal decision
there by a Jordan he pushes the Jeep on
David I see your expression what is this
move G4 is the idea of what's going on
here yeah G4 for the score he wants to
play next move he plays it first okay
question and it's played and queen F6
answered yeah if black had time to go
one square further to kick away that
white Bishop that would have been a
mating attack potentially against the
white king but for now White's King is
safe and white has won the pawn back the
downside is now any end games might
favor Black White's Bishop is terrible
Locked In by its own pawns the Black
Knight much more flexible and also note
how most of the pawns are just on one
flank of the board we've talked about
this throughout the uh chess kid cup
Bishops are better than knights with uh
pawns on both flanks here it's
definitely this Knight that is superior
well dark Square control by Jordan he's
playing it positionally
what do we think of this Daniel well
Rook take my eyes are always drawn to
this exchange sack Rook takes C5 because
so many of the pawns are on light
squares they're incredibly hard to
attack but I think Notre back views this
as a desperation measure right now he
has a very simple question for Jordan
how are you going to make progress your
night is pretty your pawns are pretty
but D5 E2 and G4 all of the vulnerable
pawns are protected by one piece that
piece is itself protected by the pawn
the king and the queen so it's
incredibly solid and if Black's Rook
moves away from the eighth rank black
could absolutely get mated by a tandem
of the queen of the Brooks Jordan has a
lot of enemies at his door and he's
navigating them so well he's producing
chance after chance he's forcing Notre
back to be accurate but those background
Master is not flinching at all thus far
yeah the black Rook forced into
passivity not what he wanted Jordan
key question is whether he can improve
his Knight if the Black Knight was
somewhere nearer the white king then
huge chances
okay why is this a blunder five and G4
oh my God five we live we're going home
again possibly the ship won't have trees
trapped
he wanted to trade the Rooks with Rook
B8 he wasn't just trying to be fancy he
was trying to force pieces off the board
and he just forgot where the danger
comes from
this bishop is trapped nowhere to go and
if you can't take this Pawn you're just
going down a pawn at the very minimum it
crossed my mind just pushing this Pawn
forward trying to hit the black queen
but maybe the idea persists maybe you
just it doesn't help yeah it doesn't
help at all we should do one Queen D5
still for Owen The Rook is hanging too
oh yes and this is the first time I'm
seeing not a bad just lean into the
screen like that
he knows that this is turning around F5
is there a way to actually safeguardia
Bishop David is it all over for him look
at the bar it's all over in one move we
were just saying he's played perfectly
he's found safety but this happens when
your queen gets too far distanced from
your king you lose all ability to defend
and this white Bishop we thought it was
holding the fort on its own turns out
that was an illusion and uh White's
going down to defeat now also it is
Clumsy putting that white Rook on a
square it can later be captured by the
Black Knight
I think he just panicked I think he got
over excited and the thought the
prospect of getting that desired draw
relaxation Jordan needs to do it this
morning James is played the move Queen
to C4 get out of that bin hit that Rook
threaten the pawn on G4 and that's it
and we have ourselves an armageddami
there's a reminiscent of what happened
before right all I needed to draw
playing this guy in like same thing
happens it's crazy how it just repeats
itself like that in the same situation
hopefully he's able to try to salvage
this but it doesn't look like the rook's
hanging and we're going to take G4 whoa
what the heck yeah but Jordan wasn't
born yesterday he's not gonna allow
Queen h8 come on you played that so
quick too King G8 yeah like no way
so sneaky dropping the White Queen back
trying to get onto the uh opposite
corner on the diagonal but yeah Jordan
thinking of the opponent's time that's
kind of a boss move your opponent plays
like the trickiest tactic ever nope I've
spotted it bang I've shut the door rugby
one and keep fighting it's like Bishop
D1 Black's King is a little bit Airy so
Jordan has to demonstrate some Precision
but he could just maybe go for checkmate
without even touching the D5 Pawn
yeah Black's gonna be at least one Pawn
up and
still struggling to see how White's
Queen ever kind of zigzags her way in
towards the black king feels like a pipe
dream
another turnaround in this match and now
for another back he's got all these
difficult questions to answer with just
four minutes on the clock and in the
studio we keep talking about that big
moment from earlier in the year at the
Tata steel Masters 2023 a fantastic
performance by notabeck saw him leading
the tournament from the start and it was
in round 13 the very last round where
Jordan run Forrest with the black pieces
took away all those dreams beat him and
this a big grudge match everything going
his way and now we're seeing another
turn around Jordan not a back going into
Armageddon
Jordan's just in the zone we saw him
just kind of hiding his head at the
beginning of the game I think that
helped him regain his Focus after that
heartbreaking defeat in the previous
game with whiten
what a beautiful move King G8 in one
second just yeah really fast so I got
out of there yeah I mean this was great
I mean is is very powerful but this was
one that was dry from the beginning very
dry position he just worked it worked
the magic that he could got some chances
there and took them when they were there
so great job from Jordan so far just
making the best of his position and
creating these problems that are
unsolvable right now for Abdul Satora
yeah a couple pipe dreams here maybe
Rook A8 at the right moment some
perpetuals if you take the punt on D5
you have to watch out for the bishop
coming to B3 once the Knight moves on to
Greener pasture so just a couple T's
left across an ice dot but Jordan's got
six minutes to do it I I just don't see
outer back pulling out a Swindle here
does pull this one off for the Army
Garden do you think the momentum totally
shifts towards Jordan absolutely of
course especially that last game when
you win that last game and you're going
into an Armageddon you still feel the
pain of the last game so of course it's
easier said than done it's like a little
bit of Psych there you got to get over
it but hey I won I'm feeling good you're
feeling a little bit more confident too
especially even if you win the bid there
it'll be even better and then black
piece is winning let's say Jordan gets
the bid and it could be game over
the bishop has fallen back and David in
this position can black just start
getting greedy pick up the D5 Pawn with
the check he's done it says yes
something wrong FG what's the follow-up
giving back one point he wouldn't just
open up the white king but yeah the
proof is in the pudding you've got to
eat that pawn and
ask black the question how to Checkmate
because Rock Cafe blunders the E7 Pawn
that's a very easy pawn to blue and then
that Queen and A1 is going to have its
moment in the Sun
between wow what is the follow-up four
do you want to hit the E3 Pawn okay we
need to check maybe there oh your checks
yeah
feels like both things are equally open
at this point Feels Like Jordan maybe
didn't need to get greedy and if you ask
the question Tanya I was saying okay I
wouldn't be able to resist either just
taking that pawn but suddenly on the
light squares as Daniel mentioned all
sorts of tricks and okay he's jumped in
but showing almost equality here what
24. is it Queen D4 and then forcing that
Queen trade the Knight is nowhere good
to go the bishop jumps out to A4 E7
Falls I think he's bothered Queen D4
must have missed it I don't know if
that's the move Queen D4 Queen E1 in G2
then
oh wow let's ask sockfish for help here
Queen D4 only move everything else
you'll find the black there's just
nothing else to do queen A2 check is a
miserable end game he's reaching out
he's about to make a move Queen A2 does
trade the Queens but a really bad end
game and he finds it Queen D4 super
precise by notabeck geez you didn't got
impatient he tried to force the win he
was a pawn up of two pawns up he didn't
need to go this Direct
oh wow I thought I was bracing myself
for Armageddon I was saying okay well
lightning strike twice will it strike
again same
24 yeah Black's Rook is just too passive
what a sequel so Queenie one king G2
Rook Cafe Bishop F3 and like and now
who's attacking who buddy you know
that's actually very scary line there
yeah that's ubiscus F3 is sacking he was
no good right Rook takes F3 tanks check
yeah King is G4 you probably got
Perpetual there but not more than that
and Jordan of course cannot trade queens
that was Zero winning chances there he's
tried to check on E1 but the Knight on
C5 is just not contributing to the
attack in any way it's totally dominated
by the queen
I don't see a move for him it's even on
the board Queen E1 King G2 and look he's
shaking his head oh my goodness nothing
to do this is maybe what he'd missed the
black Rooks entry can't be blocked by
the movie you guys mentioned Bishop F3
attacking as well as defending
wow you're done so close he created
everything but not about nerves of Steel
I would have resigned I think after F5
Suddenly It's counter play it's no
longer a two result game
even white could win this if black over
press is without question why
what to do you have to force that draw
that I think you just mentioned there
for the next game over no moves there's
no checks there's no moves no ideas
this is cake this is heartbreaking after
the way things turned around and how
Jordan van Forest did manage to create
his chances in a clutch wind position
and then just rushing with that pawn
move G3 and then it's all over but not
about Queen D4 keeping it precise
keeping it sharp and now the players are
down on the clock the clock is almost
level not if I can feel it he's so close
to taking this one that's why I need to
retire Guys these youngsters they're so
sharp so resourceful you don't just
outplay them and beat them you need to
beat them like 10 times in one game and
how do you finish them off and Greg Shaw
they're saying uh man I really wanted
the Armageddon I think that's all of us
here in the studio yes it would have
been a lot of fun to see these two
incredible Fighters take it down to the
Armageddon but uh so far not the back
looks like he is about to level this
game and with that win the match
the audience realized what he's done
there's simply no hope now no checks no
tricks
white white is the one with threats
okay he plays this uh Rook move trying
to enter threatening Queen F1
threatening to bring it I think you have
to take on F3 or you literally lose on
the spot actually it's that bad you have
no other moves and of course you lose
the match on the spot if you make a draw
no that's it it's an open situation for
Jordan Rook F3 if that's the best option
to try to get a Perpetual check in this
is indeed match over and Jordan really
trying to find a way to keep things
going and the problem here Daniel is it
that white is simply threatening to take
on E7 and you're made on G7 and black
just says no no mating constructions
maybe 96 can be tried that's what I
would play Give in Jordan's situation
okay it takes an F3 can't blame him for
that as long as Notre Beck
side steps all the forks and there's
nothing to sidestep he just literally
only moves cleaning G4 Queen E2 check
and King F5 maybe possible but I think
he's just gonna go King H3 okay H3 and
make the draw talking roll yeah
I think King F5 loses there by fourth
after a series of checks but oh yeah
it's calculated at all
don't need to be a genius to see that
line
AR genius to know white will Retreat the
king to safety and make the draw and uh
win the match whoa King F7 was there a
knight D3
Queen D5 King F6 and queen D4 King E6
and you dodge the checks so wait a
second oh but Queen h8 might be the way
to like force black it to giving a bunch
of checks I don't know also looking at
Queen takes D6 and does black have more
than just a Perpetual check there dang
no Queen D6 oh
it's all because that night a Black
Knight on C5 it's far away from White's
King it just put that on the king's side
and you're talking a different tune
there but Knight on C5 unable to give a
single check the queen is just not
enough to deliver anything more than a
perpetual
yeah I think this check is uh maybe the
safest the simplest I was just wondering
about Queen takes trying to use the pin
but uh yeah this one would have been
fine too wow okay he finds a safer one
he gave a series of checks the Queens
are coming off the board no winning
chances for black even with a knight
such a good piece here you can
recentralize it but uh simply you're
never going to create passport
Heartbreaker that one that is the final
blow that Queen trade wow that was a
very practical decision there but not
the back just going for this end game
and once you see that you grab it faster
than a college student grabs a free
donut like you just take that Queen
straight and run with it because you
know you're never gonna lose this end
game yeah
it's not nothing to try for
and there we have it not the back of the
Statue of takes the match against Jordan
van Forest what an incredible fight this
was a disappointing end for Jordan after
a fantastic turnaround in that King's
Indian defense he's smiling he knows
he's done it all and nodded back there
as well with a smile both players have a
lot to be proud about with the kind of
fight that they put up in this big match
entertaining classy chess David what was
the highlight actually the Highlight for
me was nordeback Abdul satoroff's
defensive play it was with that Resolute
defense that he was able to clinch the
match Jordan had created winning chances
and in this position he had already won
a pawn with black white king out in the
open and maybe it was just the
technician to win a second Pawn that
caught him on his heels here that really
tripped him up in his winning attempts
if he had left that pawn on the board
then the black king feels much safer on
the light squares there's never going to
be any checks on this diagonal black
could simply have give him a check
himself and the attack would have been
decisive if the white king sidesteps the
black Rook could join the action
crashing down now on F2 if the white
king had stepped back then the same idea
that Jordan actually played in the game
would have been even stronger Here pawn
to G3 this white king is not going to
survive the combined might of Black's
Army in the end just one careless move
that was suddenly counter play and Noddy
back guided it towards the draw
what an amazing play that was just
keeping everything under control after
that Miss by Jordan van Forest we've had
such an incredible day of Chess we
didn't get an army gun but we got four
extremely fighting rapid games and uh
for Jordan van Forest he does get get
knocked down to the losers bracket not
the back of the satrobe he continues his
run in the Winner's bracket and we do
have not a bag joining us
and what a game that was the last one we
are waiting for him and here he is
congratulations
thank you
it was a crazy match all four games just
so much entertainment for us how are you
feeling while playing was it up and down
yeah it was crazy match and there were a
lot of mistakes I think and
yeah I was a little bit maybe lucky that
I
I survived in the last game but uh
overall uh I I think we played a very
good match and
yeah it was very tough Death Match
indeed
um
yeah I'm looking forward for the finals
yeah we're so excited to watch you play
in the finals we're not back I want to
just talk about the games a little bit I
want to start from game two there was
this moment and I see your expression
and I think you know what I'm talking
about
yes yeah exactly yeah
um yeah I played Queen F3 but uh
honestly I I didn't uh my plan was like
playing D6 and since the game
uh so after he played F5 I just
immediately played D6 because this was
my initial plan I just didn't see Rook
F2 and yeah it was some kind of uh yeah
it was some illusion that uh I'm getting
mated but uh yeah
basically that was it yeah
and did you uh did you realize that you
missed that moment while
the game was on or
wards
after this game I just realized that I
can take it
all uh turned out well in the end but
even the final game
everything was under control but then
Jordan he's so good at this he managed
to create his chances
yeah he created a very messy position
um yeah I of course I I missed F5
uh I totally missed this idea of
trapping my Bishop on F3 and yeah I I I
was very lucky to
to play E3 and uh I have this queen A1
trick to coordinate my pieces otherwise
it would have been just uh
uh just I was just getting a crushed
there if not Queen A1 then then okay
um he could have played uh Queen E4
check instead of
queen queen takes D5 I guess with the
idea of Rook f8 or G3
which is I think stronger but uh
yeah I mean it's it's very tough uh in
kind of tense
tense situation yeah I mean basically
you just grabbed the opponent uh
uh yeah after that I I just hold the
game
yeah you played flawlessly after that uh
not a bag in the studio we were also
discussing about the history with uh
Jordan man Forest now you guys have
played some amazing chess in the past as
well and I know it was a difficult
moment back at the Tata steel Masters
the final run was this a bit of a grudge
match for you
consider it like as
as a something dramatic
she's lost that game because he played
better than me and uh
yeah he just outplayed me there and uh I
I wasn't uh of course I was very upset
not winning the tournament but I wasn't
very upset about the game
uh yeah yeah today I managed to to beat
him but uh yeah I think we can I think
he has still chance to play in the
finals so yeah we'll see are you might
have a rematch but tomorrow you've got a
day off while the players fight it out
in the elimination bracket what's the
plan
um yeah have a I mean I'm enjoying time
here and uh yeah also preparing and yeah
just just have a walk and uh to
to go say I think maybe there is a a
beautiful place here I think nearby so
yeah I will I will go there and I will
have a rest
all the other bracket the action on to
see who you will be playing in the Grand
Final
of course but uh until then maybe I will
have a
I will I will rest
I wish you a really good rest and before
you go we got a little surprise for you
we had a joint competition for uh chess
kids and we want to show you one of the
the Young Artists they actually do you
and not in fact this is
this is yeah very nice very nice
it was one of the winning paintings it
was you know what I thought was really
amazing was the
what's the matter
was the Madeline around I it reminded me
of the Chennai Olympiad
yes
quite nice
memories yeah we've been just having
these amazing drawings of all of you
being sent and thank you so much you're
such a sport and we're so excited to see
you in the Grand Final enjoy your rest
day
thank you bye-bye
all the best
wow not about that reacting at uh the
Arts that we received earlier it's just
so awesome and so cute the kind of
drawings that we've been seeing come in
and these are the brackets while not
back up to such a gets a day off in the
Winner's bracket we will be seeing
action in the loser semi-final last
Fabiano caruana takes on shoes musad and
the winner will play against Jordan as
not a back said Jordan Barn Forest might
actually come back to face him in the
Grand Final David yeah we've actually
seen that twice already this season the
player losing the winners final is able
to retrace their steps fight their way
back and get a second shot at the price
so uh don't be surprised if we see a
rematch of today's Final
just amazing incredible stuff there and
more action coming up Daniel what did
you make of uh what we witnessed in the
the final game for just amazing action
all the way I mean Jordan is in such
good form this tournament and again he's
got another chance he's just gotta rest
I know who he would more rather face
between karawana and Joe musard pretty
complicated question I think it is Jewel
moussard so he's got some time to rest
Notre back though he is the future he is
incredible he's Universal and just the
way that he handled that after he
committed the mistake after he allowed
F5 that was the most impressive bit to
me the way he just calmed himself down
and then found 15 perfect moves to pull
out the draw and make his way into the
Grand Final
a very well deserved break there after
all the action that we saw from
noribbeck of this art drop we've seen so
we've had so much fun today the chess
was fantastic starting from the
elimination bracket up to the Winner's
bracket we had the drawing competition
saw some amazing fun artwork there and
not just that it doesn't stop here we've
got a really really fun segment coming
up tomorrow we're gonna reveal that
tomorrow but here's a little teaser
David Howell went to London and the
chess kids did challenge him to a school
test David it was a lot of fun
what's the capital of Guyana
[Music]
two times two what year did Queen
Boudicca die I think of an entry
what are the effects of the black death
and where did it originate from what do
all the coordinating conjunctions put in
a certain order spell out I want you to
clearly explain how you find out the
percentage of a certain number clearly
[Music]
that was fun to watch I'm still
traumatized kids are too clever these
days so what can I say
for all the chess kids out there
at this on chess kid it is the coolest
most fun platform to start your chess
journey and the chest Journey does
continue in the chess get cup we do have
not Evac Abdul satra who's made his way
into the Grand Final and we'll find out
who challenges him to win the chess kit
cup we will be back with all the action
tomorrow see you then
[Music]
Harry the H1 is alive she's blundered
the white king can now creep forward two
seconds one second he has to make a move
no moves
let's go King's Indian let's go we got
one finally bro E4 or you're dead
I'm dead
Jordan in absolute disbelief
oh my God we live we're going down again
not a back of the soccer takes the match
against the Jordan van Forest
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]